thank you
hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel in this session we will
learn Microsoft Excel and they get
started I would like to take a quick
confirmation from our viewers if my
screen
my audio is clearly Audible
if yes kindly type yes in the chat
section if not please do let us know in
my section and we will solve it as early
as possible
great I see a lot of positive responses
from our viewers it gets cleared to get
started caption full text and you're a
tech geek into technology instead of
getting subscribe Channel and don't
forget to hit that Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn now
without further Ado let's dive into the
agenda for today's discussion at first
we will go into the Excel basic
knowledge where we will understand some
fundamentals of excel about filters Etc
then we will get into the column
operations which will have adding and
eliminating the columns in Excel and how
to summarize some elements in Excel
similarly through operation in Excel
then we will get into the spreadsheet
fundamentals where we will understand
how to lock a spreadsheet or password
protect your spreadsheet Etc then we
will dive deep into filters operations
in Excel and followed by filters we will
understand AutoFill in Excel and how to
add watermarks in Excel insert PDF image
in Excel once we are done with the
fundamentals we will dive into using
some critical functionality such as
adding slicers into Excel sum of
functions in Excel which is the
conditional form of using some function
in Excel then we will understand the
goalsake fundamentals in Excel data
cleaning for your data before analyzing
your data then converting numbers
towards sorting data for your
spreadsheet standard deviation how to
calculate standard deviation then age
and time differences in Excel wave will
understand the fundamentals of
calculating age calculating time
difference Etc then we will also
understand date oriented operations in
that same segment followed by that we
will understand how to calculate
percentage and average in Excel so after
this followed by that we will get into
the print page setup where we will
understand the page set of
functionalities and page break
functionalities in Excel then the Dax
functionality is Pivot tables where we
will understand how to create pivot
tables Etc then we have various charts
which we will be using for data
visualization in Excel then we have some
lookup function Excel the latest v-stack
function in Excel and how to add High
links in Excel and finally people try to
understand how to recover the unsaved
folders or visualizations in Excel and
to make things interesting we will also
discuss some of the important shortcuts
in Excel with that we are clear with the
agenda now over to our training experts
now let's look at a scenario here so one
day in a startup
One Professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague response
well we can make use of Microsoft Excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to their business needs
now
the colleague response well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question says let's go ahead with
Excel and let's train our employees in
Excel
and
the suggestion is welcomed which would
make the job easier for them
and they would basically decide on using
Excel so they decide on taking a
training right away and basically
starting to learn Excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use Excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so Excel proves to a be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days various
features in Excel like searching sorting
filtering makes it easier for you to
play with the data and Excel also allows
you to beautify your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and Analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
Excel also provides good security for
your data Excel files have the feature
of password protection this way your
information can be safe
now when we talk about what is Excel and
how it can be used so Excel or you might
have heard a spreadsheet can be
basically used for lot of different
tasks than just storing the information
in so-called tabular format
now Microsoft Excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in Excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a small tour to understand how to
work with Excel now to do that what we
can do is we can type in in our search
say for example Excel and just select
your Excel app which is installed and
here you see you have lot of options
which says take it over drop down list
get started with formulas make your
pivot table going forward with pie
charts and much more so we can click on
this one which says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to Excel and if you
have always wanted to be better at Excel
you have this which can help you so
let's click on Create and that takes us
to the store window now that says
instructions for screen readers which
basically talks about 10 different steps
in which we can learn Excel and using
the spreadsheet app so there are more
than 11 sheets which we see here at the
bottom end and each one gives us a
simple example which we can work on so
for example if I click on ADD now that
takes me to this page which says how do
we add numbers now you might be provided
data which we can upload by loading a
file from our machine or getting data
from a web Source or even connecting to
a database so there are various options
which we will see in some time so here
we have an option which is called Data
you can click on this one and this
basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from SQL
Server from analysis services from odata
data feed you can get in from XML from
data connection Wizard or also from
Microsoft query you can be running in
different queries here which shows up in
the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use and
that basically will display all the
connections for this particular workbook
which we do not have as of now but we
can create them but let's look at simple
examples now you can follow these
instructions here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is from
which row to which row you would want to
add add the data so for example I could
just do a sum here and that shows up all
the different functions which are
available then we can open up a
parenthesis and we can say I would be
interested in totaling the amount
from
column D and I would select for example
D4 so I could be doing this and then I
could say D4
onwards till d 7 so that's the data
which I'm interested in you can close
your parenthesis and hit enter and that
gives you the total there is also a
shortcut for this which you can always
do is we can first delete this and you
can just place your cursor here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime expand or basically
collapse so I will basically select this
which says this function needs two
numbers which is number one and number
two and then you can hit on enter and
that gives you the total so similarly we
can be getting in the data here by
selecting all the fields so here it also
says that you can use a shortcut now
what we can also do is we can add
numbers over 50 by selecting the yellow
cell here and then giving a condition
such as so I can basically use something
like sum if and then open a parenthesis
I can select I would be interested in
this row and then I can even drag and
drop
till here so that tells me the 11 to the
15 you can then put in a comma here and
you can give your condition say for
example we would say I would be
interested in numbers only above 50 and
we can select this
close your codes and then just close
your parenthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here I could select this now
there is also an option I can click on
home and I can go for something like
Auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and I can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then I can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum F Formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically select all the numbers which
are lesser than 100 so the way we did
earlier here that can be always a
shortcut so you can always for example
if you would want to avoid typing in the
formula you can always copy it from here
and then just hit on enter so you are
back into this cell and then I can
basically go here and paste the number
and then as per the requirement we are
required to select anything which is
lesser than 100 so what I could do is I
could select here I could say let's say
G and then I can change this value to
g15 and that's one more way now we see
our selected rows have been changed so I
can hit on enter and I can check what is
the result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so I will have to also change
this one to a lesser sign and that
basically gives me the total which is
160. so that's how you can simply add
numbers you can use autosum you can type
in the formula you can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum and then
you can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your cells within your Excel sheet
now here we have an option which says
100 now we can click on this and that
basically says it is making a sum of
column C4 to D4 so if I click on this
one I can check that this is row number
four which shows up here and I also know
this is column C I also have D so this
equals is basically giving me a sum of
C4 to D4 now what we can do is we can
always place our cursor here at the
right corner and then we can just drag
and drop and this basically gives me a
total of all the numbers for all
different rows so this is one shortcut
which we can do to get the total Excel
will automatically give the totals which
we call as filling down now what we can
do is in the same way if we would want
to get the totals here we can first
check what is this 200 and this tells me
this C11 to c14 total so it is totaling
the rows from C11 so column C and 11th
row till 14th row and that's the sum now
what I can also do is I can similarly
like above we can do a filling right
which basically means bringing your
cursor here and then just dragging and
dropping it all the way where you would
need the totals and this basically gives
me the total there is one more quick way
to check if this is right so the easiest
option would be to select this cell now
what I can also do is I can just select
all of these fields by just highlighting
and selecting all the fields once it is
selected press on Ctrl R and that gives
you the total now if we would be doing
this stop down then I could select all
these rows for this particular column
and then I could do a control D so
that's your filling down and this one
was filling right so this is an easier
option of doing a fill when you would
want to have the formula applied to
every row as it occurs in the first row
or the last row we could test this by
for example selecting these fields I
could delete them and I have here which
says 130 I could just place my cursor
here and I could drag it all the way up
and that should also do the same Magic
which we were seeing from top down so
this is a simple way wherein you can
fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate or move your computation to
all the cells
let's look at the split option which
basically helps us in splitting the data
when we have some kind of pattern or
when we have some kind of delimiters in
our data in say one particular column
and we would want to derive the values
out of it so we can always use the
splitting option now the easiest option
would be so for example we have our
email column which has the email IDs and
which we can clearly see has a first
name dot last name now I see that there
is a last name Smith filled up here
first name is empty so what I can also
do is I can just type in say Nancy here
now that's the first name I can again
start typing in the second name and as
soon as you do that you would see a
faded list of numbers and that's your
clue to hit enter and once you do that
you would see all the first names have
been filled in here if you would want to
maintain the case sensitiveness you can
just go ahead and delete these and let's
type in as it occurs so let's say Nancy
as the first name go down to the next
cell and just type in Andy and there is
your grade list so just hit on enter and
that basically fills up your first name
what we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now I can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking Ctrl Z and that's basically
gone what I can also do is I can select
a particular field and then I can go
into home option and under home you have
an option here which says fill so you
can select this and then you can do a
Flash Fill which is what we are doing
here so click on Flash Fill and that
automatically fills up the values so in
this way you can work within your
spreadsheet and you can be filling up
the values where a delimiter by default
is understood and we can split the data
now however sometimes you might have
some data which has a different kind of
delimiter and there is again a smarter
way of splitting your data so you can
always scroll down here and that says
splitting a column based on delimiters
so we have some values in the data
column and these values in each row are
separated by comma so
select this your data is already
selected text to columns delimited comma
selected and now click on next so it
basically says what is the destination
let's select this one
and I can choose what would you want to
have so that shows me this would be my
GitHub preview now I can basically
select this one I can say finish and say
okay and now if you see our data has
been placed in in the columns
appropriately so this is how you can
split your data based on a delimiter and
then organize your data in a better way
now there are some Advanced options
which we can learn later but this
basically tells about using a formula so
this is something if say if we have some
name in one cell and if you would want
to split it into first name your helper
column your middle name last name so
that can also be done using formulas and
this basically tells how would you
extract characters from your left cell
and how would you place them in your
right cell so you can try this activity
which is a little more of advanced
option the benefit is that you can
always use this
wherein if you do some kind of
transformation using your formulas if
your original data gets updated then the
split data will also get updated and
that's the benefit of using formulas
where you can place values from one cell
into multiple cells based on execution
of your details in the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your X and Y axis or as I would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and I would say two rows now I
can select all of these and then I can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt V that's a
shortcut what you can also do is once
you have selected all your Fields you
can just copy them so just do a Ctrl C
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special and once
you do that you need to select the
transpose option over here and click on
OK and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as a mount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed in this particular
format now there is another way of doing
that and again that's using your
formulas so what you can do is you can
transpose with a formula also and that
basically works when you have similar
kind of data so this has six columns and
basically two rows so you can basically
do this so you can select this and
earlier we were doing a copy but now
what we would want to do is we would
want to just look at the row numbers
which tells me it is c33 c34 and it
starts with c and ends in with your H
column so what we can do is we know that
we have six columns and two rows so
transposing that would actually give me
two columns and six rows so what we can
do is we can select two columns and six
rows in our Excel sheet I can then
basically start typing in the message or
I can just go to the address bar and
here I can say
transpose
let's go for c33
h34 it basically selects my data and now
I can just do a control shift and enter
and now if you see all the values have
been populated now you can just place
your cursor in one of the cells but if
you see the address bar the formula
Remains the Same this is because this is
an array formula so we can read more
about an array formula here it's
basically something which performs
calculations and on more than one cell
in an array and in the example here the
array is the original data that is c33
to h34 so your transpose is just
changing the horizontal orientation to
the vertical orientation so this is a
very simple way in which you can
basically use the excel's capability to
transpose your data and convert your
rows into to columns and columns into
rows apart from working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data sorting the data or basically
splitting your data transposing your
data one of the other requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how Excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so let's check that
the thousand hundred ten thousand the
values then you have Bakery which should
ideally be the first row if we sort it
in alphabetical order which goes with
Bakery as desserts you have the values
so we can check this again so select
department and then just do a sort and
filter and let's say sort A to Z and if
you see the data has changed but it's
not just in changing your First Column
but then it has taken care of all the
data however the data has been sorted
based on the department column so you
have Bakery which aligns with deserts
which has the values and now we have all
the data which has been filtered now
what we can also do is we can sort
December's amounts from largest to
smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the December
column let's say 20 000 and then what I
can do is I can go into sort filter and
then I can say sort largest to smallest
so if you see Bakery breads is the row
which has the smallest data or might be
you have Delhi sandwiches so that one
looks also smaller so let's do a larger
to smallest and if I do this you would
see the values have been shifted now so
it is no more based on the department
column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the December
column and you see Bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes based on
the values these are all string values
or words so it sorts alphabetically if
you have numbers might be you can give
some values and you can sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select if you would
want to select the data so I could do a
custom sort and then I could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the Sorting
needs to be done is it cell values is it
cell color font color conditional
formatting and then you can also choose
the order so that's one more way to do
that now if you scroll down that also
shows how you can sort by date or a
color so for example if you would want
to sort based on the expense date so
there are different options so what I
can do is I can select this date field I
can just do a right click I can go into
sort and then I can choose I would want
to sort oldest to newest so since I
selected the date field it basically has
sorted all the data and it has taken the
expense date into consideration now
there are these filters which you see on
the row headings we could have also used
those so I could have selected this and
that basically says or mentions which
are the dates I would be interested in
looking at I also have sort by color
here I can do a sort oldest or newest or
newest to oldest so I could also use
these filters which have been applied
here now we have the data which is in
color so if I would want to basically
select the color columns or color cells
I could select this I can basically do a
right click here and when I go into sort
I could choose put selected color or
cell color on the top and that basically
will make sure that my data is sorted
and it has also sorted that in a
descending order so in this way you can
sort or or basically filter your data
what we can also do is we can add
filters so sometimes we can go for
formulas which we would want to use what
we can also do is we can basically
select the filter which has been applied
here now how does the filter come in
there so if I would select a particular
row I could select a particular row and
then I could decide if I would want to
just add a filter to this one and that's
how the filter has come in so we have
the filter what we can do is we can
basically click on this drop down and
then you have something like number
filters so we can always go here we can
basically choose one of these so we can
basically choose above average so I
could select this and then basically it
shows me the values we could also delete
the filter by clicking on this one and
we could say well I'm not interested in
this filter anymore
so I could clear the filter and that
shows me all the values or I could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food I can go in here I can go
into number filters and then I could say
well I'm interested in values which are
below average above average might be
greater than and then I can choose what
is the value so for example if we say I
am interested in food which is greater
than 25 dollars I could give a value
here I could say okay and now I have
applied the filter similarly you can
select this and then you can just clear
your filter and your data is back so
remember no data is lost it is just
hidden or basically based on the filter
not shown so that's good enough for us
and in this way you can sort and filter
the data so for more details obviously
in all the sheets you have the links
which point to more information on the
web and you can always refer to these so
this is simple way in which you can sort
and filter any amount of data which has
been stored within your Excel within a
particular sheet now that we have
learned about add fill split transpose
sorting and filtering it will also be
good to learn how to work with tables or
basically converting your data into a
tabular format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in five columns and N
number of rows so I can basically select
this data and then what I can do is I
can insert choose the table option and
then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that I'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learned earlier
how to use and this is basically my
table which is a collection of cells
which has some special features so we
can easily add rows to this table we can
add columns to this table and we can
even do some calculations so for example
here I can click on this one I can
basically enter some field and then I
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example I
would say chocolates
I could give some value here so is 25
000 might be 35
000 and then basically I can given some
values here now what you can also do is
you can continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this option
here in the top bottom right corner you
can just drag it towards the right and
that basically has automatically created
columns for my next months wherein I can
feed in the data so this is a simpler
way wherein you can keep adding more
rows and columns to your data if that
has been converted in a tabular format
now let me just do a control Z that
basically deletes the columns again Ctrl
Z deletes the last row which we added
and I can stop here or I can even remove
my values by doing multiple control Z
and removing my rows so this is how I
converted my data into a table and then
I can easily work on this what I can
also do is I can do some calculations so
what we can do we have a table here we
have a total field and what we can do is
we can just select one cell here now as
we have learned earlier we can do a alt
and then equals and that basically says
what is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum of the last three
months and if that's what you would want
to do just hit on enter and it has
automatically calculated the totals for
all your rows for these three columns so
the sum formula is getting filled up now
I can select any particular cell and I
can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started calculating the sum from the
October column till the December column
and has given me the calculated values
of the columns what we can also do is we
can get total rows in the table now
that's a simpler option so what we can
do is we can select any l in this
particular table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
I can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here and if you would want the
average then we could select this and
from the drop down I can select what I'm
interested in so for example I would
want the average values and not the
total I could just select this and that
gives me the average of these values so
we can always do simpler computations
here by converting our data into table
format let's learn about one more
efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here now say for example
you have this data which has the values
in the food column and department is
empty and say for example you would want
to enter the values in Department
however you would want to select the
department should either have produce or
meet and bakery and these are the only
three options which should be available
for any user to fill in the values how
do we do that so we can basically create
a table by pressing Ctrl D so what I can
do is under my department
here I can select one of the cells and
then I can do a control T that basically
converts this into a table I can say
okay and my table is created now what I
can do is once this part is done
we can select all the blank Fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable now under your data tab you
can go in and select data validation and
this has an option called Data
validation click on this which basically
says allow any value so here I will
select I would want to give a list of
values and then I can type in my values
here which I can say produce
say for example meet and then say Bakery
now these are the values so we can click
on okay
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to Apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so I can go into every cell and
then I can basically choose what is the
department which handles this and then
basically I can select one of these from
the drop down so this is an easier
option of creating your drop down and
then feeding in the values from the set
of values which you have defined here on
the right so this is a simple example of
using your drop downs working with your
tables working with your sort and filter
transpose split filling up your data
adding in some data here and similarly
you can use Excel for more than one use
case using its inbuilt features to
easily work with your data let's see how
we can import data or bring in data into
our Excel from your local machine or
from an external web source so what we
can do is we can open up a blank Excel
sheet and say for example you have been
provided a text file or a CSV file and
you would want to import that data into
your Excel sheet that can be easily done
so right now I've opened an Excel sheet
now I can click on data and here I have
an option which says existing
connections from other data sources so
or you can click on connections if you
have already created some so we can
click on from other sources so this is
one option where you can connect to your
different data sources and you can get
the data from one of these what we can
also do is I can click on connections
now it says there is none I can click on
ADD it says well show the connections
where connection files or Network
connection files on this computer so I
can say let's get some files from this
computer now if that does not show up
something so say browse for more and
that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where I have some data sets I'll
click in here and this is basically a
folder where I have some data sets now
let me select this particular file and I
know it is a CSV file so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a DOT CSV file which is what we
are interested in so I'll take this file
I'll say open now this basically shows
me the text import wizard option which
says is the file delimited I'll say yes
click on next so I will select comma as
my delimiter I can say text qualifier is
none now this is my data so my data
preview is already showing me the data
is what is the data in the CSV file you
can click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is General
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so I'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here so we basically have this and now I
can click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data which we have here the
connection which we have created say
open and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on OK and now this
data is automatically inserted in my
Excel file I can basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what I
can do is I can go into my GitHub and
let's say I would be interested in this
CSV file so I can select this and this
is my GitHub path a path on web so I can
click on draw and that basically gives
me the raw path where this particular
file is now you can select this copy
this particular path and here you can
come back to your Excel sheet we would
be interested in getting the data from
web might be from a text file where we
will have to specify the delimiters or
let's go to web and here I can given the
web path from where I would be
interested in getting the file let's
give the GitHub path which is publicly
available and then click on import now
once you click on import it tells me
that two Fields data and value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on OK and now you have the data
coming in but then this basically shows
me in one particular field so what we
can also do is we can just do a control
a that selects all my columns here and
that's my data so we can then basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next we
can select comma and let the text
qualifier be codes
it shows me data preview click on next
so you have the general format it shows
the destination that's the column click
on finish and now your data has been
split and you have the data which you
have imported from web so this is the
data which is coming in from web this is
the data which came in from my local
machine and similarly we can even create
connection with an existing database so
I can basically click on connections if
I would want to do that so I have an
option called connection here and it
says where the selected connections are
used I can basically click on ADD I can
basically choose if I would want to get
the files from Network or from computer
like we did earlier I can click on
browse for more which should show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new SQL Server Connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place you could basically
choose what kind of connection you would
you want so these are all the different
options which we can go for and we can
basically connect to a database for
example if I have some database and say
for example access database
I can see if there are some files with
that particular database and I can
import it so similarly we can also uh
click in here which says new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders from databases so you can
basically click here and then you can
import data from a mySQL database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web from
your Hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources and then you
can bring it into your Excel so in this
way you can get your data from different
sources into your Excel into your
spreadsheet and then you can continue
working on those data sets
we have already learned some basic
operations which you can do in Excel and
let's Implement our knowledge by working
on this particular data which is coming
in from housing data set now here if we
see some fields we have agent date
listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been sorted
in newest to oldest order of date listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what I can do is I can
just click on data listed and then I can
either go in here I can select sort I
can get into custom sort and then I can
choose the column based on which I would
want to sort the data so I would look
for the newest data to the oldest data
that means that would mean a descending
order of dates or you could say the
oldest state or the earliest month will
be towards the lower side of your sheet
so here we can select date listed now I
can say let it sort based on Cell values
and the order what we have here so we
have newest to oldest so let's select
this I can say OK and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in the state
listed so we have sorted our data into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your date column so the result shows
up here now what we can also do is we
can have different questions which we
would want to answer so for example I
would want to sort the data in ascending
order of area and descending order of
agent name how do we do that so let's
look into this so this is here I already
have the result here and how did I get
this so I'm looking for ascending order
of area and descending order of agent
name so we can start with any particular
column that does not matter so for
example if I look into this Excel sheet
I have my agent name select this which
we want in a descending order so we
could either do a sort and then go for
descending sort Z to A we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or I could just say
sort Z to A and then it has arranged the
data based on the agent column being in
descending order now I can go into area
and then I can again do a sort and I
wanted my area column to be used for
sorting the data and ascending to
descending and that basically not only
changes the order of this particular
column but for my complete data so let's
do that and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so we can see
how many values we have here and the
area values which we see and this is how
you get your result so I'll just do a
control Z and again and I'm back to my
original data and this is the sorted
result which we are seeing at similarly
we can answer other questions for
example sort the data according to the
following order of area that is we are
saying count D
Central and then your county so we can
basically choose in which particular way
we would want to do it so it is County
Central and then again County so if I
look into my G3 so here I basically have
my data which is having some South
County then you have your Central and
then you have your North County so we
would want to sort the data to solar
problem which is according to the
following order so first we go for area
then we go for South County Central and
North County so what we can do is we can
basically
have area field selected and I would
want to sort this particular data so I
have South County Central and North
County so I can basically go for custom
sort
and then I can choose which is the value
or column which I'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like cell
values well you can also try to explore
conditional formatting icon if this is
what you would want to use or we can
basically go for just cell values and
here we can say if I would be interested
in first getting my values for South
County so for example I can say custom
list and then I can basically given the
new list here so I can say s
Dot County
and then I would want Central and then I
would want North County
so let's select this
as it exists we can basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with Kelly you have in the 12th
row something like Lang and that's what
we are doing so we can basically arrange
the data in a particular order by
choosing a custom list and then sorting
your data so that's one more simpler
task what we have done where we have
sorted the data in the order where
under our area column we first wanted
South County then we wanted Central data
and then we wanted North County so this
is how you can do it now let's look into
one more problem so it says find all the
houses in the central area and we would
want to basically apply a regular filter
let's let's see how do we do that so we
can click on this and here we have the
data so the problem statement is we
would want to find all the houses in
Central Area now how do we do that we
can do a sorting but we would want to
use the filter which you see here is
implemented so how do you do it so you
can select this area and say for example
I would want to apply filter I can just
go in here and I can say let's get a
filter on my first row and now I have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the Central Area houses
let's go in here it says all these
fields are selected that means it shows
everything wherein your area has all
these values let's unselect this and
then I will only be interested in the
central so let's say okay and then say
okay so now you see that the area filter
has been applied and we are looking at
the central column so what we have done
is we have applied a simple filter and
we are looking at our data at any point
of time if you do not want the filter
then what I can do is I can select this
and I can say well I'm interested in all
the data so I could do this or you can
clear the filters from area and you get
your data back so that's in one way you
can filter out your data so let's look
at an example of sort and filter where
we might have to filter the data based
on two columns or multiple columns with
different kind of values where it could
be and and or condition now say for
example this is the data I have and this
is the question which we need to answer
such as find the list of all houses in
the central region with pool and South
County without pool now if it was a
simple filter based on one cell I could
have just selected my header row I could
have then applied the filter
and once I have the filter I can look in
area where I have three regions so I'm
only interested in Central and South
County so I can get rid of North County
and that's fine but then we have two
different conditions here so we need the
data in central region to have the value
for pool being true
and for South County the value has to be
without pool now how do we do that so
what we can do is we can first create a
copy of these headers here so let me do
that now the area has to be South County
so basically I can either just select
this and I can choose this value
and then I can select this and then I
can choose Central so that's the
criteria which I have and the pool value
has to be so central region should be
with pool so then this one
basically has to be true
and this one has to be basically false
so south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now to get my result we
can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is M column and
eighth row okay so we would want the
result here so let's go ahead and now
click on data and then in filter you
have an option called Advanced and here
what I can do is I can say I would want
to filter the list in the place but
that's not what I would want to do so
I'll say copy to another location and
here if you see the list range will tell
me that this is the data so A1 to J 126
so a to J column selected and all the
rows
criteria range is basically based on
what I have given here so that is m
from 1
to V which is 3
so I'm selecting these columns and then
I am saying all the way whatever
criteria I have given and cop V8 so that
basically will give me my filtered
result so you could basically just say
okay and now I have my data which has
been filtered and I have my area which
is South County that is without Pool
Central with pool again South County
without pool and then if you look at
your central value that's pool so this
is an advanced filter which we have
applied where simply we have filtered
the data based on two columns and then
we have our result so in this way you
can have your customized filter applied
on two different columns and get your
data which can be either
replacing the existing content or in the
same sheet in different set of columns
and rows you can have your result let's
look at one more example of filtering
where you are trying to filter the data
based on and condition condition being
met in two different columns and then
you would want to filter out the data
for only specific columns so the
situation is the agents with a house in
North County that should be County area
having 2 and a single type family so we
are talking about two bedrooms and we
would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that if
we would want to only populate these
columns which is Agent area bedroom and
type now what you can do is as I
explained earlier that you can get your
result in the same sheet in a different
location and so here I have created
these headers which says agent area
bedrooms and type now this is basically
a copy of all the columns what we have
here agent data listed area list price
bedrooms bath square feet and so on so
you can basically create a copy of the
headers here and this is where we will
give our Advanced criteria to filter the
data so the conditions which need to be
met is we need to look at North County
so for example here in area I can
basically go ahead and select one of the
values North County now the criteria is
having two bedrooms only so let's say
bedrooms and let's say the value should
be 2
and then basically I am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type I
can give the criteria single type so
this is my and condition so we are
saying North County area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if I select this this one tells me
that this is m one row onwards till V
2 so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this so let's go
ahead and then go for data filter
Advanced and here in advanced it says
filter the list in place now that's not
what we would want to do so I'll say
copy to another location this basically
selects the list range so which is
telling me A1
2 J 126 so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on M1 V2 which we have given
here and copy to I would say for example
from M7
2
P 7 now this is the area where I would
this is the place where I want the
result let's say okay and now I get my
data which is based on the question
which has been asked that you would want
the agents with a house in North County
area having two bedrooms and single type
family so in this way you can basically
do Advanced filtering get your data and
get it stored in the sheet anywhere at a
different location well I could have
also done filtering in place and that
would have replaced the data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some Advanced filtering we can
also use Excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say using some numerical
filters now here say for example the
problem statement is that you would want
to display all the houses whose list
price is between
45
000 to 600 000 or say for example we
would want to filter out the data to
something else say for example let's say
I have I would want to filter out the
data between three hundred thousand and
four hundred thousand so we can
basically
update this
say for example I am saying I am
interested in 300
000
to
400. 1000 and that's the criteria to
filter out the data now there are two
different ways or there are two easier
ways to do it one is I would want to
look at the list price so I can select
this I can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so I
could basically select this I could say
I am looking for Value which is greater
than or equal to three hundred thousand
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if I just do this I have applied
my filter and I have my data which is
filtered based on my criteria right so
that's one easier way of doing it or let
me do a control Z
now let the filter be there which you
can anyways use but what we can also do
is as we have seen earlier methods so
get a
set or get your column headers here
and then you are giving two columns here
now the only difference between
my
this set of columns which I have one two
three four and then you have 7 and 10
columns and if you see here we have 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where I can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
or condition would lie in a different
line now here I can give this value so I
am looking for listed price being
between 300 000 so I am saying it should
be greater than or equal to 300
000 and then I can say less than or
equal to 400
000 now that's my criteria and then I
need my result here which is in M 7 so
what I can do is once I have given my
criteria which I'll be using to filter I
can get into Data I can go ahead into
advanced and then I can say copy to
another location so it is selecting my
A1 to J 126 criteria range is based on
M1 to W 2 and then I would want my
result from this particular column so
let's say okay and now you have your
data filtered out in a different
location in the sheet which has been
filtered based on your and condition so
you can filter out the data in this way
or you could just apply a filter on a
column and give the conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
Excel where we would have an and and an
or condition so say for example this is
the data given to you and the question
is that you would want to find all the
houses in North County again that's a
spelling mistake but then they are North
County area with a list price greater
than 300 000 and having three or four
bedrooms so the bedroom has conditional
so it has R 3 and 4 and then basically
you have list price which is greater
than 300 000 now I could have obviously
selected The Columns and then basically
gone for a filter so I can just do a
filtering here and then I'm looking for
list price being greater than 300 000 so
which we can always give a number filter
and I can say great greater than and
then I can say greater than or equal so
I can say greater than and then I can
give 3030 300 000 and that's basically
the filter which we would want and here
I would want to select the bedrooms
which should be just either three or
four so if for example here I go in here
and I unselect this and then I say 3 and
4 right so I am getting my data which is
greater than 300 000 and it should have
the bettering values which will be
either 3 or 4 selected now that's one
way of doing it let's do a control Z and
get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
hear
give the criteria
so for example I have my list price now
this is what I would want as a condition
so let's say greater than
three hundred thousand
300 000 and bedrooms should be three
and then I can say greater than 300 000
and then I can say 4 so this one
basically gives me a situation where
your list price has to be greater than
300 000 and bedroom should be either
three or four so we have given our
filtering criteria now to get the result
what we can do is we can go into Data we
can go into advanced and we can say copy
to another location so our list range is
selected which is columns a to J row
number 1 to 126 your criteria range is
given in M1 to V3 where we have
specified and we are saying the result
would be in M 7 to V7 so if I do this
now I have got the same data which we
were seeing earlier and here the bedroom
values are three or four and basically
the list price is greater than 300 000.
so this is a simpler way in which you
can create your filters and all this
Advanced filtering what we are seeing it
it will be saved with your sheet you can
always go back and change this value or
you could do filtering where one person
has to look into the filter to see what
values have been selected now let's
understand what is a formula in Excel
in Microsoft Excel a formula is an
expression that operates on values in a
range of cells all formulas in Excel
written a result even when the result is
an error
there are different ways to handling
errors which we'll see later formulas
allow you to perform basic calculations
such as addition subtraction
multiplication and division
you can also find out percentages and
average for a range of cells manipulate
date and time and lots more
now let me open an Excel spreadsheet and
show you what a formula is
so here I have my Excel worksheet
now let's see
I have some values under this a column
say 20 30 and 40.
now
I want to write a formula that will add
the values that are present from cell A1
to cell A3 so I'll give an equal to sign
and give my
cell range that is E1 plus E2 plus A3
now if I hit enter it will give me the
addition of 20 plus 30 plus 40 which is
90.
now let's say
I want to divide
for T by 30
if I hit enter it will give me the
division of 40 by 30 which is 1.33 now
let's see what a function is in Excel
when you're working in Excel you will
often hear the terms formula and
function used frequently and sometimes
interchangeably
they are closely related but not exactly
the same technically the formula is an
expression that begins with an equal
sign functions are used to perform
complex calculations that cannot be done
manually functions have names that
reflect their intended use
now let me take you back to the Excel
sheet
and I'll show you what a function is
suppose
now I want to add
the values ranging from A1
to A4
either you can use a formula like we did
here we wrote a formula using multiple
addition operator but there is another
way which you can use
that is to write a function
so Excel provides a function called sum
that allows you to select a range of
cells so I'll select E1 to A4
and close the bracket and if I hit enter
it will return me the result of 20 plus
30 plus 40 plus 90 which is 180.
similarly there are other functions
let's say I want to find the average of
a range of cells so you can use the
average function to do that
if I hit tab it will auto complete I'll
select the same range of cells from A1
to E4 and close the bracket if I hit
enter it will return me the average of
these selected cells which is 45. now
that you have understood the basics of
formulas and functions in Excel let's
dig deeper into learning the different
types of functions available in Excel
and use relevant formulas when needed
along the journey on your screens you
can see we have a mathematical functions
worksheet where we will learn the
different mathematical functions present
in Excel
let's begin at looking at the simple
table
that has three columns the quantity
column price per unit and total sales
now let's find the product of quantity
and price per unit to get the total
sales value for that we will write a
formula using the multiplication
operator so here I'll write the formula
I'll give an equal to sign I'll select
the first quantity
multiplication operator and then select
my price per unit
and if I hit enter it will give me the
product of quantity and price per unit
so 10 into 30 is 300 now to copy that
formula I will just drag this down
you can see we have all our total sales
values now
if you want to find the sum of total
sales
you can use the sum function so here
I'll write equal to then use the sum
function I'll open the bracket then I'll
select my total sales values close the
bracket and I hit enter
it will give me the total sales or the
sum of sales
similarly
if you want to find the average of total
sales
you can use the average function so I'll
type average and hit tab it will auto
complete
I'll select my sales values
close the bracket if I hit enter it will
give me the average total sales now
there's another function called sum
product that is available in Excel you
can use the sum product function to
return the sum of the product of
corresponding ranges or arrays
so let's find the total sales using the
sum product function
the first array we will have the
quantity values while the second array
will have the price per unit
so I'll
select my sum product function
my first array I'll give the quantity
values I'll give a comma
and I'll select my second array that is
price per unit I'll close the bracket
hit enter you can see we have the total
sales value that is
1165. now moving ahead let's understand
the types of logical functions in Excel
and how you can use it
to the extreme left you can see there
are a number of logical functions I have
noted here so you have is even function
Resort function is logical and so on
now let's use them one by one and see
how it works
there is even function returns true if
the given number is an even value and it
returns false if it's not an even number
so we have here two numbers 4 and 13
now
if I want to check if 4 is an even
number or not I can use the A7 function
so I'll give equal to sine
and type is even
and I'll select this number or the cell
close the bracket if I hit enter it will
return true because 4 is an even number
similarly if I have to check for 13
I'll write is even
and select the cell which is A3 close
the bracket
I'll hit enter it will return false
because 13 is not an even number
similarly
the is odd function returns true if the
given number is odd and it returns false
if it's not an odd number so let's check
if 4 is an odd number or not
so I'll write is odd
tab
then I'll select this cell
close the bracket hit enter it returns
false because 4 is not an odd number
similarly
let's check for 13 I'll write is odd
select A7 which has 13
I'll hit enter it returns true because
13 is an odd number now
next we have the is logical function
this logical function returns true if
the given value is a logical value and
it returns false if it's not a logical
value
when I say logical value I mean true or
false now let's check if 30 is a logical
value or not
so I'll write equal to is logical
let's select 30
if I hit enter it returns false because
30 is not a logical number
similarly let's check for the next two
values
I'll select this cell value which has
true in it
if I hit enter it returns true because
true in itself is a logical value
similarly false should also return true
because it's a logical value
you can see it here then we have is
number function that returns true if the
given value is a number
could be integers floating values or
whole numbers now we have a number here
which is 40.5 let's verify if it's a
number or not so I'll write equal to
then select is number
select the cell close the bracket hit
enter it returns true
similarly you have to check if 30 is a
number or not
you can use the same function which is
is number
select 30 close the bracket hit enter it
returns true because 30 is also a number
now
in the next cell we have a text value
you can see it's CNN so ideally it
should return false because CNN
is not a number there you go it has
returned false because CNN is a text
value and not a number now let's explore
a few other functions that you can see
here so the round function rounds a
number to a specified number of digits
so suppose I want to round up
35.316 to 2 decimal places so I'll write
equal to
and I'll give the round function
I'll provide my number 35.316
comma since I want to round up to two
decimal places I'll give two
I'll close the bracket if I hit enter
it gives me the rounded value of 35.316
which is 35.32 now the round down
function rounds a number down towards 0.
so let's see
I'll give the round down function
and I'll provide the same number that is
35.316
let's say
I want to round down to two decimal
places
if I hit enter the result is 35.31
similarly the round of function rounds a
number up away from 0 so I'll write
round up
I'll give my number 35.316
if I give the number of digits say 2
it will return
35.32 so it rounds up this value moving
ahead
now if you want to convert a number into
integers you can do that using the int
function
so suppose I want to convert 35.316 into
integers I can
give my integer function that is int
and provide by number 35.316
close the bracket if I hit enter
so you have the integer value of this
floating Point number
similarly if you want to find the
integer of say equal to int let's say a
negative number minus 35.316
it will return the negative integer
value that is minus 36.
now the truncate function truncates a
number to an integer by removing the
decimal of fractional part of a number
so let's say I want to truncate 35.316
I'll write
trunk which is the truncate function
now let me pass in my number that is
35.316 let's say I want to do the number
of digits as 2
I close the bracket hit enter it returns
me
35.31 so it has truncated the last digit
now similarly
if I
if the number of digits as 1 the result
will be 35.3
you can see it here moving ahead
the ceiling function rounds a number up
that is to the nearest multiple of
significance so I'll show you what it
means I'll use equal to then pass in my
ceiling function
I'll give my number 35.316
if I give say 2
close the return Smith 36 because the
nearest highest multiple of this number
is 36. similarly if I give
let's say 5 it will return 40 because
the nearest highest multiple of this
number to 5 is 40.
now
talking about the floor function
the floor function rounds a number down
to the nearest multiple of significance
so for example if I
use the floor function
the same number
35.316 now let's say I want to give the
significance as 2 it will return 34 the
nearest lowest multiple of this number
that is divisible by 2 is 34.
now if you want to change this number
from 2 to let's say we want to give us 7
if I hit enter it will give 35 because
35 is the nearest
multiple of 7 next let's talk about an
important function called subtotal now
subtotal Returns the subtotal in a list
or database the sub maximum minimum sum
and others let's explore a few of this
let's see
I want to use subtotal function
and let's say I want to find
average you can see here one is for
average I'll give one comma
I'll give my reference
this quantity column values
close the bracket if I hit enter
will give me the average of the selected
cells from
E2 to E4 now
let's say I want to find the subtotal
and this time I want to let's say I want
to count so I'll give 2 comma
I'll count all the values present in the
selected cells
from E2 to G4 and close the bracket hit
enter it returns me 9 you can see there
are nine cells that are filled in here
next let's say this time I want to find
the subtotal and let's take some now so
I'll give 9 comma
let's sum up the price per unit column
so F2 to F4 close the bracket hit enter
you can see the sum of price per unit is
105.
now let's do one more
use the same subtotal function
now let's say I want to find the maximum
value
from the sales column select my total
sales column
close the bracket
write enter returns me 480 because
that's the highest or the maximum value
of total sales
now Excel provides a factorial function
called fact so if you want to find the
factorial of a number you can use this
function
so find out the factorial so I'll use
the fact function
let's say I want to find the factorial
of number 5
I'll close it
can see the factorial of 5 is 120
similarly if you want to find the
factorial
of let's say the number 7
it returns me 1 0 4 0. moving on now you
can use the Max and Min function to find
the maximum and minimum values in a
range of cells so I'll use the max
function let's say I want to find the
maximum from price per unit you can see
it has returned me the value that is 40.
similarly you can use the Min function
I'll use the same column price per unit
now you can see the minimum value from
price per unit column is 30. Excel also
has a function called Rand between that
returns a random number between the
numbers you specify so if you want to
Generate random numbers you can use 5
Square the result should be 25 you can
see it here
now I want to find the power of 4 raised
to 4
the result is 256. moving ahead the
Midas function or the mod function
Returns the remainder when a number is
divided by a divisor so let's see how to
use it I'll use the mod function
and give my number 10
let's divide 10 by 3 the result is 1.
now we have a few other numbers let's
try them also
use mod 12 let's say I want to divide 12
by 4
the result is 0 bit 9 similarly let's
see one more
I'll use the count function now let's
see I'll select from G1 to G4 if I close
the bracket hit enter it returns Me 3
because total sales the first cell value
is not a number it's a character value
hence it's skipped the count of total
sales and it counted the remaining cells
now next moving on to count a function
the county function counts the number of
cells in a Range that are not empty so
for example if I use the count a
function now let's say I'll select
from L1 to L4
it has returned Me 3 because we had an
empty cell so it skipped that count and
it counted the remaining cells that were
non-empty similarly let's use the
function once more and type count a now
let's say I'll select from L2 to n 4
close the bracket hit enter it gives me
5 because we have only five values that
are dels are empty so it skipped that
count moving ahead we have the count
blank function now as the function
suggests it counts the number of blank
or empty cells in a specified range of
so if I use count blank and let's say
I'll select this range from L1 to L4
close the bracket
you can see it has returned 1 because we
had one empty cell
in this range of cells now let's do one
more count blank
I'll select
from L2 to n 4
close the bracket it has returned 4
because we you can see it here we have
three blank cells here's a total four
hence it has returned 4. up next
we have the and function
the and function checks if all the
conditions or arguments are true
it returns true if all the conditions
are true if one of the conditions is
false then and function will return
false let's do this with an example
suppose I
write the and function
so the first argument or the parameter
has to be a logical
condition let's say I'll select from
E2 to E4
and my condition will be
greater than 9 let's say my second
condition
is from F2 to F4
is less than
45 close the bracket hit it returns true
because you can see our first condition
from E2 to E4 all the values are greater
than 9
while the second condition from F2 to F4
all the values are less than 45 so since
both the conditions at one of the values
is not less than 450 you can see we have
a value 480 which is greater than 450
and
our second condition F2 to F4 all the
values are greater than 25 now since one
of the conditions is false so and
function returns false moving on to R
function
the or function checks whether any of
the arguments are true and returns true
if all the arguments do not meet the
condition it will return false so you
have to satisfy all the conditions in
order to return a True Value I'll use
the or function now let's say I'll give
my condition from E2 to E4 greater than
15 comma from F2 to let's say F4 less
than 25 hey close the bracket I hit
enter
it has written me false because both the
arguments are not satisfying the
condition you can see from E2 to E4 none
of the values are greater than 15 and
similarly
from F2 to F4
none of the values are less than 25 now
since both the conditions are false are
or statement false let us take one more
example I'll use the r function again
now the condition will be from G2 to G4
greater than equal to 300 comma let's
say from F2 to F4 less than equal to 40.
I'll hit enter there you go it has
returned us true because both the
conditions are true conceive all the
values between G2 to G4 are greater than
or equal to 300 similarly all the values
from F2 to F4 are less than or equal to
40. now let's get to our second tab
which is character text functions here
we will learn various character
functions and how you can use them in
Excel so first you can see we have is
text function so the is text function
checks if the given value is a text
value and returns true or false so if I
were to check if this value is a text or
not so I can use the is text function
I'll give reference to this cell close
the bracket it returns false because 10
is not a text it's a number similarly
let's check the next one I'll select
cell E3 if I hit enter you can see it
has written true though the value is 10
but still it's a text the reason is you
can see on top we have given an apostop
before writing 10 so I'll show it to you
here in case I write 90 hit enter the
numbers by default are right aligned now
if I give an apost off and then write 90
hit enter it is now a text you can check
that using the x is text function select
the cell close the bracket hit enter it
returns me true so this 90 is a text
value now similarly let's check for the
next one is equal to is text
I'll select this cell hit enter it
returns me true because Excel is a text
value now the next function we have is
the length function
as the name suggests the length function
Returns the number of characters in a
string so it will count the total
characters including spaces as well as
special characters so let's see how many
characters does this string India has
if I hit enter it returns 5 You Can
Count India has in total 5 characters
similarly
let's check
for this sentence
I'll write Len which is the length
function
select this cell close the bracket hit
enter
it returns me 28 because it has counted
the spaces also now this is a function
called text that converts a value to
text in a specified number format so
suppose
I want to convert these date values into
text values in a given number format so
I can write the text function I can give
the value by referencing this cell comma
let's say I want to print the date value
in the form of a text in this format
let's say DD mm and YY close the bracket
you can see it says converted the date
value into ddmm YY now similarly you can
change the date value to text in some
other format like
d d Triple M then 4y and see it returns
30 June
2015.
now if this is a text value or not you
can use the same function that is is
text I'll give reference to the cell
there you go it has written me true
which means it has converted the date
values into text now moving ahead next
we have the replace function the replace
function replaces the part of a text
string within a different text string so
suppose I want to replace cell a 15
value which is a101 I'll give my start
numbers 1
the number of characters let's say one
and my new text I want to replace the a
value with B close the bracket if I hit
enter you can see here a101 has become
B101 because we replace the first a
value to B now let's try out a few more
examples I'll use the replace function
I'll give my old text that is that is
a102 I'll give my start number as 1 my
number of characters as one
let's say the new text I want is A2
close the bracket you can see it here
from our old text which had a it has
replaced with new text that has A2 now
let's say I want to use the replace
function over Adam I'll select this cell
a17 now let's see I the start number is
1 the number of characters is let's say
2 and I want my new character as s a
close the bracket you can see it here
the first two characters from Adam has
been replaced by S A that is what we did
here so we started our start num with
one then we chose the next two
characters that is a d and a d we
replaced it with S A so the name becomes
Sam now moving ahead the next function
we have is substitute the substitute
function replaces existing text with new
text in it text string for example if I
use the substitute function I'll give my
old text which has I work at simply
learn give a comma now I'll select let's
say I work which is from my old text and
I want to replace it with
he works
close the bracket
you can see
The Substitute function has replaced has
replaced the second 2010 from our old
string to 2016. next let's use the
substitute function once again I'll give
the cell reference as e22
this time I want to replace
2010 present in the old text to 2016.
you can see here at two places there
were 2010 it has replaced it to 2016 at
both the places then we have the
concatenate function you can see it here
concatenate means combining strings so a
concatenate function join submerges
several text strings into one text
string here I have two strings hello
and in another cell I have world I want
to concatenate these two strings
so I'll use the
concatenate function I'll select cell
e25
give a comma now I'll give two inverted
commas with a space give another comma
and select cell B25 that has called
close the bracket there you go now it
has concatenated both hello and world
now it's one word hello world similarly
let's concatenate these two cells I'll
use the concatenate function and select
my first cell that has XL is
now you can use an Amber sent to
concatenate as well and then give to
inverted commas for space give another
Ampersand and select the next cell close
the bracket hit enter you can see it has
concatenated
the two cells and it has formed a
sentence Excel is fun to learn up next
we have the repeat function
now repeat function or rept function
repeats text a given number of times you
can fill a cell with a number of
instances of a text string we have some
data here so here let's say these are
the age groups of women and there was a
survey these are the number of
respondents we got from each each group
I want to create an histogram I can use
the repeat function or rept function I
want to give my text as a special
character
and hit a comma and I'll select cell b32
which is the number of times I want to
repeat that character hit enter you can
see it has repeated the special
character 10 times now similarly we can
do it for the next few cells also if I
just copy paste this formula it will
give me the result so you can see it
looks like a histogram now let's say I
want to repeat hashtag and add the rate
symbol for 10 times so I can write the
repeat function give my text as hashtag
and add the rate and the number of times
I want is 10
close the bracket it returns me the
result which has hashtag and at the rate
printer 10 times moving ahead next we
have the type function now the type
function returns an integer representing
the data type of a value now here on the
right you can see suppose the type
function returns 1 it means the value is
a number or it's a blank let's say the
return type is 2 it means the data type
is a text if it's 4 it means the data
type is a logical value that is either
true or false now if it's an error it
will return the value 16 and if it's an
array it will return 64. now let's try
these examples
here we have Excel
which is a text value
so if I use my type function and select
Excel hit enter it returns me true
because Excel is a text value you can
see it here if it's a text it will
return to similarly let's try this one
hundred it has returned me 1 because 1
is a number so it will return me 1
15.45 if I use the type function 15.45
hit enter so it has returned me one now
you can see these are some errors now
it's an error because we have divided a
39 by A40 you can see it here E39 add a
text value and A40 had a numeric value
so you cannot obviously divide a text by
a number so it has written me an error
now if I want to check the type close
the bracket hit enter it has returned me
16 you can see it here if it's an error
value it will return six similarly this
one more error here let's try this out
use the type function give this error
hit enter
this also has returned 16. now let's
check one more example for an array now
you can write an array inside the type
function itself to write an array we use
curly braces I'll give one comma 2 comma
3 and 4 as my array elements
I close the curly braces and the bracket
if I hit enter it has returned me 64.
you can see it here if it's an array it
will return the data type as 64. which
is an array now
there is a function called is blank
which checks if a cell is empty or blank
if it is empty it will return true else
it will return false
now if you were to check
if this cell is empty or not
if I hit enter it turns me true because
you can see it here cell a47
is empty and there's no value in it
now if I want to find out
if Cell e 48 is blank or not if I hit
enter it returns me false because there
is a value for t in it
now we'll see how to use trim function
so the trim function removes all the
unnecessary spaces from a string but it
won't remove the same all the
unnecessary spaces except the space
between Angela and Stevens now I'll copy
paste this value to the remaining cells
you can see it has removed all the
unnecessary spaces from the original
string
now you can check the length once again
for the trimmed string if I hit enter
the length is 15 for our defense you can
see it has removed at least six spaces
from the original string now let's copy
paste this formula it has removed the
unnecessary spaces from all the original
strings next we have the find function
so the find function Returns the
starting position of one string within
another string now you should notice
that find function is case sensitive so
let's use defined function here I'll
write find I want to find where capital
S is located in the cell A52 that has
Angela's defense into the comma select
A52 hit enter it returns me the starting
position that is 11 now if I were to
check using the find function this time
I want to find where small e is located
within A52 which has Angela Stevens I'll
give a comma and I want my start name as
1 close the bracket hit enter it has
written me seven you can count it here
on the top so where the cursor is is the
first position so now keep shifting two
three four five
cell e52 that has Angela's defense
close the bracket hit enter it has
returned me 11.
so basically it has returned me this s
but since search function is case
insensitive so it did not care if it was
an uppercase s or a lowercase s
similarly if I want to find where a is
located or capital A is located in
Antonio minor
I'll use the search function
I want to find Capital a within text
I'll give
cell a54
now let's say I want to give my starting
num as 5.
close the bracket
it has written me 19
so it has written me this a
because the only a that exists after 5
is this
so here also since we searched for
Capital a but it looked for any a that
was present in Antonio minor be it small
or capital
finally we have a clean function
so the clean function returns all
non-printable characters from the text
now you can see here this cell has three
lines of text now if you want to print
this cell in one line I can use the
clean function
it will remove all the non-printable
characters I'll select cell a67 close
the bracket hit enter there you go it is
printed the address in one line now we
have one more text which says I hope you
are doing well during the pandemic
now if I want to clean that cell
close the bracket it has printed the
same sentence in one line now there are
a few more functions let's see them one
by one we have a function called upper
so the upper function converts any text
string into upper case
so we have a string called India now if
I want to convert India into upper case
I'll use the upper function select that
cell you can see it here it has
converted India into uppercase
characters
similarly you can use the lower function
to convert any text string into
lowercase
I'll use the lower function
select that string enter
there you go so all the letters in the
word India has been converted into lower
case now there is another function
called proper which is used to convert
any string into proper case
so I can write a vlooker function
something like this I'll give equal to
search for vlookup
now my lookup value will be stored
to comma
then I'll select my table array so I'll
take my table array from A2 to
C7
if you want you can choose the entire
table also
give a comma my column index number is
this department column which is the
third column
and range lookup is either true or false
I'll select false which is 0 for exact
match
if I hit enter you can see it has
returned marketing
and in the table also if you see Stuart
is from the marketing department so this
is a simple example how you can use
vlookup
now
if you want you can choose the entire
table so I can select from A2
to E7 hit enter will give the same
result now suppose I want to find from
the marketing department
so this is the person who is from the
marketing department I want to find the
city I'll use the vlooker function again
vlookup
now my lookup value is marketing
element column with the leftmost lookup
column
select the remaining table leave a comma
and my column index number is 2
is the city column
and I'll give my range look up as 0
because I want the exact match I'll hit
enter you can see it has returned me the
city to which
this person from the marketing
department belongs to that is cancels
let's see another example
suppose I want to find the city to which
the person with the last name Davis
belongs to so I'll write my vlookup
function I'll take my lookup value as
Davis give a comma now my table array
will start from the last name column
and let's select the remaining columns
as well
now my column index number is will be 3
as per our selection
for example let's say we want to find
the first name of the person who is from
Los Angeles city so we have our lookup
values Los Angeles and now we want to
find the first name so I'll again use
the lookup function I'll give my lookup
value as Los Angeles
comma Now my lookup Vector is the city
column comma a resultant Vector is the
first name column
we close the bracket hit enter
you can see it has returned Miss to it
which is actually wrong
you see our original table the person
who is from Los Angeles city is not
Steward but it's Lucy
so the mistake that we did was before
applying the formula we did not sort a
lookup column so let me short this
column in ascending order go to the data
tab I'll sort it I'll click sort now you
can see it has written Me Lucy and you
can see there was an error because we
sorted the table so the values changed
so be aware of this now let's try
another example let's say I want to find
the department of the person who was
hired on this particular date which is
10th of November 2001 so I can use the
lookup function here better hostile sort
this date Hyatt column in ascending
order click on sort now let's find the
department of the person with the last
name as Davis
so you can see
Davis and the department it belongs to
is sales
so I'll use the edge lookup function
again select my lookup value as Davis
and give a comma Now my table array
I'll select from G2 to M5 now in this
selection my row index number will be 2
which is the department column
0 close the bracket hit enter
it has returned sales so Davis is from
sales department moving ahead now
let's explore the IF function so the IF
function in Excel checks whether a
condition is satisfied or met
it returns a value if true else it will
return another value of the condition is
not satisfied so let me use an IF
function here
I'll give my logical test as
say the value in cell 11
if it's greater than 5 then I'll return
Yes 10 is greater else I'll return no
close the bracket hit enter
you can see the result
it says yes 10 is greater because at
condition 10 is greater than 5.
now if I change this value to 4
it returns no because 4 is not greater
than 5. now we have a question here
I want to add values to this result
column
so our condition is
if the player scores more than 50 and
average is more than 42 then he is a
good player else he's not a good player
so we'll return not so good so we have
three player names the runs they have
scored and the average they have so I'll
use the and give my condition
I'll write equal to if
now since I am checking for two
conditions that is the player should
score more than 50 and the average
should be more than 42 so I'll use and
and close here
so I'll check
if
p 22 which has the runs is greater than
50
and Q 22 is greater than 42 then we'll
return is a
good player
else
not so good close the bracket now if I
hit enter
it has returned me good player because
both runs and averages the meter
condition
now let me copy paste this formula
for this cell you can see Michael has
scored 40 runs and his average is also
40. is not so good because
our condition was we should have scored
more than 50 and average should be more
than 42 so both the conditions was not
met the next function we have is if n a
now the if any function will return the
value you specify if the expression
resolves to any value otherwise it will
return the result of the expression so I
want to find
the department of Anthony now you can
see the first name column this no name
as Anthony let's see what happens if you
want to find the department of Anthony
so I'll write equal to if n a now in
value I'll use a vlookup function I'll
give my value as R12 which is Anthony
and I'll choose my column as
from O2 to S7
give a comma Now the department or the
column index number is 3 which is the
department column
I'll give 0
close the bracket
give another comma
now if the value results in n a
will return
such as value not found hit enter
you can see it here it has written me
value not found because
our vlookup function could not find any
lookup value as Anthony in the first
name column so it returned value not
found
similarly there is one more function
called if a returned value not found
similarly there is one more function
called if error
so the if error function Returns the
error value if the expression is an
error otherwise it Returns the value of
the expression if there is no error so
these two cells you can see we have some
values 10 and 0 let's say I want to use
the F error function and
the value I'll give is say I want to
divide
u3
by
u4 so I am dividing 10 by 0
now
if the result is an error we'll return
cannot divide close the bracket hit
enter you can see it has returned we
cannot divide because you cannot divide
a number by 0 hence there was an error
so it returned this value now let's say
I want to divide let's say I want to use
the if error function again
now I want to divide W3 which has the
value 10 by W 4 which is the value 5
I'll give the value if error that is
cannot
divide
if I hit enter it returns me true
because 10 is divisible by 5 so divided
10 by 5 and the result was 2. similarly
let's say I want to find
the city to Virtual again there is no
Anthony's try this out I'll use the
index function now the array I will give
us from Z 2 to AC 7. comma myronum is 3
and the column number I want is 2 close
it returns me Davis which is this one
the reason being we skipped the header
column our column was selected from this
cell so this is our first row second row
third row so third row and second column
we have Davis similarly let's check for
fifth row and fourth column I'll use the
index function I'll give my array from
Z2 to 87 this time I am selecting the
entire table
I'll give my row number as 5 and my
column as 4 close the bracket
hit enter
the result it returns is Boston you can
see
the fifth row is this one and the fourth
column is City so it underst Boston now
the match function
Returns the relative position of an item
in an array that matches a specified
value so if you want to find
the position at which
events is located in the table so you
can use the match function something
like this match I'll take my lookup
value as
y 15 which has events
comma
now my lookup array
will be
the last name column because events was
from the last name column comma I'll
give 0 for exact match I'll hit enter it
gives me 5. events was present in the
fifth row let's check for Boston now
I'll use the match function again my
lookup value will be Boston comma my
lookup array will be the city column
comma I want the exact match close the
bracket hit enter
it returns six so if you start from the
beginning here this is the first row
second third fourth fifth and sixth in
sixth row we have Boston now you can use
this index match function to return a
value in a column to the left with
vlookup you are stuck returning a value
from a call I'll select my lookup array
from
Z1 to z7
comma 0
I close the brackets hit enter
it has written cancels you can see
Jensen the first name Jensen belong to
City Kansas similarly
let's find the city to wish the person
with the last name as events belongs to
so evens you can see from the table
belongs to Los Angeles let's find out
using our index match function
I'll write index
and then
array I'll give as
ec1 to ac7 comma
myronum
I'll give my match function
lookup value will be evens which is ab15
comma
look up array is ee12a7
which is our last name column and 0.
if I hit enter you can see it has
returned
Los Angeles
now let's find out the department to
which zampa belongs to
so I'll use my index function
now I'll select my array from
aa1
to ac7
comma
I'll find the row number using the match
function
so my lookup value will be zampa which
is ab18
comma
the lookup array will be
A1 to a 7 comma 0
and close the bracket
give one more comma now I'll find the
column number I'll again use
my match function to do it this time I
want to find the location of department
so I'll give
Department that is eb1 as the reference
comma the lookup array will be from E1
to ed1 which are the column headers
comma 0
and I'll close the brackets if I hit
enter it gives me sales so you can see
here from the table zampa is from the
sales department
so in this way you can use index match
function to find the row number the
column number and the value you are
looking for now we'll talk about countif
countifs some apps and average functions
so you can see I am here in a new tab
now to check these functions I am using
a coronavirus data set you can see it
here it has a date column then we have
divided the date into D month year
number of cases debts countries from
which these cases and deaths came from
we have the continent and few other
information
so first let's see what county function
does so the county function counts the
number of cells within a range that meet
the given condition
so we'll see these functions by taking
an example
so we have a question here we want to
count the number of times Afghanistan is
present in the data set so I'll consider
my G column that is countries and
territories
so I'll write my countif function I'll
give my range from G1 to the end of this
G column
I'll give a comma
go to the top now my criteria will be
Afghanistan
if you want you can use cell reference
as well I am typing the country name
manually if I hit enter
it gives me 446 so in this column that
is the G column Afghanistan is present
146 times similarly let's count the
number of times India is present in the
data set
so I'll use the county function again
I'll select the same range you give a
comma Now my criteria will be India you
can see here India is present 155 times
moving on the next function will talk
about is countifs so the tips function
counts the number of cells specified in
a given set of conditions or criteria so
our question is count the total number
of days in which the cases in India have
been greater than 100 so to do this
count ifs function
I'll select
my criteria range
first I'll select the D column comma
my first criteria is we want to check
for India
and then
my second condition is that the number
of cases has to be greater than 100 so
my next criteria range will be the cases
column comma
and my condition is
greater than 100 close the bracket hit
enter the result is 68. so a total of 68
days India had more than 100 cases the
next example is we need to count the
number of days in which the deaths in
United States have been greater than 200
so for that
I'll use the count ifs function I'll
give my criteria so this time I am
taking my first criteria as the cases
comma so the cases have to be greater
than 200
close the bracket hit enter
so you can see the total cases in India
till
3rd of June have been
more than 2 lakhs now I want to find the
total debts in the United States till
the 3rd of June I'll use the same
sumif function
now my first criteria will be the G
column
comma
I'll give my second value as
United States of America I'll use the
same format using underscore
States of
America
comma
now the second range will be the deaths
column
close the bracket hit enter you can see
the total debts in the United States
till 3rd of June have crossed
one lakh similarly let's now
see our sumifs function to the sum X
function adds the cells specified in a
given set of conditions or criteria so
we have a question here we want to find
the total cases in France on those days
where the deaths have been less than 100
so this would be those days instead of
whose okay so let's see our sum UPS
function now
first we need to give the sum range
since we want to find the total cases so
we'll give the sum range as the column e
comma Now the second criteria is the
countries column so I'll give the G
column and we want to check for France
give that criteria comma the second
criteria is I need to find only for
those days where the debts have been
less than 100. so I'll give the deaths
column comma the criteria should be less
than 100.
close the bracket hit enter
is the result so the total cases in
France on those days where the debts
have been less than 100 is 20
638 now let's talk about the average
function so the average function finds
the average or the arithmetic mean of
the cells specified by a given condition
or criteria so our question is want to
find the total average daily cases in
India this is till the 3rd of June so
I'll use the average function and my
first criteria I'll select is the
countries column and my criteria will be
India and then I'll give the range that
is the E column which has the cases if I
hit enter
so these are the daily average cases in
India till the 3rd of June next let's
talk about some date and time functions
in Excel you can see here I am in my
date and time sheet
so let's start with the today function
the today function Returns the current
date
or today's date
so if I write equal to
today close the bracket hit enter it
will return me today's date which is
28th of July now you can use the Now
function which will return the current
date and time value
so if I write equal to now
if I hit enter
you can see it has returned the current
date and the time so this is basically
the system date and time you can see it
here now there's another function called
time the time function converts hours
minutes seconds given as numbers to an
Excel serial number formatted with a
time format so you can see here I'll
write the time function now let's see
I'll give my RS as 20 so it's in 24
hours format let's say a minute I'll
give 40 and seconds I'll give 20 if I
close the bracket hit enter the time is
8 40 PM now you can subtract the Now
function from today function to return
the time value so let me show it to you
here I'll write my Now function and I'll
subtract today so hit enter
it returns me the time this is the
system time now
there's another function in Excel called
Date diff function which Returns the
difference between two dates in terms of
years months and days
now here I have a date of birth which is
30 December 1994
and we have today's date I have used the
2D function
if I want to find the age I can use the
date D function so I'll write date div
and in that I'll give my
first date value as the date of birth
which is 30 December 1994.
comma my second date value will be
today's date which is 28th of July
now I want to find the age in terms of
years so within double course I'll give
y right enter it gives me 25 so it has
subtracted our first state value and the
second date value to return the year now
the date D function will always return a
whole number you can see it here this
was a whole number you can use the ear
Frac function in Excel to return the
year fraction representing the number of
whole days between the start date and
the end date so I can use the year Frac
function here
write your Frac my start date will be
ready to birth
now the end date will be today's day
comma basis
I'll give one which is actually it will
divide the actual number of days by the
actual days in a year right enter
it gives me my ear fraction which is 25
point
five seven six three
now let's see
I'll replace one with let's say 2. write
enter it gives me
25.95 you can see it here if you give
two it will divide the actual Disease by
360. Now the default value is 0. moving
ahead
we have the weekday function
now the weekday function returns a
number from 1 to 7 identifying the day
of the week of a date so
let me use the weekday function I'll
give my
serial number as today right enter it
gives me three now let's say I want to
use the weekday function again I'll
use
my cell reference E2 which has the
today's date comma
now the return type
I'll give as 2
which means
it starts from Monday through Sunday so
the first day of the week starts on a
Monday and ends on a Sunday tip 2 close
the bracket hit enter it gives me 2.
the second day of the week then we can
have your day function month function
and your function let's explore them one
by one so the day function Returns the
day of the month it will have a number
between 1 to 31 so 1 means the beginning
of the month and 31 means the last day
of the month
so if I use my day function on
E2 which is today's date
if I hit enter
it gives me 28 that is 28th of July
similarly let's check for month
I'll give the same cell reference hit
enter it gives me 7 which means the July
month
now let's find the year give the cell
reference hit enter
it returns me the year that is 2020. now
you can extract the hours minutes and
seconds from a Time Value so I'll use
the r function to get the r value from
the current time you can see it has
returned 14 which means it's 2 pm now
let's find out the minute also I'll use
the minute function give my Now function
hit enter
19 so it's 2 pm and 19 minutes now let's
find out the seconds also I'll give my
Now function to get the second also
there's another function in Excel called
days 360. so days 360 function Returns
the number of days between two dates
based on a 360 day year
so we assume that in a year all the
months have 30 days so I'll use my
days 360 function
I'll give my start date as my date of
birth which is B12
comma the end date
I'll give today's date which is in B 13
and the method I'll use is true which is
European method
you can see what the European method
says the start dates and end dates that
occur on the 31st day of a month will be
equal to the 30th day of that month
close the bracket hit enter it gives me
the total number of days that were
between
my first date that is the starting date
and the end date similarly now let's use
these 360 once again
I'll give my start date let's say 25th
of June 2020 and my end date will be
today's date so get the total number of
days that is 33 similarly we have your
month which means end of month so end of
month function Returns the serial number
of the last day of the month before or
after a specified number of months so
I'll use my EO month I'll give my start
date as B12 which is my date of birth
and then I want the number of months to
be 10 hit enter you can see it has given
us the next day when the month is ending
so it is 31st of October 1995. coming to
Vietnam function the weeknum function
Returns the week number of the year so
I'll use my weak num function and my
serial number will be today's date comma
the return type I want is 2 so I want my
beat to begin on a Monday so I'll give
two close the bracket hit enter
it gives me 31 so
today's date that is 28th of July is the
31st week of the year let's explore a
few more functions
we have Network days and work days now
these are Advanced functions
of date and time in Excel
now the network days function Returns
the number of whole working days between
two dates
so Network days automatically excludes
weekends that is Saturday and Sunday and
can optionally exclude a list of
holidays supplied as dates now I have
listed down the list of holidays this is
from the U.S calendar
and the list of holidays are for the
current year that is 2020
so first let's use our Network device
function to find the number of working
days between two date values
so I'll write
Network days
and let's say I'll give my first date or
the starting date as
1st of July
2020
and I'll give my second date value
as 31st of
July
2020 close the bracket hit enter it
gives me 23. now let me show you the
calendar now this is the July calendar
if you can see
the first day of July starts on
Wednesday
and it ends on Friday and in between we
have one two three four five six seven
and eight so total we have eight
weekends
so our Nets skipped counting these
weekends so since July is at 31 days
month it has subtracted those eight days
those were on weekends so 31 minus 8 is
23 so in total we have 23 working days
in July now let's say I want to include
the holiday calendar also so I'll use
the network days function Again YouTube
My starting the workday function returns
serial number of the date before or
after a specified number of work days
the Excel workday function takes date
and Returns the nearest working day in
the future or past it can be used in
logistics to calculate shipping dates
delivery dates that need to take into
account working and non-working days it
automatically excludes weekends that is
Saturdays and Sundays so let me use my
work day function I'll give my start
date as
first of July
2020
and the number of days I'll give is 5.
close the bracket hit enter
it has written me a serial number you
can convert this into a date value so
our next working date after first of
July is 8th of July if you see the
calendar we started on 1st of July so
counting five days after first of July
so one two three
4 and 5 so the next working day after
five days will be 8th of July so it has
kept counting the weekends 4th of July
and 5th of July similarly I'll use the
workday function again this time I'll
give my starting date
as first of July only and now
I want to find the next working days
after five days and I'll give my holiday
list close the bracket hit enter I can
convert this into a date value you can
see it has given us 9th of July because
five days we had a holiday that is 3rd
of July which was an Independence Day
finally let's move on to our next and
the final section in this tutorial for
functions and formulas we have some
Financial functions so these Financial
functions are commonly used in Banking
and Financial sectors let's have a look
at them one by one first we have the PMT
function now the Excel PMT function is a
financial function that Returns the
periodic payment for a loan the PMT
function can be used to figure out the
future payments for a loan assuming
constant payments and a constant
interest rate so I'll just show you the
arguments the PMT function takes you can
see it takes rate in PR or nper PV FP
and type so rate is the interest rate
for the loan and PE ER is the total
number of payments for the loan PV is
the future value of the total value of
all loan payments now FV is the future
value or a cash balance you want after
the last payment is made by default is
zero type it is optional when payments
are due so 0 means end of period 1 means
beginning of period now let's use the
PMT function to find
the future payments for a loan so I have
my data here on the top I have my rate
as five percent I'll use
cell reference E2 comma
then I want my NPR or number of period
so I'll give myself B2
comma
the present value
is my loan amount
that is 2 lakhs
comma
I don't want any future value would give
it a 0
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it has returned us the PMT
amount or the principal amount
now you can see it has given us
a negative number the reason being the
amount is getting deducted from our
present value so to solve this issue you
can give
a negative sign here so if I copy paste
the formula again let me put it in this
cell
equal to I'll paste it
now if I
give a negative sign now I can edit this
instead of 4 I'll give 12 because we
want to find it monthly so
will convert our annual interest rate to
monthly interest rate now and I'll
multiply the NPR or the number of
periods into 12 and I'll hit enter
so this is a future value of the PMT
monthly moving on
if you have a table here you can see
there have been a series of cash flow
over a period of time
Now using this table I want to use my
irr and xirr function
so the irr function in Excel Returns the
internal rate
of a series of cash flows so if I want
to find the internal rate of return I'll
use the irr function
and
I'll select my values from
B16 to B21
close the bracket
so this is my irr value that is 22
percent
if I want to find the X error value I'll
use the X irr function that Returns the
internal rate for a schedule of cash
flows that occur in irregular intervals
now for using the X irr function I'll
use this table now you can see it has
irregular cash flows over a period of
time
so let me use my X irr function
I'll give my values ranging from
F 22
to
f27
comma the dates I'll give from e22 to
e27
close the bracket hit enter this is my
xirr value up next
we'll see how to find out the feature
value
so for using the future value use the FV
function in Excel that Returns the
future value of an investment you can
use the FV function to get the future
value of an investment assuming periodic
constant payments with a constant
interest rate also
so this is my table
so we have an annual interest rate of 10
percent yes we have 8 and yearly payment
we have one lakh now to find the future
value I'll use equal to f v
rate I'll give G4
which is 10 percent comma
nper I'll give G5 which is the number of
years that is 8. and yearly payment I'll
give 1 lakh which is G6 comma
present value 0 type is also 0
right enter so this is my future value
which is 11 lakhs
43 588
similarly if you want to find the
present value so you can use the PV
function which Returns the present value
of an investment that is a total amount
that is series of future free means is
worth now
so let me use the PV function I'll give
my rate as eight percent which is G13
comma my number of periods is 5 or you
can assume 5 years comma my PMT or
payment per period is
10 000
comma future value 0 type is also zero
so this is my present value
up next we have the net present value or
the npv function
so the npv formula or the function
calculates the net present value of an
investment based on a discount rate and
a series of future payments having
negative values and income having
positive values so you can see in the
table here
our investment has a negative value
and our incomes have positive values and
we have a discount rate of 10 percent
now let's find the Net Present Value we
use the npv function now the rate I'll
give is 10 percent comma rules how to
add columns or how to add multiple
columns in Excel now without further Ado
let's get started with the Practical
mode now we have started our Excel
worksheet and here you can see we have
Android details on our worksheet now all
of a sudden uh you wanted to add
employee second name as well or a last
name right so you're a beginner and you
don't know how to add a column or you
know you might be a little ambiguous
right so instead of using this simple
step you might end up creating a whole
new sheet or maybe other approaches as
well which are time consuming so let me
give you this simple step all you have
to do is select the column so here you
wanted to add a last name right so B is
your column with the first name and here
you wanted to add a second name or the
last name which is in between the
columns B and C so remember that Excel
adds a column always towards the left
side of a column so here if I if you
wanted to add a call next to B then you
want to select the column C and right
click and select the insert option so
that it can be added in between B and C
which is adjacent to V so let's look at
it right so you have added the next uh
column or a new column right next to the
column B and it's in between the
designation and employee name now you
can add your inner second name so that's
how you create a new column in Excel now
in case if you wanted to you know create
multiple columns all together so here we
have or here we needed a second name
also here you have a designation and you
wanted to add another column which you
know assigns manages to the employees
right so I'll let's delete it delete the
second column and let me explain you how
what I want to do so here you wanted to
add the second name of the employee and
also the manager of these employees
right so here you wanted to add two
columns all together right and now you
might be wondering could I add two
columns together uh or will it work only
for the one column thing right now it
works for two columns and also more than
two columns all together so you wanted
to add two columns here right so select
the two columns you can you can select
or you can click on the column C and
hold that left key and drag it along the
right side okay so here I have selected
two columns and here it's three right so
you can see here uh it's one zero four
eight five six seven six R cross three
see that means you have selected three
columns if I navigate another four you
can see we have selected four columns
right now right click and select on
insert and you'll have four columns in
between employee name and designation
now you might have to add your second
name manager's name manages employee ID
you know and the department everything
or you can add anything or any number of
columns in between the existing columns
comparing two different columns or
multiple columns happens to be an
important job when you're working in
data analytics as you have to come up
with some decisive decisions based on
the data now if you had to do it
manually then you might end up taking
hours or even days based on the data set
you're working with but if I say that
you can do it within minutes then it
would be interesting to work with right
now we'll be doing the same now we'll
work on our sample data set right on my
screen
so here we have column 1 and column two
now our job is to compare the column 1
and column 2 and come up with the result
now the first and the simplest way to do
it is use the built-in condition
formatting which comes with Excel by
default now all you have to do is
select all the data and navigate to home
and in the home go to Styles group and
select conditional formatting and in
conditional formatting you can see
highlight cells so in that you can use
duplicate values when you click on
duplicate values a small pop-up window
will come on your screen and here you
have an option of choosing whether
duplicate or unique so duplicate means
you're comparing the cells and you can
see there are some duplicate cells which
are present in column one are also
present in column two now you can also
check how to uh you know find out the
unique values which are only present in
column one but not in column two so you
can just press unique and there you go
you can find it now you can also try to
you know change the color by filling
with green for The Unique columns and
duplicate cells with color red now this
was the first method and you can also
work out some different ones like you
can just directly press equal to and
select the cell and equals to and the
next cell press enter and if there is a
match it will give you true if there is
no match then it will give you false now
you can drag it down and see which all
are matching and which are not
now you can also make some minute
modifications to this
so uh if in case you didn't find the
data then you can say not found so for
that you can try if and inside brackets
and then you can give the value as not
found
if true it's found first you have to
give the True Values so for true you can
write it as found and in case if it's
not found then you can write it down as
not fund
and there you go close the bracket press
enter
and there you go if there is a perfect
match you will have found and if there
is no match then you'll get not found
now so far we have discussed uh
comparing two cells using conditional
formatting and also by using equals to
operator and trying to add some tweaks
to the equals to Operator by involving
with if operator and apart from those we
also have another way to compare two
columns in Excel so another way is using
the lookup functions so we'll use a
simple vlookup function to compare both
the cells so for that let's type in
equals to vlookup
space and select the cell you want to
check for and then
the range of elements you want to
compare and then I'll press F4 to log
them
now uh you want the data from column one
and now you want the exact match so 0
press enter
so there you go so the elements which
are present in column 1 and column 2 are
been displayed here so but in case if
the elements are not found you'll get an
error so let's look at that simply drag
the formula to all the cells and there
you go so the elements which are
matching will give you the proper result
but the ones which are not matching will
give you not applicable or error message
this can be fixed we can make some minor
tweaks to the same formula
so we can add if error
comma
simply write an as not found
close the bracket so that should do so
we have closed the bracket and press
enter there you go now simply drag this
and soon you can see the data which is
having no match is shown as not found
now uh there is another possibility okay
let's get back to another different
sheet so this should work
so uh we we already have the formula so
let's erase that first I'll erase the
whole data
and even this one
yeah now we have the clear column for so
here you can see we have for India and
here you can see we have just four and
similarly here you have Mahindra and
Mahendra and here you have Mahendra
right so in some situations you might
have to compare two different columns
but the names might be a little
different right so for example uh if
you're working with Oracle and if you're
working with Oracle America and you have
in the first cases Oracle and in the
second column is Oracle America then
those are one thing but we have some
minor text changes right just like here
you have Fort India and here you have
four so what if you had such kind of
issues so you can also make some minor
tweaks to it so using the same lookup
formula you can add equals to vlookup
and
also the comparison cell which is this
one and we are not you're not stopping
them you're trying to add
the wild card here so the wild card is
asterisk which means if there is
anything like uh if you get the
comparison between the first cell and
the second cell which matches and if
there is anything extra
rather than the actual cell please try
to consider it so that's what we're
going to do so after entering entering
the wild card symbol you'll select the
range of columns which you have to uh
you know fetch the data from
and then try to fix them using function
key F4
you're looking from the column number
one and then you're finding the exact
match now you can close it and enter
now let's try to drag it
there you go
so you have the data Mahendra and
Mahendra
Hyundai India Honda India or to sum in
Excel for that let's get started with
the Practical mode now on my screen you
can see the sales of four quarters from
different regions that is east west
south north and Central now you might
want to calculate the sum of sales
happened from all the regions in q1 or
you might want to calculate the sum of
sales happened in one region of all the
four quarters
that is either you want to calculate the
sum of all the regions from quarter 1 or
you might want to calculate the sum of
all the quarters in one region right so
to do this you have some simple
functions in Excel so you might say me
you have some function Etc right for
that you might want to go into the you
know equals to mode and fetch some
option and subtotal or sum UPS you have
to select the function from here but
what if I tell you that there is one
simple easy shortcut where you just have
to make one single click and you'll have
all the sum right so that seems
interesting so on the top in the home
bar select home and in on the top right
corner you have the editing group in
editing group you have aggregation
function that is summation
so you have different aggregations here
some average count numbers maximum
minimum more functions here you might
want to select the sum and you can get
all summation numbers here
so I'll select one cell so the second
query where we wanted to calculate the
sum of all these sales happened in east
region with all the quarters included
that is this one C2 to f 2 right so let
us select J2 and
select the autism option and here it
will automatically select the range for
you that is C2 to F2 if you want to
change it can also you know change it
like minimize the number if you just
wanted to calculate the sum of three
quarters you can do that so now we want
four quarters so select enter and there
you go you have all the sales of all the
four quarters of east region now if you
simply drag it you will have the sum of
all the four quarters of all different
regions
now let us calculate the summation of q1
of all the regions that is this one
select AutoZone and it will
automatically select all the cells for
you
that is from C2 to C6 right press enter
and you'll have the summation similarly
you can you know drag it and you have
the numbers here of all the Q2 cells of
all the regions Q3 cells of All Region
and Q4 sales of all region
now let us try to change the colors that
you can have a reference that is it's
different it's it's this total sum or
right you just have a reference to
identify it
now similarly to this one as well
so that's how you implement Auto sum in
Excel how to add two columns in Excel
so first let us assume that we are
trying to add two columns in Excel which
has textual kind of data this type of
data can be added using the concat
function which is a string concatenation
function in Excel so type in concat
press Tab Key to select the function the
first cell that is A2 and next the
second cell that is V2 separated by
comma press enter and there you go now
you can see we don't have a space so you
can modify the formula
add space
double quotes space
double quotes comma press enter
there you go now I can drag the same
formula across all the cells and you
have it now coming to the last column
where we literally have numbers right so
you can add two different numbers over
here
either you can select the first cell
that is D2 plus E2 and press enter and
you get the number or you can use the
sum function
tab to select and
one
two press enter or another simplest way
is select all the blank output cells so
these are the cells where you are
expecting an output of two cells that is
column entire column B and entire column
e right now after selecting the blank
cells of f column or the resultant
column press the shortcut key that is
alt equals to so this is the shortcut
method to call the sum function and
assign the cell values of individual
columns that is d and e and get the
resultant cell in F column right so
remember the shortcut key that is alt e
that is how to add rows and Excel for
that let's get back to the Practical
mode now we are on the Excel spreadsheet
now here we have some sales data based
on a store now what we are going to do
is we are going to add some multiple
rows or a single Row in this particular
data so here you can see the region wise
category Wise statewise subcategory Wise
and there are sales and quantities right
now let us imagine that you must start
to add a sale data here right so let us
imagine that on the row 7th you are
supposed to add some detail for example
some technology related sale happened on
that day and you missed out to add it
right so how do you create a new row now
so for example if multiple sales
happened on the same day like three to
four and you missed out them so how do I
add three to four rows in between the
existing data right so don't worry about
it it's completely simple all you have
to do is select the row and right click
and press on the option insert now this
will insert one single row if you wanted
to add one single uh row or a tuple and
if you wanted to add multiple rows for
example you wanted to add three rows all
together then it's also simple all you
have to do is select three rows
and right click and press on insert and
then you have three rows so there you go
so that's how you add multiple rows in a
Excel spreadsheet or that's how you add
one single Row in an Excel spreadsheet
how to freeze rows in Excel now we might
want to start our practical mode So
currently we are on Excel and this is a
spreadsheet data
so here you can see columns and rows so
especially the fourth row and the column
C right so uh currently we have data on
our spreadsheet and it is exceeding the
number of rows currently visible on our
screen right so when you scroll down you
can see that the header or the headers
of all the columns are getting vanished
or scrolled up along with the data right
and you might want to keep that so that
you will have reference to every single
aspect of or every single cell data
you're referring to right so for that
reason you might want to freeze this and
also you might have a doubt what if even
even I had this data in the column
section right and what if I had to
freeze that and you know when you scroll
this and keep that data set on the
column as it is right so we can also do
that let's look at both of them so there
is a simple process to do that all you
have to do is select the cell or for
which you want to uh you know set the or
freeze the column adjacent to it or the
row adjacent to it right so currently I
want to let me expand it so currently I
want to freeze this particular row right
and this particular column so the cell I
would be selecting is the first cell
here that is D5
right so when I select this particular
cell I can be able to freeze this
particular row and this particular
column
so now you need to navigate to the
toolbar and then select the view menu
and inside view option you can see there
is an option of freeze pins right so
click on the drop down so you can see
three different options as we discussed
earlier we can either choose to freeze
an entire row that is a second option or
you can freeze the entire column that is
the third option or you can freeze both
that is the first option right freezing
rows and columns so let's select this
one and see if our rows and columns are
frozen or not right so now let's scroll
down and you can see our row is
successfully Frozen there right and
similarly scroll towards right and you
can see our column has been successfully
Frozen right so this is how you freeze
rows and columns or you can freeze panes
in Excel so with that we have come to
the end of this tutorial on how to
freeze raw or how to freeze columns or
how to freeze both the pins in Excel
spreadsheet lock or protect cells in
Excel now let's get back into the
Practical mode and start our Microsoft
Excel now we are on the Microsoft Excel
and this particular spreadsheet is
related to employee details
now the screen is visible a bit better
now let us imagine that this is our
confidential data and you want to edit
only two columns that is the designation
column and phone number column now let
us imagine that the company has finished
one annual year and now there are some
promotions happening in the company and
let us also imagine that the phone
numbers of the employees provided by the
company have undergone some changes so
now the minor edits that you want to
make are related to the designation
column and phone number column now you
can see that all the columns that is the
blood group new salary salary hike
current salary and name of the employee
serial number employee number everything
is editable so in such kind of scenarios
when you pass on this data there might
be a possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename this sheet
now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can lock the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to lock the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password now when you select all the
cells in this particular sheet you can
just click on this edge here and you
have all the cells selected and now
right click somewhere on the sheet and
you can see an option called format
cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see by
default Excel keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns D and I and
now let's right click and go into format
cells and in the protection option make
sure that you uncheck the locked icon
now select OK and now
okay so you cannot include the merge to
sell fine we have a cell here which is
merged okay let's remove that
okay now again select the entire column
right click get into format cells and
uncheck the log option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is locking all the cells which you don't
want to get added and unlocking the
cells where you want to make some edits
now the second stage is protecting the
sheet now right click on the sheet name
and you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select love cells and also select
envelope cells so let us provide a
password here so let us use some simple
password so that we don't forget that so
I'll be selecting one two three and now
select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type 1 2 3 again now select OK and
now the sheet is protected
now we have successfully logged and
protected all the cells in Excel now let
us verify that the cells you wanted to
protect are really protected and locked
or not so we have unlocked phone number
and designation and everything else is
locked now let me try and edit the blood
group so when I double click or try to
edit this particular sheet then I'll be
receiving a warning from Excel it says
the cell or chart you're trying to
change is on a protected sheet to make a
change unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a password
so it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unblocked
so you can see I can really edit the
unlocked cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable now
let us go through the designation column
and try to edit this particular column
now since I said that there's a
promotion happening in the company so
the deputy CEO is now the current CEO of
the company
and software developer happens to become
the senior software developer
and the tester as well let us imagine
that he will become the senior
and so on
okay so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
foreign
and you can see on my screen we have the
sales data of one single employee in the
month of January okay so this is the
sales data of John in January sales
now let us imagine that we have the same
persons or same Jones data of sales of
all the three months okay so here we
have the sales data of John for January
February and March and you wanted to
Club all these three months and write it
down as quarter one right so let us try
doing it
now you can see that uh only January is
replaced as quarter one and February and
March are still remaining the same so
let us try to delete them
so we have deleted them and I think now
it looks like uh this is a sales data of
one single quota that is quarter one but
again
quarter one is under column B and anyone
who looks at it feels like this data is
of January February and March and all
the quarter one details are only present
in B column but C and D are completely
you know different from this one right
so you don't want that kind of an
impression on your uh you know the one
who are presenting to you so in those
situations you want to merge all these
three columns and make sure that the
quarter one is present somewhere in
between the cell so that all the data
looks relevant and uh it defines that
these data elements belong to Koto one
right so there is nothing in Excel to do
that so select all the cells that you
want to merge and going to home button
and in home button get into the
alignment group and select merge and
center so you can do it directly also
you have a couple of more options there
is merge and center merge across merge
cells and unmatch so we'll go through it
one by one so first we'll go through
merge and center
so there you go the sales code merged
and it has been aligned into Center
now again if your manager or anyone's
video to you wants this to be you know
independent like they want it to be in
terms of January February and March so
that they can have access to it in
month-wise so you want to unmatch it
back right how to do that now so the
same menu and select unmatch and there
you go you have your data packed in the
original form again all you have to do
is you know rename a few cells
there you go
and you have it back right so in a few
situations okay you can also add
reporters so that it looks more relevant
now uh you know now let's try to merge
this again and margin Center yeah now
again uh let us imagine that you are
going through an appraisal cycle and you
also wanted to add some comments about
the sales happening in your company uh
regarding uh all the employees right so
also we have that here now let me expand
a little bit
yeah okay
so again let's margin Center
now
uh you wanted to you know you wanted to
take a review of your level one level
two and level three managers so you have
all the three uh rows here but you can
see the cells are not merged and you
wanted to merge every single row so
merging and centering everything row
wise would be a little time consuming I
mean three columns is okay but what if
you had like uh you had to take a review
from a couple of small manages like five
to ten right or imagine a you wanted to
write some random comments apart from
review you wanted to write some random
comments based on month-wise uh sales or
something like that so it would be time
consuming right so apart from that you
have another option where you you know
select all the cells and come over here
and select the option of merge across
and all the cells will be merged all
together at once and you will be having
those individual rows where you can
write down your reviews like review one
and so on review
2 right so this is how the option of
merge across works and we already have
been through the margin Center and merge
is completely similar to margin Center
so this is how margin Center merge cells
and merge across and unmatched cells in
Excel that is how to convert rows to
columns in Excel
so for that we might want to get started
with our practical mode now you can see
I'm on my Excel worksheet and I have one
table on my worksheet right now so you
can you know transposing or you know
converting rows to columns is a very
simple task I'll explain you in two
different ways so the first way select
all the cells
that you have on your sheet and press on
Ctrl C so it will give you the copy
option and then you can also paste in
the same sheet or if you want you can go
to a whole new sheet and select the
paste option over here but before
selecting the actual paste option you
can see a small drop down icon click on
that and navigate to paste special and
in this you can see transpose option
click on that or you know make sure that
it's checked and press ok now you can
see all your columns have been converted
into rows and all your rows are
converted into columns so this was the
first way and what as the second way you
ask me so it's really simple select one
cell somewhere
and you know you can or let's create a
new sheet as well so here you can you
know write down the formula as transpose
and select the array which you want to
transpose so this is the array
so transpose is basically an array
function in Excel so once you are done
with you know selecting your data press
enter there you go so all your rows are
now columns and all your columns are now
the rows so you can see that I've got
some data which is first name of the
employee last name of the employee and
phone number and let us assume that your
manager has given you a task to identify
all those employees which did not give
and
phone number so you wanted to identify
them using a check box right
like you will be providing a check for
all the employees that we have received
the phone numbers and you will not be
checking the employees which did not
give the phone number right so let's try
to do that so to include a check box you
might want to get into the developer
option but for few reasons Microsoft has
disabled developer option by default to
enable developer option all you have to
do is just navigate anywhere on the
ribbon here
and right click and then you can see
customize the ribbon option when you
click into it you will be redirected
into the ribbon option and here you can
see the developer option on the right
side
right this one so by default you can see
that your developer option is not
enabled to enable it you have to check
in it and there you go you have it now
so press OK and you will have the
developer option now go to the developer
option and select the insert option and
there you can see the checkbox now draw
the checkbox anywhere
I'll write over here and there you go
you have the first check box right now
if you want you can even customize this
so carefully click it
you can edit the text
and write it as
done
okay
now you can even copy this to all the
cells
just select and drag and there you go
now you can go ahead and check all the
employees which you have received the
phone numbers
and you can eliminate the ones which did
not provide you with phone numbers
that's how you can do it and there's
also another option where you can use
this to include it in a formula
since this data is only of 25 rows you
can manually check in the data and you
can leave the data which is you have not
received but what if you had 2500 right
then you might need formula so in such
scenarios you can use a formula so how
do you use that so for example if this
particular box is checked then you will
get a True Value here and if it's not
checked you will have a false value then
you can use that Boolean value to
include in your formula right sounds
interesting now let's try to implement
that
you can right click the cell and you can
find format control
then you can see here
you have an option called cell link here
select the cell link
and press ok
so here you can see if you have checked
this the value is true and if you
uncheck this
you can see the value turned false now
you can use this particular cell
reference for including this in a
formula now let us also check how to
include checkboxes on Google Sheets and
Google sheet it's really simple all you
have to do is get into the insert option
and you can see a really available
checkbox you don't have to use any
developer options over here
and there you go you can just check and
uncheck it that is how to add filters in
Excel now it is really simple to add
filters in Excel so we are on a
practical mode right now so on my screen
you can see an Excel spreadsheet of
sales data so here you have various
columns regions category state
subcategory sales quantity and much more
right so now let us imagine that we want
to add filters on the region part so we
have southwest east Etc right so we want
to you know let us imagine that you want
to extract the data of only west region
and you wanted a filter so doing it
manually could take a lot of things so
using filters will be helpful now select
one cell on the headers part and select
the filter option in the data toolbar
you can see the date option in the
toolbar right so click on the data
option and navigate to sort and filter
group and in that select the option of
filter now you can see the filters are
been added to all the column headers
region category state subcategory sales
quantity right now we wanted the West
category so when you see or when you
click on the drop down icon you can see
all the options are selected right the
central east west south every everything
right but now we just want West one so
click on West and select okay there you
go so you have everything from the west
region now let's imagine that you wanted
to look into office supplies only or
technology only right you can do the
same with technology and press OK and
now you'll have all the technology
related sales in the west region right
so that's how you use filters in Excel
or that's how you add filters in Excel
AutoFill in Excel
now AutoFill in Excel is a feature where
you can add some series automatically
using Excel for example let us imagine
that you wanted to add index numbers
right so starting from 1 to 10. so
manually you will be typing in the
numbers and you'll be doing it right so
instead of this what if I said you there
was a simple way where Excel will fill
all the data for you right so just start
with one
do and select these two cells and you
can see the flash logo over here right
so that's the indication that Excel has
understood your pattern and it is ready
to fill the remaining numbers so as long
as you drag this logo or that ending
part where you have a small square box
that will fill all the numbers until
where you are prevented so that's how
autofill works and you might be
wondering will it work only for numbers
no it will also work on some Logics as
well okay this was the first part let us
also look at some other tricks with
autofill now most of the time we might
be just adding one number and try to
drag that cell and the result is it will
copy the same number all the time right
so you can change it by clicking on this
menu you can click on fill series and it
will change to series
and this was one more trick with numbers
now getting back to the next type so let
us imagine now the next type of series
you want to add is weeks in a day right
so you will be having Monday
Tuesday Wednesday right so you can also
do the series of weekdays using AutoFill
in Excel as well so drag that cell and
it will give you all the days or
weekdays in a week
now let's try January
and this will give you the months in a
year
in the shortcut way right since you just
added the first three letters of the
month it will recognize the pattern and
it will do the same for you now let us
try the full names of months
right and now let's try to drag it it'll
fill all the full names of all the
months
now
let's try the dates so let us imagine
that this is the first day of the
current year
right it will now give you all the dates
of that current month or until the end
of the year as well
there you go
now let us imagine that your manager
tells you to add the dates of working
days in the month of January so how can
you do that it's simple all you need to
do is select the cell go to the fill
option select series and here select
column wise since you want the dates and
columns and here in the type select date
date unit should be weekday and the
stock value should be the next month
right since your manager asked for the
weekdays of January so your stock value
will be the first of February press OK
and there you go so since the first of
January is Friday that's selected over
here and the rest to Saturday and Sunday
are eliminated similarly we have all the
dates here of working days only so
that's how you use AutoFill in Excel how
to add Watermark to excel now on my
sheet you can see some data so here we
wanted to add some Watermark logo to
your Excel spreadsheet so that it looks
genuine and worked by you right so
that's the overall idea of adding a
watermark now go to the insert window
and in the insert window go to the text
option click on that select header and
footer once you select header and photo
you can see something on your screen
like this so in this box which is
highlighted by a cursor is why you're
going to add the picture on my top in
the menu bar you can see header and
footer elements in this select the
picture element and it will navigate to
you to a different option window since
we are adding the image from our local
system select from file or if you are
adding from your Bing or any search
window you can also add that or one rep
as well but now let's go with from file
it will directly navigate you to the
pictures folder in your local system so
here is my simply launch logo click on
it and select insert now you can see the
images added in this format which is
Ampersand and picture and you might
wonder where is the picture it is
actually present to view it click on any
cell in the spreadsheet and there you go
you can see it now you might be
wondering the image is a little towards
top and abnormally placed right so no
worries you can always you know format
your picture just press enter and use
enter to move your picture towards the
center of your data spreadsheet and also
there is another option of format
picture altogether here you can adjust
the height and width of your image by
you know increasing and decreasing width
or increasing and decreasing height
using the arrow marks also works and
apart from this there is another option
of picture formatting where you can
choose your image to be washing out
black and white grayscale or anything so
currently I am going with automatic
which will automatically adjust the
brightness and you know everything for
your image it looks perfectly fine so
click on OK and there you go right so
now
this should be fine
right now everything is done and
everything is automatically saved if you
are having that auto save option on your
spreadsheet and let's go back to the
normal view from the header and footer
view click on The View and go to normal
you might be confused right where is the
logo to vanished I have to save it no
it's already saved everything is fine
even the image is there but you cannot
see it in normal view to see it click on
file click on print then you can see the
logo it will be present only on the
printed Pages not on the normal view
okay so that's how you work with
watermarks in Excel and that's how you
can add and customize your watermarks
using Excel how to insert PDF in Excel
now there are multiple ways to insert a
PDF into Excel so we will go through a
couple of ways first is here let us
imagine that we wanted to insert some
PowerPoint presentation in PDF format
into our Excel sheet so that it belongs
to excel Basics now click on the cell
where you want to add the PDF or just
click any cell in the Excel spreadsheet
then go to the option of insert in the
toolbar then navigate to desktop option
click on it and select object
and here you can select create from file
and then you can browse and here you
have your Excel Basics PDF in my
documents click on that select insert so
here you can just press ok
and the PDF will be inserted now you can
minimize the size of PDF to fit the cell
there you go the PDF got successfully
inserted into your Excel spreadsheet now
let's discuss about the second way now
the second way is completely same the
only difference is you can add some logo
to your PDF so you can see it has been
added in direct form of a PDF like what
sticker first slide of the PPT but
instead of that if you wanted to
highlight it as an icon then you can
select the display as icon button here
and press ok now you don't have to
reformat the size of your PPD or PDF all
you have to do is add the logo to your
PDF and it will also include the title
so this is another way of adding you
know PDF to your Excel sheet now another
way so a few times you don't want the
first page of the PDF to be visible or
any kind of logo of that PDF reader to
be visible on your spreadsheet sometimes
all you want is some dedicated image or
a dedicated logo right so to this time
let's try to add a dedicated image to
our PDF so go to insert again here you
can see the illustrations option
click on picture and from this device so
I will select the simply launch logo and
now you have to resize the logo a little
bit to fit the cell
there you go
you can click on the right click button
and and select the option of Link
now select the existing file or web page
option so if you are interested to learn
more on hyperlink in Excel we have a
dedicated tutorial on that please go
through hyperlinks in Excel by simply
learn which will explain you everything
about hyperlinks in Excel how to insert
them different types of documents to be
inserted and how it works in real time
for now let's try to insert the existing
web page
and go to documents navigate to
documents and inside this you have the
Excel basic PDF click on OK and it has
been added to your image so when you
click on it it will open the PDF
document attached to it so when you
hover over to the cell you can see it
will ask you a permission do you want to
continue or not just click on S ignore
the warning so you can see the PDF has
been successfully opened how to insert
image in Excel now let's get back to the
Practical mode now we are on our Excel
spreadsheet and here I'm trying to
insert some images onto my spreadsheet
so here we have company logos and
Company brand names so since we already
have the brand name so what we need to
add here is the brand logos okay so how
do I add such kind of an image into an
Excel spreadsheet that you might be
thinking that Excel spreadsheets are
just for data not multimedia image of
files right so no it's not it's
completely wrong you can also add your
images onto your Excel spreadsheets is
completely simple so click anywhere on
the Excel spreadsheet navigate to the
insert button select the illustrations
option from the Allens group click on
that and you know in the drop down you
can see the pictures icon or the
pictures button click on that
and select from this device or if you
have an online stock image you can take
that or you can also check out from
online pictures for now I'll select the
device this device
and here I have some images the images
what we need are simply learn and simply
code logos press ok
or insert so here you have them
now
you can also adjust the size of the
image using the small buttons here
pass it over here
and done
so you might be wondering is it all done
is there anything more to do or just
adding an image is done no most of the
times when you create or you work with
Excel spreadsheet you will not just you
know add some data and add a relevant
image to it most of the time you add
some graphs or you most of the time you
will add some charts uh to showcase the
data dashboard right so it will be
something like this so this is how you
add the image or graph onto your
dashboard and sometimes you might not
have enough place to display your entire
dashboard during those situations what
you do is you try to hide the row or
column so now let's try to hide this
particular room let us imagine that you
wanted to show only uh to uh charts and
there is no space for your third chart
in such scenarios you might want to hide
or remove that third chart okay so let's
try to hide it and see if gets if it
gets hidden or not when you try to hide
it you can see the column A has no data
and the row number four has been hidden
so we have three and five but what about
the image it is still present right so
if you want to make sure that the row
also hides the image then you might have
to do a little formatting with it so
select the image go to picture format
foreign
you can also right click and directly
navigate to picture format this opens up
a set of options and here you might want
to go to the third one which is picture
format third and select the properties
I'm here select the option of move and
size with sales so when you select this
when you try to hide this it will also I
mean the graph or the image will also
hide along with the row so that's how
you do it so slices in Excel are
software filters used along with Excel
tables or Excel pivot tables over a
large amount of data not just filtering
out data but slices also help you with
an easy understanding of the information
being extracted and displayed on the
screen now Microsoft Excel slices are
compatible with Windows and Macintosh
operating systems now let us understand
how to implement slicers in Excel so for
that we might want to get back to the
Practical mode that is starting a
Microsoft Excel
now we are on our Excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the Excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table this
table from Microsoft Excel has been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default Excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement this slices in Excel we might
want to create or convert the format of
database into a normal table for that
you can select all your data and just
press Ctrl T and that will allow you an
option called convert the data into
table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and in the filters group
select the option called slicer now you
will be provided with multiple options
since we have the columns employee ID
employee name Zone designation
Department salary employees date of
birth and employees date of Journey so
we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices now let me select the
first one that is Zone next designation
department and let's also select
employee name
now press OK and there you go we have
our slices
now let's try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done now let us imagine that we want
to see or take a look at the employees
who are working in the East Zone then we
have all the information displayed on
the screen who are working in the
Eastern they are Jack Tony Banner Fred
Etc and their Department designation etc
etc all on one single screen so this
really helps you while you're presenting
your data in a presentation now for a
change let's try to select the
department now if your client wants to
select the data from only analytics
Department then you might want to select
on the analytics key on the department
slicer and the echo you have an employee
called lookups who works in the East
Zone and his department is analytics and
his resignation is contract East and the
salary he is getting is 65
000.
now similarly
you can see that we have only selected
analytics and your client also wants
data from it support now you can see
that analytics is gone
but what if we want both analytics and
ID support then you have an option
called selected multiple then you can
select analytics and ID support and if
you want HR you can also do that and in
the zone if you want best along with
East then you can do the same east and
west and you have all the employee
details and in the designation let's try
to Select Senior trainee
okay select multiple senior trainee and
manager so that's how you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in Excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation so what is
summers in Excel
now you might want to calculate uh the
total sum of sales right so let us
assume that this is your entire store's
sales data and you wanted to calculate
the entire sum of sales so there is a
sum function in Excel where you just
have to you know select all the cells
and apply some function onto it and
you'll get the sum of all the sales
right so with something like this you
will select all the cells and then
you'll apply a sums function and you'll
get the sum here and average everything
right so this is fine but what if you
just wanted to find the sales that are
happening in only western region as you
can see our column f is based on region
so we have four regions South West East
and Central so your manager asks you to
find the sales happening in suppose say
a west region so how do you calculate it
would you manually go into each cell and
check if it's Western calculate that
will be time consuming right so what if
you had a method which could do it for
you just in a matter of few steps or few
clicks right so that's exactly sumifs so
it will basically add a condition
calculate the sum of sales where the
region is equals to West simple to like
or similar to SQL query right so that is
exactly what we're going to do in Excel
today that is using Summers now let me
add here sales of
west region now in the next cell let's
add a summers function remember there
are multiple sum functions in Excel so
when you type in s u n you can see so
many options based on sum right you just
have some followed by that you have some
if it is just some if not some ifs today
we are concentrating on some F's so not
just sum if we'll go to some F's so
we'll be having an option of placing
multiple if conditions there so let's
also try that more on that later now
let's press tab to select our sum ifs
function now okay we forgot another
important step so before we apply sumifs
we need to convert our table into a
table format yes it looks stable but
right now it's not in tabular format it
is in the format of database we know
that Microsoft Excel considers its data
as a database by default so to convert
the database into table just click
anywhere on the data and and press Ctrl
T so that you'll have a new dialog box
and it will ask if your table has
headers just make sure that you have
ticked in it our table does have headers
so select ok now our database has been
converted into a perfect table and it's
ready for applying Summers function so
now you can see our database has been
successfully converted into our table
now let's begin with our Summits now
again remember we are using some ifs
here not some if or sum so select some
ifs and press Tab and we have a service
function now the first step which column
are we looking at what are we finding
out right which is a sum range what sum
do you want for now we need sum of sales
so select the sales column and we have a
simple key function here let's hold Ctrl
again press shift and hold shift
together so we're holding Ctrl and shift
key together and now we're pressing
lower Arrow key once yes the entire
sales column has been selected comma Now
where do you want to look so we want to
look I mean which part of the table you
want to fetch right so this is the
region part we want to fetch right now
so again hold Ctrl and shift together
lower Arrow key the entire column is
selected now the next last part so we
want to look into the both of the
columns that is sales column and region
column now which type of data you want
so for now we want to Western type of
data the that is the sales data which is
happening only invest right so we'll
select this cell with the data as first
or you can also manually enter it for
now let's select the data so I'm
selecting this cell F7 which has data as
best right now let's close the
parenthesis and press enter so there you
go you have the sales happening in the
western region now you can also try to
format it in the form of currency so
let's use
dollars since it is based on American
states so let's use dollars so there you
go now we are having the sale state of
West now let's try to copy the same to
all the four cells and for now here
let's type in East
and this can be salt right and this can
be your central
there you go
now you can also copy the same formula
and make minor edits to it so here
instead of f8 you can select a East
so where is East here and press enter so
you have the sales related to East now
let's try to edit F9 with South
select South Region enter so you have
South sales and what remaining is
Central so let's edit Central as well
and press enter so there you go right
now you have all the separate sales data
from west east south and Central now
again uh you might want a bit more
granularity in data right or in your
reports right like you wanted to find
the sales data happening invest and you
wanted to find out the category based on
only Furnitures so your manager will ask
you okay a fantastic job so now just
give me another minute detail on the
data I want to calculate the sales
happening on West based on category
Furniture right so he wants furniture or
he wants office supplies only right you
can also do that it's not an issue at
all now let's try to copy this cell and
paste it here and sales invest let's add
another input here on furniture
right now you wanted to calculate the
sales happening in west region only on
furniture so you can also do that now we
can use the same formula as well just
copy paste the formula here right and
you can add few things here when you try
to add a comma it will automatically
generate the next criterator so it is
expecting that you are looking for
adding another criteria right now which
column you want you want category so
let's select category you want to select
all the cells same track Ctrl shift
lower key and again press comma and you
wanted to select Only Furniture so
select on furniture cell then now press
enter so there you go we successfully
have the sales data from west region
based on category Only Furniture so
that's how you do summers in Excel you
can also add a few more details to it
like in Furniture you can also look only
for tables so here you can see in west
region we have furniture sales data and
we have sales data of West Region based
on furniture which includes only tables
you can also do that using sum as
function in the same way all you have to
do is select the subcategory column and
select the cell which has the data as
tables goalsake and Excel so for this
tutorial we'll be considering the
students database now let's get back to
the Excel
so now we are on the Excel sheet and you
can see that in this particular Excel
sheet we have some student details we
have the serial numbers names row
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like math science computer
statistics social GK and the final marks
obtained percentage and total marks
right so let us imagine that a company
has come for an interview
so all these students are going to
attend an interview and the minimum
percentage to attend the interview will
be like 75 percent so you can see that
we have 75 here and all the students
have got above 75 except for the one
student who watches Mike right so for
Mike to attend the interview he needs 75
percentage or above so uh he can make
some modifications in one of these
subjects right so there is always an
exam after the exam called as
Improvement exam so if you can like this
course and extra marks in the subjects
which you have scored less so that you
can make up to the percentage what
you're expecting you can do that so here
in this particular sheet uh Mike has six
subjects right and in such subjects you
can see he has code 76 91 45 71 94 and
62. so out of these he have scored less
and one subject compared to all the
subjects one subject is really low that
is computers so what if he can give an
improvement exam and increase his
percentage to 75 right so that can be
done so if we can do some Brute Force
methods like we can change the marks
like 55 and then check this particular
one so it's getting 74 right so using
the brute force method will be a little
bit lengthy so you can do this because
it is just a small table which has least
number of data and you just have one
single cell to modify so that can be
done in small tables but what if you had
some table with hundreds of rows or
thousands of rows that will be time
consuming right so for that we have some
inbuilt functionality in Excel that is
called goal seek in Excel so for now
let's eliminate the marks here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65. now we need
the target as 75. okay so let's write it
as
Mike's Target right you need mic so mics
new Target as
75
[Music]
okay now to make sure that we need a
Mark here which can get mic to 75
percentage we will use the data
operation so here on the toolbar which
has file home insert Etc we have one
other option called as data so when you
click on data from toolbar you'll have
this ribbon and in this ribbon we have
various options so when you come into
forecast group we have an option called
what if analysis when you click on
what-if analysis you will have a set of
options out of which we have goal seek
now for goal seek we need to select a
table cell that is this particular table
cell that is M9 so we need the value 75
here right so what is the cell that you
need to change here for that you need to
select this one and select this
particular cell here right and now you
can select ok now you can see that Excel
has automatically run all the
permutations and combinations and has
come up with a number so that the
overall percentage of mic will be 75
percent right so the expected marks that
Mike should be getting in his computers
Improvement exam should be equal to 56
or greater than 56 to get the final
Target as 75 so that he can attend the
company's interview how to highlight
duplicate values in Excel now for that
let's get started with the Practical
mode now we are on our Excel spreadsheet
and this spreadsheet has some values of
employees that is their employee ID name
designation Department salary date of
birth and date of joining now our
concern is to highlight some cells which
are duplicate in this or some rows which
are duplicate so for example here you
can see on row number seven we have the
details of Martha
and you can see the same details of Mata
in the row number 14 as well right so
you need to eliminate those cells or you
need to eliminate those rows now you can
say there is a quick way just few clicks
and those will be eliminated that is
conditional formatting yes that is also
one way but I'll show you what's the
problem with that okay so let us select
the entire table and get into
conditional formatting and here you have
duplicate values highlight cell rules
where duplicate values
and there you go the problem so here we
have designation which is duplicated in
certain ways department and salary state
of joining right so there are certain
conditions or scenarios where you cannot
directly identify which is the duplicate
rule
again you can use the same for this
right so you can select the entire
column of employee ID and you can
identify the duplicate cells here since
the employee IDs are unique for everyone
so this is a way but let's dig a little
deeper and understand the way of
highlighting duplicates with an advanced
technique so let me cancel this and for
that let's create a new uh column
and let's name this as duplicate
flag
e flag
so the new column has been created which
is the flag so here we will be using a
simple formula that is
count F and here press tab to select the
formula and here we will be adding our
range that is which range are you
considering so the range will be the
employee ID since employee IDs are
unique for every employee
and
and let's press function F4 to fix it
and now
again the criteria and the criteria will
be the same cell that is A2 and now
close the bracket and press enter
now let's track the same formula to all
the rows
okay
now here we have now what you can do is
sort it in an advanced way go to sort
and filter
and custom sort and here you'll be
sorting by the D flag and it will be
smallest to largest
so now you can apply the conditional
formatting to highlight it you can
select the column Edge or the D flag go
to conditional formatting highlight cell
rules and here you can get into greater
than
and give the value as 1
okay
so all the cells which are you know
repeated multiple times will be selected
here and they will be highlighted with a
selected color what you have given so
I've given Red so now you can select
these cells and I'll let them all delete
them from your spreadsheet
and now all your data in the spreadsheet
is unique and clean so that's how you
highlight duplicate cells in Excel for
this particular task we will be
considering the student database now
let's get into practical mode and start
our Excel so on my screen you can see
some data related to students now let us
try to duplicate some of the rows here
okay
so we have selected the rows 8 9 10 and
11. now we shall copy them
paste them so now these are the
duplicate elements right
now there might be possibilities about
the duplication of class because all the
students all the 10 students are in same
class so there might be a duplication
but we are not looking for such kind of
duplications right we are looking for
the duplication of the entire row for
example we have the details of mic over
here in the eighth row which has the
roll number of serial number S7 name as
mic roll number class blood group and
subject scores percentage round of
percentage and total marks so the entire
eighth row has been copied here and it
is in the row number 12 we have the
exact same details so what if you have
the exact same rows duplicated so that's
what we're gonna deal with we're gonna
eliminate the duplicate rows all
completely together
now to carry over this task we have to
select the data from toolbar so you have
various options file home insert Etc so
you need to select the data and inside
the data toolbar we have the ribbon and
inside ribbon you have got the duplicate
values or remove duplicates option in
the airplane so select all the data
select remove duplicates and now you can
see that we have all our column names
over here and make sure that you have
selected my data as headers and then
select ok
and now you can see that Excel has
automatically removed four duplicate
values so four duplicate values are
found and removed 10 unique values
remain
now another type of removed duplicates
can also be done so you can see that
here we have another data set which has
phone numbers or phone names that is
phone makers that are Samsung Huawei
Vivo Oppo Etc so there are some
duplicate values and this have copy
pasted it then so now you can also do
that so
just select all the data
and now go into home
and select conditional formatting and
here select highlight cell rules and
inside that you have duplicate values
selecting this option will help you
identify the duplicate values in your
data set but not to remove them so you
can select that and you can see the
duplicate values are highlighted over
here in the red column
now again you can get back to data and
select the option of remove duplicates
and select OK and the duplicate values
will be automatically eliminated
so that's how you delete or eliminate
duplicate values in a data set and you
can also see that we have another
duplicate in this particular row and if
you wanted to select a particular row
and eliminate the duplicate signals to
do that now for that you need to go to
the same process remove duplicates and
here Microsoft Excel is asking you if
you had to expand the selection to the
entire data set or you want to continue
with the selected data set Etc or
selected column itself so for that you
need to select the continue with the
current selection and remove duplicates
and press OK and you can see one
duplicate value is found and it has been
removed and six unique values remain
so that's how you use that is how to
eliminate rows in Excel now let's get
started with the Practical mode
now we are on our spreadsheet and you
can see I have some sample data on my
spreadsheet and it does have some blank
rows
now how do I eliminate these blank rows
so one step is you can you know select
the entire row and try to right click
and delete it
again this sort of method might take us
to get rid of all the blank rows and
most of the time you might end up even
selecting the rows with data in it right
so if I want to select multiple rows
then I'll be selecting some rows with
data as well which might be a little
Troublesome in the future now let's try
to use the easier way now for that go to
the find and select option select the
go to special option and in that select
the blanks option and press ok now hold
Ctrl key and press minus key
and you will have an option of deleting
the cells now select the entire row now
we are selecting the entire rows with
blank data and press OK and the cells
will be shifted now this was simple but
let me show you another example so even
here we have some blank groups but in
between those blank rows for example
take cell 17 or cell d17 or row 17 we
have some data testing
and here in the employee ID we have some
data in a26
and again in beat 39 we have some data
that is first name
right in such scenarios how do I
eliminate data so we have a simple Logic
for it so all we need to do is add
another row which is to count the number
of cells in the row now that can be
count
now here equals to the function is Count
a
a step
and
the sales will be from
A2 to G2
press enter now you have seven
so now we are basically calculating the
number of cells so if you apply the same
to the entire uh data set let's drag it
and there you go so there are certain
places where you find zero which are
basically the empty columns right
now let's do some formatting if you need
let's try to add filters
Ctrl a Ctrl D and now table will have
filters and headers
now here you can see the drop down icon
click on that now instead of select all
what you can do is Select zero now you
will be highlighted with all the rows
which do not have any data select all
those and press on delete or
what you can do is the same way Ctrl
minus
there you go
now
clear the filter
now all you have is the data
without any kind of blank rows so all
the rows that had some amount of data
are retrained and all the data or all
the cells or all the rows which do not
have any data which are completely blank
they have been eliminated that is how to
convert numbers to words
now here on my sheet you can see we have
some numbers that is ten dollars or ten
point two zero dollars twenty two
dollars fifty three point one two
dollars twelve dollars and hundred and
ten dollars now the task is to convert
these numbers into word format that is
representing the numbers alphabetically
right this might be a little curious and
we also might end up searching for a
predefined method which is not readily
available in Excel but there is a way
where you can create a function using
Excel VBA or macros now again creating a
macro is completely complex now
identifying the trouble Microsoft has
already come up with a readily available
macro code on their official website
which will support the various versions
of Microsoft Excel starting from
Microsoft Excel 365 to all the way up to
the older Excel version that is 2010.
now you can scroll down and use this
particular macro function which
Microsoft has readily made us available
and use this to create our own macro and
Excel VBA now let's get back to Excel
and you can create a macro using the
developer option now developer options
will not be readily available in
Microsoft Excel to activate developer
option go to home and go to the options
menu in the last
and here go to customize ribbon and here
in the second drop down menu you can see
developer option by default it will not
be checked click on the check option to
activate developer options and press ok
now you have your developer options
ready click on developer options click
on Visual Basic and here to insert a new
macro click on the insert button click
on module and a new macro window is
readily available for you now Ctrl V to
paste your code and your function is
with the name number to text right now
close the macro
foreign
and here your function will be readily
available
equals to and the function name was
number to text press tab to select the
function and select the cell where you
have the data close the function press
enter now drag the same formula across
all the cells and here you have the text
converted from numbers so here we have
ten dollars twenty cents and you have
ten dollars twenty cents twenty two
dollars and no sense 53 dollars and 12
cents 12 dollars and no sense and
hundred and ten dollars with no sense
now that's how you can convert numbers
to words using the macro which is
predefined for excel in the Microsoft
website that is how to convert cells
from low case to uppercase in Excel now
let's get back to the Practical node and
now we are on our Excel spreadsheet so
here we have some text boxes on the
column A and on column V we have lower
and upper okay so um we have a mix of uh
uppercase and lowercase in our text so
first we'll try to convert them to
lowercase and then we'll try to convert
the entire text into uppercase so for
that you need to press on equal symbol
and select the lower formula
tap and you selected the function and
now click on the cell A3 that's your
cell address and press on ok now all the
letters are converted to low case so we
had J in the uppercase which is
converted to lowercase now all you can
do is drag the formula to all the cells
and it will be applied to all the cells
right now let's similarly try to convert
into uppercase and tap space and there
you go you have selected the formula now
the cell address
press enter
and drag the same address I mean drag
the same formula to all the cell
addresses and the echo all the cells are
converted to uppercase now we are on the
Excel spreadsheet so you can see that I
have five different sheets of the same
data so why do we have that so I'll be
explaining you how to sort data for
multiple parameters so firstly we will
try to sort data in the form of numbers
right so let us imagine that this data
is being shared with you by your manager
and he wants you to sort this data based
on the salary numbers so he wants you to
arrange the data in the form of
ascending order or descending order may
be which will help him find the employee
with the highest salary right so how
could you do that
so it's really simple you could sort the
entire data just within a few clicks so
how would you do that so since you're
focusing on salary select any cell from
the salary column only right select this
particular column and select any cell in
the salary column get into the sort and
filter options and here select this sort
of arrangement you need that is largest
or smallest or the smallest to largest
since the problem statement was to find
the highest salary click on largest to
smallest and there you go so you have
Tony and the designation senior and he
works in IIT support and he draws the
highest salary of eighty thousand right
and there's also another one which is
pepper and she works for the analytics
team
and now
the next sheet let's get into the sheet
too and this time let us imagine that
you wanted to you know arrange or sort
the data based on the employee date of
joining or date of birth right again if
you wanted to arrange the data in which
you find the youngest employee or the
oldest employee of the organization you
can do that click on any cell in the
date of birth column and go back to the
sort and filter and here you will be
seeing the options sort oldest to the
newest or the sort the data from newest
to the oldest so since we want the
oldest employee select oldest newest and
there you go so the oldest employee is
Alfred who is an associate designation
employee and he works in the admin
department and he's drawing the salary
of 25 000. so that's how you can sort
the data when you are trying to sort the
data based on date wise so first we try
to sort the data on the number wise so
you can apply the same for your employee
ID salary and if there is any
possibility you can do that as well and
if you want to apply the same sorting
based on dates you can do that as well
using the Sorting function in the same
way now let's get back onto the third
sheet and here
now a single column wise is perfectly
fine there is no issues with that now
you wanted to you know let's imagine
that you have two columns okay let's
eliminate a few columns here
Maybe
we can eliminate the employee ID and
okay let's keep a few columns so we'll
just keep employee name and employee
salary
okay so here we are trying to
demonstrate if you are uh trying to sort
the data using one cell in the column B
will it maintain its relationship with
the cell a okay that's our query right
so let's see I'll go a little detail so
let us imagine that you wanted to sort
this data based on highest salary okay
so when you do that will it also impact
the cells in the column A so it will
basically impact but just uh it's a
query right any of you viewers might
have that variable I uh if in case if I
try to sort the data based on this will
it affect the sales on the rest of the
data set okay so in basically it will
impact so I'll try to you know sort the
data based on ascending order
so this is the smallest to largest and
you can see uh the Tony and pepper so
since I selected the cell in the column
B it also impacted the change on the
cells of column A so that's how the
Sorting works now we'll get to a little
Advanced sorting techniques so here we
try to I mean already we try to sort the
data based on numbers based on alphabets
based on you know uh date of birth right
so I think we forgot the uh ascending or
you know sorting based on alphabets
let's do that as well select any um cell
in the column A and go to certain filter
try selecting a to z or okay let's try
to Z to A okay so here you can see the
names have been sorted based on the
descending order from Z to A right so so
far we tried on alphabets so far we
tried on numbers date of birth and
a couple of more things so let's dig a
little deeper and try to sort based on
colors right so for that you don't uh
you know find that uh extra setting here
in the regular certain filter so you
might want to get into the data option
and here you'll find another sort
function which is a little at once so
that's how you do it so since we have
colored in this cell or column of salary
select that salary and we're going with
cell value so in the cell values section
select the cell color and here on the
cell color options you'll have green
blue and yellow that's what we have used
in our cells so let's keep Green in the
first position which is on top and press
ok now you will see greens means ordered
at the first position now yellow and
blue are left up so why is that so
because you didn't provide it right so
you can do what that as well I mean you
can always add uh the setting to it
right select any cell go to sort and add
a level and then again select the salary
and sell values to sell colors and now
the cell color in the second position
would be blue
and that will be on bottom
and they can add another level
the same salary
the cell values will be cell color and
it's a yellow will be somewhere in
between or bottom okay so based on
hierarchy uh it will be selecting press
ok
and
there you go so you have cell yellow and
blue at the bottom and green add the top
position as per your suggestions
now we are on the last sheet so here in
this last sheet we are going to you know
dig a little deeper into the advanced
sorting methods so previously we tried
to apply the advanced sorting methods
for colors now we'll try to apply the
advanced sorting methods based on the
data set we have here I mean the data we
have in our data set right so select the
sort option and let's add a few details
right so firstly let's sort the column
employee ID okay so let's have these
smallest to largest or
yeah now that would be good now let's
add another level where we will sort
okay uh I think we will sort based on
employee name that would be a little
better so let's try to uh sort it on
employing name here and here will be
employee salary
okay now the cell values and this would
be from A to Z and the salary will be
from the smallest to largest so
basically what we are trying to do is we
are trying to sort the employee list
based on employment from A to Z so the
employees name starting from A to Z will
be ordered first and another subset of
the Sorting will be done based on
highest salary that is smallest to
highest so let us imagine that we have
three employees with name starting from
a and their salaries are ten thousand
twenty thousand and thirty thousand so
how would it sort so it will sort
basically uh in the alphabetical order
first so first three names will be
sorted and then it will also have
another condition to sort the data where
keeping the lower salary on top and
higher salary and the last right so uh
this is how the algorithm works for
sorting now let's press OK and see the
output
so there you go the names are Alfred and
you have the highest salary here
smallest to highest so this is 25 000
next we have Banner bonds and Ben so
here you might be seeing why we have
been in the third position despite he
has a low salary and name starts with B
right so here it is trying to work based
on the alphabets in the order right so B
A and B E it's not just comparing the
first letter it's also comparing the
following letters as well right so n
comes first R comes later so bonds is
pushed to the second position a comes
first and E comes later so B A let us R
push to the first position and Ben is
pushed to the third position so that's
how A2 works right so accordingly the
set for B A is created here 3540 next
Ben 12 and next you have Bobby Brown
Brock Chris Clark right so that's how
the data has been organized and sorted
based on multiple levels of parameters
you provide for sorting so first we will
understand what exactly is standard
deviation so standard deviation is a
calculated square of variance Now what
is variance okay nothing to worry let us
also understand what is variance
now the next part variance so what is
variance variance is a measure of
variability
it is calculated by taking the average
of squared deviations from the mean now
what are deviations so slowly you can
understand that we are getting into the
topic of statistics and graphs so uh
before getting deep into it let's
understand what is deviation so the
deviation is a measure that is used to
find the difference between the observed
value and the expected value of a
variable in simple terms deviation is
the distance from the center point so
for example when you are going through a
graph so you will be expecting some
value right and if you get some
difference that is above or below the
expected point that is called the
deviation what is the difference between
the expected point and the obtained
point so that is the deviation now next
is the observed value so the observed
value is the value that you get in real
time unlike the predicted value so now
you might be thinking to calculate
standard deviation we might need a few
parameters and you're exactly right so
to calculate standard deviation in Excel
you need variance and then you need
deviation and then you need mean right
so all these parameters are supposed to
be calculated first and then you will be
having the final formula to calculate
standard DB now that we understood the
theoretical and formula based
explanation about standard deviation
it's time we calculate the standard
deviation using one of the most popular
business intelligence tool that is
Microsoft Excel so let's get back to the
Practical mode
so now we are on the Practical mode and
we have some sample data on my screen
right now let me expand it a little bit
yeah there you go
so as discussed before to calculate
standard deviation we might require the
mean variance deviation and deviation
square and then we can calculate the
standard deviation so let's go step by
step so the first one is calculating sum
right so to calculate average we might
need some of all this course so we have
the index values that is 1 to 10 and
scores of each index value that is 1 to
10 right now let's calculate the sum of
all values here press tab to select the
function
select and drag these cells press enter
and then you have this course now you
want number of indexes so clearly you
can see we have 10 but still let's count
them
c o u n t tab space to select and select
the number of cells press enter and you
have count now what's the mean so mean
is simply the average of all the numbers
right so you can either divide the sum
by count or you can simply use the
average function so let's try to use the
average function so that we also have an
idea of how the average function Works
press tab to select it and select all
the cells and press enter now you have
the average or mean value
now we have the mean value and now after
finding the mean value we are supposed
to find out the deviation so remember
the deviation that is the difference
between the obtained value and the
predicted value right so the operand
value is this one which is here in C2
and the predicted value is this one
that is 82.6 that's our mean right
according to formula we are supposed to
eliminate the value of obtained minus
the mean right so select uh the cell
equals to C2
minus the obtained value that is mean
now press F4 to freeze the value and now
press enter
so that you can freeze the value and
drag the formula across all the cells
now you have the deviation
right
now the next step is to find the sum of
all the deviation numbers so I either
you can apply the sum formula to all
these numbers or you can just drag this
cell over here and the formula will be
automatically copied now similarly the
count function to count all the values
let us drag it and you will have it over
here right now the next step is to find
out the square deviations or the square
of the deviations which is really simple
all you have to do is equals to select
the cell and see that small hat kind of
logo on the number six use that
now into two press enter
you have the square
similarly drag the same formula across
all the cells and you will have your
square numbers similarly drag this
summation function over here so you will
have the sum of this and the count
number as well
now comes the final formula
now we have the mean value that is over
here let's color it
foreign Square
[Music]
now that is which is this one let's
collect it in a different shape and we
have deviation as well let's color it in
a different shape
now we need to find the variance and
after we find the variance the last step
is to count the standard division or
calculate the standard deviation so what
is the formula to calculate the variance
so for variance you need the sum of
deviation Square
divided by total number of values
minus 1.
press enter and that's your variance now
the standard deviation so the standard
deviation is really simple you need to
calculate
the
variance to the power of
0.5
and that's your standard deviation
so that's how you calculate standard
deviation in Excel how to create drop
down list in Excel now for that we might
want to switch to the Practical mode
now we are on our Excel spreadsheet and
here you can see I'm trying to create an
calendar for the employees in the
company where you might have to you know
write down the day and month and year or
week of your birth date or maybe your
joining date or maybe also your last
working day right this might be useful
for all the employees to you know avoid
them from writing it down manually
so how do I create it so it takes a few
simple steps all it takes is some data
validation methods and also there is an
exclusive video specifically made on
data validation in Excel linked to which
is in the description box below or you
can search it on our official YouTube
channel now you can see that the word
calendar is on the first cell that is A1
but we have four cells below it that is
A3 B3 C3 and D3 so you might want to add
this to all the cells right like maybe
in the middle so for that you can do the
option of margin Center also there is a
tutorial on Origin Center about all the
options available in this particular
thing so you can go through that also
and here we have done the first step now
all we need is day month year and week
so in a calendar or in a month you'll
have days from 28 29 30 or 31 days right
so let's create a list or the drop down
menu for that so that whenever you click
it right so whenever you click on that
particular cell you will have the list
of all the days available right so let's
get started with that
let's create a new sheet
so why are we creating a new sheet you
won't want that all the numbers in your
calendar sheet right over here right so
with that so we are creating a new sheet
and all the data will be available here
so here let's write down the days
first and here the second number also
you can use the option of Slash fill so
that you can you know reduce the effort
here so you can see the flash flow
option over here all you need to do is
select the cells and drag them down
until you get your required dates right
so let's keep it to 31 days like when
you have the days
something it's going to be your days and
here
now the next option was month right yeah
month and year now using the same Flash
Fill option you will you know add the
months into your sheet
so this will be Sunday
so Excel has this smart Flash Fill
option where you can just drag the data
and everything will be filled according
to your requirements so Sunday to
Saturday
now the next one right that is your
month
so same as the before process will
create January
you can use the Flash Fill option and
all the way up to December now the last
one was the year
so 1990
and
1991 if you can select the cells and
Flash Fill Up to
2022 Maybe
yeah 2022 should be good enough
now this is The Flash full option you
have here and also we have an exclusive
tutorial on Flash Fill all together you
can go through it for a detailed
explanation as well now coming back to
the original sheet so this is where you
create your drop down list right so
select the cell where you want to add
the drop down list navigate to data and
then here is your data validation menu
so we have a variety of data validation
options over here there is an exclusive
tutorial on that you can go through it
for now we'll look into the list option
only because we want to create a drop
down list right so here it will ask for
soaps click on the source here the
source bar right now navigate to sheet
number two where we have the days
options select the range
so this will be your range and select OK
also you can add some message here right
what you can do is in case if there is
an error or something right you don't
want that to be happening so all you
need to do is uh write down select from
drop down
foreign
drop down only
so this could be our message select from
drop down only the title is
select options or just options
in case if there's an error you can
write down your title as invalid data
and you can write on the messages
please select
from drop down only
so in case of someone tries to write as
32 or 33 to check the Integrity of your
data validation then they will encounter
an error and an error message and then
they must be understanding what exactly
they try to do and if it's correct or
wrong right so this is to make sure that
whatever the data you enter is correct
and valid
so okay and here you can see select from
the drop down list only options with
option list as title and let's try to
enter 32 right and when you press enter
you will see an error so the error
messages invalid data please try to
select from drop down only so you can go
over retry and select it from there
right
so let's eliminate them and now select
something from the drop down so let's
take it out
maybe 10 right so this is how you clear
the day one now let's try to do with the
month
same data validation option
settings will be list and Source will be
this one
think I made a mistake here so let's
cancel this and go back to sheet 2 and
rename this as our week
yeah now coming back to the month again
it will be a list
and the source will be in sheet 2
navigate to the sheet 2 and select your
range and the input message the same
options
select from drop down only
and error alert title will be invalid
data
this one will be please select
from drop down
okay and that's done now let's continue
with here as well let's quickly do the
same
foreign
but this is your list press OK and
lastly the week
sing
process it will be a list
shows will be in your sheet too
the input message
options
title invalid data
let's drop down
only
right so your drop down list is ready
now so the month will be anything So
currently we have me and here can be
anything anywhere so let's take it as
1997 and we can be you know the edges in
the week and so what was 10th of May
1997.
let's check our calendars
so it was a Saturday
so it was a Saturday and that's how you
create a drop down list in Excel and if
you want you can also add borders to
your calendar right
so that's how it's done how to add date
and Excel spreadsheet now there are
multiple ways to add date to Excel
spreadsheet for example equals to today
this is a shortcut method and you can
enter
done you will have today's date but
again
there is some problem with this kind of
approach so today's state is 4th of
September 2022. now if you open the same
spreadsheet after today that is tomorrow
or day after tomorrow then you will have
a concurrent date that is 5th of
September or 6th of September right the
date will always vary or get updated
according to time now you don't want to
change that or you don't want that to be
happening with employee state of joining
right it should be stagnant it should
not vary right so there is another
shortcut way apart from using the date
time functions there is a keyboard
shortcut where you can add date to excel
that is control semicolon so this is the
shortcut way to add date to your Excel
spreadsheet and this particular date
will not change this will remain the
same constant date throughout the time
now there is a chance where you might
also have to add time to your
spreadsheet that is date of joining and
time of joining right so there is
another simple shortcut where you can
add
Time by just pressing three keys that is
holding Ctrl holding shift and pressing
semicolon then you'll have the time
so this is how you can add date to your
Excel spreadsheet and add time to your
Excel spreadsheet and this date and time
will remain constant it will not vary
like the 3D function that we have used
here so you can see on my screen we are
on the Excel spreadsheet and on my
spreadsheet you can see dates in column
A and A different formats n column C D E
and F respectively Now by default the
data type or the data present in the a
column will be considered as general and
there are a few situations where even if
you try to format the date in your
format like you know the customized
format you may not be able to do it
because it's still under the general
data type so for that for being on a
safer side what we will do is select the
data and navigate to the data toolbar
and in that you have the text to columns
option press that and remember to have
the delimited icon you know you might be
having the dash as 0 icon or slash as
your icon for the delimited thing and
select that and next next and here you
can see right it's in general mode so
you can press on date and DMI will be a
date format that is date month and year
now click on finish so it's been
formatted now now let's copy the same
data and paste it in all the four
formats so that we'll see the different
formats that we can change to or
customize to
right
so there you go let's expand the columns
a little bit now we have day month and
year
so now you might want to change a couple
of things right for example you wanted
to change okay let's see the menu so the
way is to select the cells and right
click and select the format cells option
and in here you can see the date
function and then here you can see
different types of modifications that
you can do to your data right so
you might want to also change your days
based on the location so right now we
are in India and imagine if you wanted
to you know change something based on us
or if you are if you're having your
client in us and he wants the dates and
US format you can also change that so
here you can see English United States
and press on that press OK and you can
see it's been changed to us format where
you have EOS in the first place months
in the second place and dates in the
last place right and now let us imagine
that your client does not want the dates
all he needs is just months right you
can also do that get back to the format
sales option go to custom and here
instead of uh you know a month date and
year you all you can do is just write
down month and year and select ok so
you'll have only month and your not the
dates now your client is being a little
more you know he wants a little more
detail and he wants you to add a lot of
granularity to your data which includes
day time Etc everything right so you can
also do that so the same way go to
format sales custom and here I think
it's indeed itself
so
let's navigate a little
yeah here so you have the day date month
and year press ok so there you go right
so that's how you can do it
and now let's try a little bit more if
we have a few more options pending
so go to format cells
and custom
and you also have
timings
so here you have date month year and the
timings
press OK and there we have all the
timings as well so since these dates are
you know I created them just a few
moments ago to keep it simple so I did
not have to add the diamonds here so if
you are Keen about adding the timings
you can also do that for example if you
wanted to add the timings of the
employees logged in and log that you can
also do that using the same format that
is how to calculate H in Excel so for
that let's get back to the Practical
mode and you can see now we are on our
Excel spreadsheet and you can see we
have a column of dates and on the column
B we have age now how do you calculate
the age using the read of word so this
is completely simple all you have to use
is the dated IF function or if you also
call it as date diff function based on
your choice we also have a specific
entire tutorial based on date diff in
Excel for further information that video
will be linked in the description box
below you can go through it or you can
use the end screens and I Cuts linked to
this video to get back to the tutorial
based on date diff in Excel now let's
calculate the age of these dates or
these people with these date of births
so all you have to do is type equals to
and type dated f
and open a bracket we need three
parameters here that is the date of
birth that is the first parameter now
the second one is the today function
because you're calculating the age of
these people as per today right so we
have a 2d function in Excel press on Tab
to select it and give a close bracket
now comma and if you wanted to calculate
the age in terms of days you have to uh
you know give d as the input
yeah here it should be D as the input
and don't forget to use the double
quotes here and if you use the single
course there might be an error so use
double quotes if you want it in the Days
part you can give days and if you want
it in months you can give months for now
we want an ESO we will be giving y as
the third parameter and press enter
there you go you have the H here in 26
years you can drag the same function and
you have the ages here as you wanted
right so this is how you calculate age
in Excel now we have started our
Microsoft Excel and here we have our MD
worksheet so dated IF function is
majorly used to find the differences
between two individual dates so it is
also called as dated F by a few people
and a few people also reference it to
date diff that is State difference so
anything is good now to find the
difference between any two dates let's
select a few dates so the first date
would be let us imagine that you're an
employee and you wanted to find out how
many errors that you've been working
with an organization so for that you
might want to need today and the date
where you join the company right so it
might be need of joining and today
so what's the difference
right so let us imagine that you joined
the organization somewhere around 2010
0 1
zero five
2010
and
today so for today I can you can give
any particular date
let us imagine that uh today is first of
January 2021 or 2022
now we have up both the date status the
joining date and the current date which
can be the current date so that they can
be anything so you might be watching
this on a different date as well so the
date of that day for today would be a
little different so we'll imagine that
today's date as an imaginary lead now we
might want to find the different status
in terms of years
so you wanted to find the difference in
terms of years so here you can find the
difference in terms of Errors days and
months as well so currently let's try to
find out the difference in terms of
years so for years you might want to
specify the third parameter in the
dative function as y if you wanted once
you have to give the M as the third
parameter and if you wanted to find the
days you might want to give d as the
third parameter so we have discussed the
third parameter so what are the first
two parameters right so the first two
parameters are the first date and the
last date so the first date in this
situation is your date of joining and
the last date or the final date which
you want here as your today so let's
find the difference so for that equals
to
so it can be dated if or date div
ided if and the first date which is the
A2 and comma the last day that is P2 and
your parameter third parameter in terms
of years that is Y close the bracket and
press enter so there you go you have
your date here so it's been like 11
years that you're working with your
organization so that's how you find out
the differences so we have 11 years
because we did not finish the 12th year
completely so if we had given the month
as maybe six
where we have finished our total years
then it will automatically change to 12
years
so that's how you work with dated F how
to calculate time difference between two
different timings using Excel now let's
get on to the Practical mode now we are
on our Excel spreadsheet as you can see
on my Excel spreadsheet let me expand it
we have two different timings that is in
and out so here we are considering a
scenario where we are calculating the
total number of hours worked by an
employee in an organization so the end
time will be the time where the employee
logged in and the out time will be the
time when the employee logged out so
here we have made some minor cell
formatting so when you right click on
any of the cell you can get back to the
formatting cells option and in that
option we have selected the AM PM so
there is also another option of choosing
the 24 hour timing that is 1320 uh 1330
so this represents the 24 hour format
but since we are you know working on
Office timings let's keep it as AM PM
okay so there you go so we have our
timings of in and out now to calculate
the time difference between the end time
and out time so this particular
calculation is completely simple all you
have to do is press equals to select
outline minus select in time so there
you go press enter and you have the
total number of hours the employee has
been working in your organization so
here also we have made some minor cell
formatting so usually it comes out as Am
Pm right but instead of that we have
made a minor cell formatting we have
navigated into time and we have selected
the 24 hour formatting so that we have
just ours in our output so that's how we
have calculated the time difference
between two n times and out times of an
employee using Excel that is calculating
percentage in Excel now let's get into
practical mode so on my screen you can
see a simple spreadsheet with student
names and their marks on my sheet so we
will be calculating what are the total
marks obtained by the students and
overall subjects and calculate what is
the percentage now we will carry forward
a few simple inbuilt functions in Excel
to calculate that first we will be
calculating the sum of marks so here
equals to sum function
and select the range of cells
close the bracket press enter
so you have the sum now
so we have to calculate it repeat so by
clicking on the same formula now we have
the total of all the subjects for
individual students and now let's
calculate percentage so usually we use
the you know divide by option that is
divide the total number of marks written
by the total number of marks available
that is we will be dividing 407 by 500
and then we will be multiplying that
into 100 so that's how we calculate the
percentage so
cell G2 divided by cell H2 press enter
and you will end up with you know the
decimal format that's perfectly all
right now we have also extended the same
formula for all our cells now select
this overall column or select the
highlighted cells right and get into the
data type here you have General so
that's why we have got that uh decimal
format but when you press percentage
you'll have the actual percentage of all
the students according to their Max
achieved so that's how you calculate
percentage in Excel that is how to
calculate average in Excel now let's get
started with the Practical mode
now you can see that I have sales data
on my worksheet so let us imagine that
your manager asks you to find the
average of sales happening in your
company right so let's navigate to the
bottom most cell and you know write it
down as average here
okay average sales
so here this is a cell where you want to
keep your average right so here we'll be
writing a small formula that is average
and tap to select it now you must select
the array of data right
so this is my adding since average is an
array function and now press enter so
there you go you have the average sales
data that happened in your company
roundoff formula in Excel
now for this particular tutorial we will
be using the student data set
now let's get back to the Practical mode
and start our Microsoft Excel
now we are in the Microsoft Excel and as
you can see on my sheet okay let me
expand this
so as you can see on my screen we have
the data set belonging to students so we
have 10 students and every one of them
has name roll number class plug group
and marks Etc and at the end we have the
person page and as you can see we have
the percentage in terms of float values
and we have a lot of decimal values like
8 and above so what if you wanted to
just have one or two digits after the
actual percentage like 80.6 or 80.66
right it would be a little bit more or
good to read right so that's what a
roundoff actually means so now let's
work on having rounded off values for
the percentage now let's create a new
column
let's name it as a
round off
percentage
great
so to actually perform the round off
formula we do have a predefined method
for that for that you just have to type
in
equals to round
and then we have round up and around
down so both of them perform the same
operation let's select a round up
and this is the n column and the row
number is three
so we'll have to press M3 and the number
of values after the decimal point for
now let's select one
and there you go press enter and the
value should be rounded off now 80.66 is
being rounded off to 80.7 now when you
drag the cell
to the all the rows and you can see all
the values will be rounded off
here you can see 75.16 has been rounded
off to 75.2 and 82.33 has been rounded
off to 82.4 so we end up with having
rounded off values now we are on the
spreadsheet so here what exactly are
page breaks so page breaks are something
which help you during your trying to
print your data or present your data in
the form of a web page right in those
times you cannot fit your entire Excel
data in one spreadsheet or one paper or
one web page right so in those scenarios
Excel will try to eliminate a few parts
of your spreadsheet or it will try to
split the spreadsheet
so how exactly it looks like so go to
the view option and click on The View
and click on page break preview here you
can see the dotted lines right so these
are the things which separate your data
in form of pages so that it can be
printable on one single page
so some of the times the user or the X
User manually inserts a page break right
so how do you insert it just go to the
page layout and here you can see the
page breaks insert a page break and we
have successfully inserted a page break
again go to the view go to page preview
and here you can see the solid line so
these solid ones are the ones which are
inserted by the users or anyone who had
the access to the data now how do we
eliminate them right so we can eliminate
them and we can try to you know get the
sheet back of the normal way so all you
have to do is click on the cell which
has the page break which is right under
the page break go to the insert
please break yeah page layout menu go to
the breaks option click on remove page
break and there you go you have
successfully eliminated the page break
and page break preview to make sure that
the page break has been successfully
removed so you can not see that anymore
so that's how you try to insert or
eliminate a page break in Excel Dax and
Excel is a sophisticated formulas type
language that comes in handy while
working with relational data and
extracting information via Dynamic
aggregation functions Dax in Excel
stands for data analysis Expressions Dax
functions are completely familiar to the
general and default functions that are
available in Excel
now tax allows users to perform slightly
escalated and advanced and custom
calculations upon various data types
like character data date time time
intelligence functions and many more and
in tax there are a variety of functions
such as backstable valued functions
backs filter functions dags aggregation
functions time intelligence functions
date and time information time logical
variant and many more now in today's
session we will look into one such type
of Dax function in Excel that is Dax
date and time function in Excel now
without further Ado let's get into
practical mode
and we have started a Microsoft Excel
inside Excel we have opened a new blank
worksheet Now navigate to data option in
the toolbar and in that go to
the powerpivot window
now we have entered the powerpivot
window and inside that you can see the
option of get external data click on
that and you can see a variety of
options that is you can get the external
data from a database you can get from
web servers that is from data service
and you have also other forms of data
sources and existing connections for now
we will take other forms of data that is
a Microsoft Excel data which is in our
local system
select next now provide the location of
your folder just browse
and we will select Dax employee data
open
and there you go we have our data
connected to our PowerPoint window click
on next
and there you go you have the selected
table and Views click finish and you can
see the data getting imported into your
powerbeard window
there you go by default if you want to
add any tax related functions into your
powerpivot window you'll have an
external added column over here which
looks something like this if there is
not an external column you can also add
the column it's not a big trouble now we
have some data here that is the employee
ID employee name designation of the
employee Department of the employee
salary and joining date Etc
okay let's expand this View and see
what's what's more in it
so this column is the date of birth and
this column is the employee joining date
right now we have so much of data now
let us imagine that we want to calculate
the retirement age of all the employees
so now let's rename the column to
retirement
date
so we have our new column that is
retirement date now we will make use of
Dax date time functions to calculate the
age and find out the exact retirement
date of that particular employee so let
us imagine that every employee will
retire after the age of 65. so we have
our date of birth of every employee and
the joining date of every employee now
we'll come up with attacks date and time
function and calculate the age and then
we will find the retirement date of that
employee
now every tax function starts with the
same method or the same way as the
simple Excel default method starts that
is by starting with an equals to and
then we will find e data
edit and
and now our first parameter that is the
start date that is the employee uh the
date where the employee joined the
organization so our sheet name is sheet1
now our joining date is in the F7 column
select F7 press tab to select it and
comma now how many months so each and
every year will have 12 months so 12
months into the age that is 65 Star 65
and now you can close the function and
press enter and then you'll find the
retirement date of that particular
employee
so there you go so we have the employee
dates that is Employee Retirement dates
for all the employees so the first one
that is Jack has the retirement date of
19 February 2085 and similarly Jennifer
has her retirement date at 15th of
August 2084. so that's how we use the
Dax functions in Excel so this is one of
the several Dax functions in Excel that
is Dax date and time functions in Excel
how to create a pivot table in Excel
now let's get started with the Practical
mode we are on our Excel spreadsheet now
creating a pivot table is just away from
a few clicks trust me it's just a couple
of clicks and you'll have your pivot
table ready to operate now click any
cell or select any cell on your
spreadsheet which has the data and
navigate to insert menu on the toolbar
and select pivot table and that's how
simple it is now automatically Excel
will choose your data you can see the
lines over here dotted line that means
the Excel has already selected the range
of data that you want to put into your
pivot table and you can either select
the existing worksheet or a new
worksheet I'll select a new worksheet
over here and just press on OK and there
you go you have your pivot table ready
now here you can see your pivot table is
a little empty all you need to do is
drag and drop the data elements that you
want on your pivot table so here you can
see on a spreadsheet we have some
business data related to a store which
has furniture and dates and
subcategories of the furniture and all
the you know in in category you have
furniture officer plus technology Etc
right so those have some sub categories
as well and different states and the
regions as well and the quantity total
sales happen right so using this
business data we can find out some key
insights of this particular data using
our pivot table right so here we'll add
the data now let me drag the region into
rows click and drag and let me drag a
categories into columns which are the
different categories which are involved
in sales data and values what are the
sales happened right and there you go
you have Furnitures of a supplies
technology as the three different
categories and those are the sales
happened in central is South and West
regions and this is the grand total and
incentive regions you know you have all
the regions over here right so Central
is south west or instead of uh all the
regions or instead of all the categories
you can you know place a specific
category in your pivot table for example
let me push the category into the
filters and here you can see the total
sales happen in those particular regions
now what if someone asks you to find the
sales of Only Furniture right so your
manager comes to you and he'll ask you
getting the sales of only Furnitures you
can select that and there you go you
have the furniture sales in all the
regions right or you can also do the
vice versa he can also drag regions into
the filters and if you wanted to find
out the region wise sales of furniture
you can also do that right
so here we have furniture and here you
have all the regions and let us try to
find the sales of furniture in the
central region and there you go right so
this is how
um the pivot table works and you can
also remove the regions for example if
you wanted to remove a certain element
from filters or anywhere if it is
columns rows anything you can just drag
and drop it right so that's how it works
and also you can increase the level of
detail or improve the granularity right
so here we have categories on our you
know columns so you can also include
subcategories into the columns
right and
and you have the reason why sales
show in the region filter select all
press OK and in the category
select all
press ok
and you have the furniture here of a
supplies here and Technology here and
also if you want to include the quantity
how much or how many number of uh you
know things got sold in those particular
categories and subcategories you can
also do that so here in the furniture
section books these are the sales and
these are the number of quantity or
elements sold in the in those particular
you know sectors so you can you can also
improve the level of granularity you can
also include the level of detail using
pivot tables in Excel now here we have
four different sheets of the sales so
the first sheet is the West Zone next is
South Zone a Zone and central zone so
all this data belongs to one single
sheet that is Superstore data set so I
have categorized or I have taken a part
of the data which belongs to central
region South Region west region and east
region now we are going to use all these
four sheets and create one single sheet
which is the pivot table of all the four
sheets now without further Ado let's
start the process now for that we might
want to use the shortcut key that is alt
D now press P now this starts the pivot
chart wizard
now here we have to choose the option
multiple consolidation ranges
then click on next
and here you can see the pivot table is
clicked by default
now we'll go to next now here click I
will create page Fields or the pivot
chart wizard will automatically create
if you want that to create for you now
click on next now here let's select the
range
now I'll be selecting the range
now next we'll Select East
right
followed by that we have South
and finally we have best
now we will name these according to the
regions
so the first one will be West
next one will be South
next one will be East
and the last one will be Central
click on next and here select new
worksheet and finish
and there you go you have the pivot
table here now you might want to change
the summation value so click anywhere on
the pivot table and change it from count
to
sum
so that you have the summation of the
total number of sales subcategory sales
and grand total of sales Etc now
here you can see all option now let's
select Central and you'll get the
details of the central region the grand
total and the sales happening quantity
of sales Etc now here you can you can
see the furniture office supplies
technology and the grand total all in
one single sheet now let's get back to
the original sheet so as you can see
this is the original sheet and in the
original sheet you can see various more
categories
which is the
which is the shipment mode customer
segment country city state
and you also have a product name
subcategory Etc so if you had added all
these into this sheet you can also
create a separate option of adding my
new details to your pivot table
so that is how the pivot table is
created using multiple sheets so how to
create a paper chart you ask it is
really simple all you need to do is just
follow few steps and you have your paper
chart ready which is completely
interactive now all you have to do is
select any cell in the data set you have
and rush into the insert toolbar then in
the group of charts you have an option
called pivot chart select on it now
you'll be asked to select the data range
and you can see Excel has automatically
select all the range that you want to
include in your pivot chart then you
have another option which is asking you
to either create the pivot chart in the
current worksheet or a new worksheet for
now let's select a new worksheet and
there you go voila the paper chart is
completely ready you might ask me this
is completely empty yes the default
pivot chart what you get from Excel will
be completely empty but you can add the
Legends and all the data that you want
to add onto your pivot chart just by
dragging and dropping the data from the
right hand side of your Excel sheet that
is from the pivot chart Fields so you
can see we have various options region
category state subcategory sales
quantity Etc now I'll add region
I'll add region to access
and comparatively we will see the sales
that are happening in those particular
regions by dragging sales into values
now you have all the data in the form of
pivot chart which is completely
interactive which represents the sales
happening in those regions now you can
also select a particular region right by
default all the regions are selected but
if you want to select only Central then
you can do that by deserting everything
and select only Central and select OK
and there you go you have all the data
related to the sales happening in the
central region now if you want to you
know kind of see all the categories of
sales happening in all the regions you
can drag the category into values again
and in the region part
okay I think we have to add category
into Legends yes now select a region
slab that is all regions and select OK
and you can see the category wise sales
in all the regions at one single go and
I hope you did not observe it clearly uh
the Excel also gives you the completely
prepared pivot table as well right which
is also interactive you can also get to
choose the data from here as well and
select OK and you'll see that being
reflected on the pivot chart so here you
can see both pivot table and pivot
charts are completely interactive that
is charts in Excel now let's quickly get
on to the Practical mode where we will
have some data sets over which we will
be trying to apply the charts now there
are various types of charts in W and
those are the pie chart the column chart
the bar chart column versus line pivot
chart and sparkline charts so we will
discuss one after the other first let us
discuss about the pie chart
so as you can see we have a small data
set on my screen which I have personally
created and this deals with the
companies and this deals with the shares
of the automobile industry so now for
this let's create a pie chart
select all the data and then get into
the Tuple bar and inside the toolbar you
can see various options and inside that
we're gonna use the insert option and
when you select the insert option you
will have a ribbon here and inside the
ribbon you can see groups tables
illustrations add-ins and here you go
these are the charts so now we needed a
pie chart so select on that icon and you
have various types of pie charts you
have two dimensional pie charts three
dimension pie charts donor type of
charts
Etc right so I would like to go with the
three dimensional pie chart as it looks
a little more appealing and easy to
understand and now there you go this is
the title of the chart and these are the
legends of the chart and this is the
chart area and these are the values
now we can uh you know kind of add the
date and labels as well so you can just
have to press the plus icon over here
and you'll have the options you can add
the data labels which will give you a
lot more interesting values
and uh you can also turn this around
as you can see we on double clicking any
part of the pie chart you'll get this
option which is called as format data
point and let's imagine that you wanted
to show the information related to this
particular one which is a Volvo which
has the biggest share so this is in
front right now now what if you wanted
to show the information related to Tata
which is over here right for that you
can select this particular Arrow key and
you can just twist it and there you go
that is coming in front this will be a
great way of presenting your data to
your clients right
yeah and there is another option where
you can directly explore this like you
can pick it out you can see this right
Point explosion where you can split it
out and you can show that especially
like you can highlight it and show it so
that's the you know a great way of
presenting your data so that's how you
can work with pie charts in Excel now
let's quickly move to the next one that
is the column chart
and in the column chart we have the data
related to some company and the profits
of that company based on air so you can
see that the year has started from 2008
and it has gone until 2021 and these are
the profits of that company year after
year so since we are dealing with column
chart I'll tell you the simplest way to
create a column chat there is a shortcut
key for that
which is alt F1 and there you go you
have the chart right on your screen
now you can expand the chart just by
dragging it like that and
you can see that there is some problem
with this chat that is we have numbers
here instead of es right you can see
that the First Column is the es which is
2008 to 2021 but here you can see we
have one two three four which is not
proper right so to change the
access that as you can see the axis
which is one two three four from one two
three four to the years 2008 2009 2010
11 Etc you just have to make one change
here and also you can see I have pressed
the plus icon over here which will open
the option where you can include the
access titles if you have and data
labels everything right so for now I
think I'll keep it as it is so you can
include the data table as well as it is
here and you can include that in the
chart there are various options that
Excel provides you
so now let's focus on changing the axis
from one two three four to the ears for
that you need to select the chart design
and inside the chart design you have an
option called select data press that and
here you have vary set of options you
can see profits you can see EOS now
we'll select years and we will remove
that and now you can see the edit option
here right select that and now it will
ask you which column to be selected for
the access range for that let's select
this and now let's select the years here
and
press ok
and there you go again press ok so there
you go you have the ears over here
instead of the numbers which you had in
the first place so that's how you create
the column chart and we have the next
type of chart which is really simple
now you know it kind of change this
chart directly into bar chart there is
no big deal in that
so uh for that you just need to select
the change chart type option over here
you're just changing the chart type and
you can get the paragraph over here
column and bar graphs are completely
same to each other only that you can see
these uh bars in the horizontal way
rather than in the vertical way and
let's do that let's not create a new
thing for that so uh yeah there you go
when you select the change chart type
option you have various set of chart
type options on the menu bar over here
so what we needed was the bar chart now
let's select that and there you go
let's select OK and you have the bar
chart
right and if you want you can include
the data labels which look a little bit
more interesting you can also include
the data table as well
okay for now I think we have to expand
the chart to get the Clear View
yeah that's how you do it
right now let's move into the next type
of one here we dealt with the bar chart
so we'll directly enter into the column
versus line chart
so we have a similar kind of data we
just had year and profits in the
previous part now we also have included
the expenses right we needed another
column to showcase the line chart
compared to the columns right so for
that I've included a new column that is
expenses all as well now just let's
select the data
and let's select the option
alt F1 to create a chart
right now automatically uh Excel has
provided us the column chat we have The
Columns of expenses we have the column
of profits and we also have ears now
let's change the data as we did before
select uh here and remove it and then
edit
select edit and select the year that is
from here to 2021
select OK and we have the ears over here
now what we needed to do is change the
chart type right select the change chart
type option and since we wanted to
create a column versus length chart it
is a combination whenever you want one
or two types of charts included in one
single chart window then it is a combo
option so here we need to select the
combo option and inside that we have
various types of combination charts we
have clustered column we have clustered
line on secondary axis we have clustered
stat areas clustered column and the
other one is custom combination so let's
go with the first one that is clustered
line
let's select that and there you go we
have the line graph with the column so
that's how we create the column versus
line and if you want you can include the
data labels and you can include the data
table as well yeah
okay I think we need to expand the
canvas a little more to get a clear view
yeah
so you have Legends over here you have
the data labels and accesses everything
and chart title you can always change
the chart title so for now let's uh
rename it as
profits versus expenses
yeah that's that's how it goes
done
done spelling mistake here
yeah it's clear now
the next type of chart we're going to
deal with is the preview chart
so uh we have dealt with pie chart
column chart bar chart and column versus
line now period chart is a little bit
different it's like you're going to
create some active chart which responds
to the variations you are making to your
data so to understand that better let's
create a practical chart over here
and select all the data
okay
yeah I have selected the data now
to create a pivot chart
so let's select
the insert option from the toolbar and
inside the ribbon we have charts group
and inside that we have previous chat
now let's select the previous chart
option
and there you go now it's asking for
range and we have selected the range
over there and we are not going to
create a new worksheet for the entire
chart we are going to create the chart
inside the existing worksheet itself so
for that let's select the uh area where
we want to select the chart to be
present now for that let's select this
and
yeah select ok
okay there is some error
and let's cancel this and try again
yeah
let's select the data
and we will chat again
we have selected the range
here
that's how you select the range
and now select the position where you
want to create it existing worksheet we
have selected that and press OK yeah
that's that's the way we've got our
pivot chart over here and you can see
our previous chart is completely blank
right now it will respond to the changes
you make to your previous chart for now
we have serial numbers and these are the
names of the guys who have
okay so these are the names of the guys
who have some dealerships for various
car makes such as Ford Ferrari Honda Kia
Alfa Romeo BMW etc etc so uh we're gonna
change or we're gonna see
um you know we're gonna make some charts
of the persons who own the cars or the
car brands or dealerships in various
regions so we're gonna work on that now
let's drag in the name
and uh let's drag region
and cards
and the units
yep so we have our chart over here
column chart which has the different
different names and the dealerships and
some of cars over there right so you can
see that we can also change some values
over here what if we wanted to know only
uh the details regarding Jennifer you
can do that you can unselect everything
and you can just select Jennifer and
press ok now you'll have the details of
only Jennifer of having the car brands
so we have the regions as well so
Jennifer owns dealerships in two
different regions that is South and West
and the sum of units and count of cars
as well
so that's how the pivot charts are used
in real time
and now let's select sales and track the
sales as well
yeah it's been dragged and you have the
sales of Jennifer
the details of her sales
and let's move the chart a little bit
and you have the plus icon where you can
include the data labels for a better
information
yeah so that's how you use the preview
chats so we are on the last type of
charts which is the sparkline chart Now
to create a sparkline chat we need to
get into the insert option and inside we
have the ribbon and inside the ribbon we
have the group that is sparklines now
it will generate a sparkline chart we
need to select this particular column
and then select the type of sparkline
you want to create so now let's create
the column type of sparkline chart yep
we have to flop these cells together
first we've got that because we're gonna
insert the sparkline chart right above
here
now for that let's merge the cells
[Music]
yeah
so we wanted to create the
sparkline chart of column type and now
it's asking for the location where we
want to create the spark launcher so
this is the location now let's select ok
and there you go we have the sparkline
chart right over here
now you can see that we have a negative
Point here so if you want you can change
that from negative to positive
automatically update that and if you
want to add the access to this
particular chart you can select the
options sparkline and there you go you
have certain options like High Point low
point and if you wanted to add some
margins and you can also do that
data type access and they're going to
have the access
show access yeah you have the access now
and you can have the high point and low
point for that as well which is the you
know the biggest change and the smallest
change in this particular segment that
is few Furniture yeah Furniture has the
highest sales in January and Home
Appliance at the lower sale and you can
also change the color
and let's type of change the color again
here we have a different color over here
which resembles a little bit more better
or you can also go with this one
and if you wanted to add the same to all
these tables you can do that just by
dragging it and you have it for all the
six months
now if we wanted to add some new data in
this row or you wanted to add a new
complete row then you can do that as
well and change that and bring that
change implemented in these charts as
well
now let us try to add a new row here
which includes the miscellaneous you
have that there right over here let's
select that
copy and let's paste it over here
so there you go we have the extra row
here so yeah now we have added the
miscellaneous row and right now we have
the sparkline chart for only four
columns or four rows that is for initial
technology home appliances and office
needs and miscellaneous is missing now
to add that as well let's select
sparkline
and inside sparkline just select edit
Group location and data and now let's
select the entire data
and select ok
there's something wrong
again
sparkline edit data
select range
this should be helping yeah there you go
we have all the five rows now including
Furniture technology home appliances
office needs and miscellaneous let's get
started with the lookup function
tutorial in Excel what is Excel vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet it
allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters now let's look at the syntax to
write a vlookup function so vlookup
takes four parameters or arguments you
can see it here there are four arguments
in the Wilco function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value the lookup value represents
the value that you are searching for
next is the table array the table array
represents two or more Columns of
information the third argument is called
the column index number now this
represents the column number in the
table from which the value must be
returned the First Column is 1 the
second column is 2 and so on and then we
have the fourth parameter which is
called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or 0 meanwhile
if you want an approximate match you
need to enter true or one if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set we'll understand how
vlookup performs an exact and
approximate match we'll see how vlookup
is case insensitive then we'll perform a
wildcard character search
will understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found and finally
you will look at two-way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlooker works
so we want to find the units sold by
Morgan using the data set on the left
so here you can see I have the data set
it has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date region
there's a representative column item
units this unit cost and total and from
this table I want to find the units that
were sold by Morgan if you look at the
table at the bottom you can see the
representative name Morgan and Morgan
has sold 30 units now I want to find
this value using the vlookup function so
here on the right you can see I have my
lookup value which is Morgan and this is
my vlookup formula and using this
formula I am getting the result as 30.
now let's go to our Excel workbook and
perform all the demos one by one so this
is my Excel workbook that we are going
to use for our demo and here is the data
set we'll be using now this is the same
data set that you saw a while ago
so this data set has seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item there's units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
now we are going to use a chunk of this
data set and perform our vlookup
analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab
all right
so here
I'm going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from Row 2
till root 12 is going to be our data set
that we'll use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
Thomson
so here
Thompson is my lookup value which means
looking at Thompson I want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here you
can see we have the representatives name
Thompson right here and from the table
you can see Thompson sold pencil
and I want to get this value which is
pencil using my vlookup function so
let's go ahead and write our vlooker
function
I'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item I'm going to write
my vlooker formula
to write the vlooker formula I'll write
first equal to
and
I'll write vlookup now if I hit tab it
will auto complete all right now let's
give the parameters so first is going to
be the lookup value which is nothing but
Thomson so I'll just select this cell
which is j17
comma now it's asking to give the table
array so the table array is the table
from which you want to retrieve a value
one thing to keep in mind is that the
value you are looking for should be the
first column of a table and you can
select the table array till the end of
the data set or till the column which
has the value you want to find
so here I'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till the end of the item column which is
going to be my table array then I'll
select the column index number so the
column index number is based on the
table array you have selected in this
case my column index number is going to
be 2 because we have selected just two
columns and the value which I am going
to find is in the second column so I'll
give 2
comma now the range lookup I am going to
give is false because I want to find an
exact match so either you can hit tab
or you can write 0 which means false
if I close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that Thompson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table the Thomson had sold
pencil all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time I'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that Thompson had sold so I'll
write my formula equal to vlookup I'll
hit tab to autocomplete I'll give my
lookup value as Thompson
comma this time I am choosing my table
array starting from the representatives
column till
the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because if you consider this table
array the item column is the second
column in the selected table array so I
am going to write it as 2 comma
the range lookup I want to give as false
because I want to find the exact match
if I close this and hit enter you can
see it has written me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose let's say this time I want
to start my table array from the region
column which is this column
so I want to select my table array
starting from the region column now this
is going to show me an error because
your table array should always start
from the lookup value column so if you
consider Thompson as the lookup value
my table array should always start from
the representatives column so let's just
try this example
so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value I'm going to give it as
Thompson comma the table array as I
mentioned earlier I am going to choose
from the region column and let's say
I'll select till the item column give
another comma and this time a column
index number is going to be 3 because
since the table array has three columns
and my item column is the last column so
I'm going to give my column index number
is 3 comma I want to get the exact match
so I'll give 0 if I close the bracket
and hit enter you can see it has given
me an error
okay now let me just show you another
method to use vlookup in Excel so here
on the top you can see there's a
formulas Tab and under formulas tab
under function Library you see we have
an option to select lookup and reference
if I click on this
and if I scroll down below you can see
there's an option
called vlookup let's choose this
all right now here you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here I want to select my lookup value
as
Thompson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be 2
I'll write 2
and range lookup I'll write as false
because I want the exact match
if I hit OK you can see it has given us
the exact same result so this is one of
the other ways to use vlookup in Excel
now let's move to the next sheet which
is regarding approximate match okay so
sometimes you might have cases where you
don't have the lookup value present in
the table in those cases you can tell
vlookup to return an approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value columns should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table and
my lookup value column which is going to
be the representatives column is already
sorted in ascending order
and let's see the question we have here
so I want to find the items sold and the
unit cost format so my lookup value is
going to be matte now if you see this
table I don't have the representative's
name matte anywhere in the table now
using an approximate match I want to
find the item and the unit cost so let's
do it
so here under item I'll write my vlooker
formula
so I'll type vlookup I'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time meluco value is going to
be matte so I'll select the cell comma
my table array I'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of
item column because I want to find the
item value format
I'll give a comma
my column index number as per the table
array is going to be 2
comma my range lookup this time I am
going to give a screw or one so I'll
write 1. close the bracket hit enter
all right it has written me binder was
the item sold by Matt
now let's try to figure out why we look
up returned binder as the item
now let's see you were asked to insert
the name matte to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it ideally you should
Place between qvel and Morgan
since this column is already sorted mat
should appear before Morgan and after
cubelle so in an approximate match
vlookup will consider the previous
highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before mat is qvel
and hence vlookup returned the
corresponding item purchased by kevl
which is binder now similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost
format
again vlookup will return the unit cost
of cubel which is 125 let's just write
out so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is matte comma my table
array for this time is going to be from
Representatives column
till the unit cost column I'll consider
I'll give a comma now the column index
number as per the table array is going
to be 4 we'll give another comma and
this time I'll double click true because
I want an approximate match we close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
written me 125 which is actually
cables unit cost okay we have another
question and this time I want to find
the units sold by Rob now Rob is going
to be my lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have Rob now let's see what
vlookup is going to return as the item
for Rob so I'll write vlookup I'll give
my lookup value as Rob comma my table
array
is going to start from the
representatives column
I'll select till here I'll give a comma
my column index number is 2
we give another comma I'll double click
on true
so close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has written me pen now let's
understand why vlookup returned pen for
Rob now if you are asked to insert the
representative's name Rob
into this column so ideally Rob would
appear somewhere between Morgan and
Sorvino because
since this is sorted in ascending order
Rob is actually greater than Morgan and
is less than Sorvino so as you know
we look up in an approximate match
Returns the previous highest value which
is Morgan here and the corresponding
item for Morgan is pen and hence we look
up returned pen from Rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario where
your lookup value is on the left in this
case it is the representatives value and
I have taken cervino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
cervino now if you consider this table
your lookup value which is sure we know
is actually this column the
representatives column and we are going
to find out the order date so your
representative's name is on the right of
the table and the value we are going to
find out is on the left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if I use the vlooker function for
this example here I'll write vlookup
I'll give my lookup value as sorbino
comma multiple array I'll consider from
the order date because I want the order
date
till
the representatives column I'll give a
comma and this time
my column index number is actually the
first column if I consider my table
array as the first three columns
selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representative's name you can do that
easily because you look up value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this I'll write
vlookup my lookup value is going to be
sorvino's order date so I'll select it
from the table
I'll give a comma my table array will
start from the G column let's say I'll
select the entire table
comma and my column index number will be
3 if you consider these as my table
array
comma my range lookup is zero if I close
this hit enter you can see we have got
so we know corresponding to the order
date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says
vlookup returns only the first match so
we have a question at hand the question
is
find the units sold by Jardine
if you see this table
we have the representative's name Jardin
twice you see here and if you look down
we have Jardin here as well but the
items sold by Jardin at the first
instance is pencil and at the second
instance it's desk
now as per the property vlookup always
returns the first match now ideally when
we write the vlookup function and look
for the units sold by Jardine you will
see vlookup will return
36 instead of 3. let's just try it out
I'll write the vlookup function
my lookup value is Jardine
comma my table array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
we'll give a comma my column index
number based on the table array is three
I'll give another comma Now I want the
exact match so I'll select 0
close the bracket and hit enter
as you can see it returns me the first
match of Jardine which is 36 so vlookup
did not consider the second match
now similarly
if you consider this table
we have Jones repeated Thrice so you
have Jones here
you have Jones
here for the second time and also we
have zones for the third time
and let's see you want to find the unit
cost for Jones so if I write the vlookup
function
I'll consider my
lookup value as Jones comma my table
array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
I'll give a comma based on the table
array my unit cost column is at the
fourth index so I'll write 4 comma the
range lookup is 0.
if I click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of Jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so our
unit cost
for Jones is 1.99 because vlookup only
Returns the first match
okay moving ahead to the next example we
have here is vlookup is case insensitive
if you consider this table
I've added another
Row in green
so if you see here I have a
representative name called Gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case here I
have added Gill's name in
capital letters are all in uppercase so
I want to find the total revenue
generated by Gill the total revenue is
basically the total column
let's do it I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is Dil which is actually
in upper case
I'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on the selection my column index
number is 5.
comma the range lookup is false so I'll
just double click on false
if we close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider Gill
which was present at the bottom of the
table in upper case
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right now moving to the next example
the vlookup function supports wild cards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value for
instance you can use vlookup to retrieve
values from a table after typing only
part of a lookup value to use wild cards
with vlookup you must specify the exact
match by giving false or 0 for the last
argument that is range lookup now we
have a question here
I want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with Ki
make now here sales represents the total
column actually
so I want to find out the person whose
name starts with Ki
so if you consider the representative
column I have one representative whose
name starts with Ki that is kibble so
using Ki as my lookup value I want to
find the total so let me show you how to
use Wild Card characters and find
the value using vlookup so write my
function vlookup
okay now in lookup value I'll give Ki
after that I am going to write Ampersand
followed by
double inverted commas
then I'm going to write a star and close
the inverted comma this means the value
starts with k i
Amber sent actually represents
concatenation and star represents
anything followed by Ki
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
I'll give a comma
next I'll select my table array starting
from the representatives column till the
end of total column because I want to
find the sales
I'll give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5.
comma the range lookup is 0 because I
want to find an exact match
let's close the bracket hit enter you
can see it here vlookup has returned me
999.5 which is actually Cable's total
now there's another way to do it
instead of selecting the cell in which
we have the lookup value I can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so I'll write the vlookup function
something like this so my lookup value
I'll pass Ki within double inverted
commas because Ki is a character value
So within double inverted commas I'm
writing Ki followed by Ampersand which
is for concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my lookup values this in
total means anything that appears after
Ki will be considered as the lookup
value
again the table array I'll select as
these rows and columns
comma my column index number would be 5
comma the range lookup is zero if I
close the bracket hit enter you see we
have the same value so this is another
method or another way of using
vlookups
okay now moving ahead let's explore
another feature of vlookup so if the
vlookup function cannot find a match it
returns a hash an a error now if you
want you can use the if any function to
replace the hash any error with a
friendly message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of May 2018.
now if the order date is not found I
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column we don't have any value for 10th
of May 2015. you can see these values we
don't have any value corresponding to
this date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value I'll return invalid date so
let me show you
how to write this
I'll type my vlookup function
I'll give my order date as 10th of May
2015.
as my lookup value and then
I'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of
region column
we'll give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma
I want an exact match
so I'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has returned me an error
now I want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date so
let me show you how to do it I'll do it
here so to return a valid message
I'll use the if any function
and within if any function I'll give my
vlookup function
so let me type if any
I'll hit tab
now for the value parameter I'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be the order date
comma my table array I'll select from
the order date column till the end of
region column comma where column index
number is going to be 2
comma my range lookup is 0
I'll close the bracket give another
comma Now if this expression results in
an error I want to display a message
that is invalid date so I'll put invalid
date within double quotes
since it is
a text message
I close the bracket hit enter you can
see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two-way lookup
now in the vlookup function the column
index parameter is normally hard coded
as a static number however you can also
create a dynamic column index by using
the match function to locate the right
column
and this technique allows you to create
a dynamic two-way lookup matching on
both rows and columns
now let me first show you how a match
function works so suppose
I want to find the index where unit cost
column is present so here I'll use the
match function
I'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma suppose I'll choose my lookup
array starting from Representatives
column till the unit cost column comma
I'll give my match type as 0 for exact
match
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array unit cost
is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem I want to
find the cost of each item sold by
Morgan
so let's
write our vlooker formula
write B lookup
my lookup value is J5 which has the
representative's name as Morgan comma
my table array I'll select from
C2
till
F12
I'll give a comma and this time I know
that my column index number is at
4 but I'll be using the match function
to find the same
so I'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array is from C1 till F1
comma my match type is 0
I close this bracket and give another
comma and I'll give my range lookup as 0
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for Morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for Morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right
now
we have another question here
I want to find how much sales did
Andrews make in the central region so
here I have
two lookup values one is Central one is
Andrews now looking at these two values
I want to find the total
to solve such problems
let me first create
another table
I'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right now I'll create another column
where I'll merge the values of region
and representatives so here let me
create another column okay I'll just
name this column as
region
rep
all right now this column
I'll use the concatenation operator
so I'll Select East
use Ampersand and then select Jones I'll
hit enter
now the same thing I'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well so I have my
new column created Now using this table
I can easily solve the problem
now to find the total I'll write my
vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of j11
ampersand
k11
comma multiple array will start from the
region rep which has the values of
region and rep combined
till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5
and my range lookup is zero if I close
the bracket hit enter you can see
for central region which is this one
and for Andrews representative the total
is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlooker performs an exact
match we also saw how using the formulas
Tab and lookup and reference you can
write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlooker
performs an approximate match so we had
matte and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only Returns the first match
following which we saw that vlookup is
case insensitive so here we had added a
new row where Gill was present in upper
case but still we look up
found the total revenue for Gill which
was in sentence case or properties next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to
use vlookups
and here we saw how to use an if any
function along with vlookup and finally
we saw how to use two-way lookups choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access to 1000 plus hours of video
content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now we are on
the sheet of Microsoft Excel and here
you can see some data on my sheet
that is employee name employee ID and
salary
so here we are going to perform our
horizontal lookup but before that let me
show you that this particular drop down
menu so this particular drop down menu
has all the names of the employees in
this particular table and we have
created this using data validation in
Excel if you want to create the drop
down menus just like this then feel free
to check out our data validation in
Excel tutorial link to which is in the
description box below now let's try to
implement each lookup in Excel so here
we have employee name but we want to
find out the employee ID so for that
let's create the hlookup now for that
equals to hlookup
now the first one is the lookup value so
this one is the cell which is the
employee name now after that the table
array we have to select all the table
arrays here
now
the row index number so the employee ID
is in row index number 2 according to
the table so for that provide 2 and
close the bracket and before closing
brackets you might want to give the
exact match so for exact match select
false and close the bracket press enter
and there you go and if you select jet
then you'll find the employee ID of
check and if you select jury you'll find
the employee ID of cherry reflecting
here now similarly let's find out the
salary of all the employees using
hlookup so equals hlookup
and lookup value that happens to be the
name of the employee now the table array
and next we have row index number that
is salary happens to be the third one in
the table so three and
exact match
close the bracket and enter so now if
you change the values in this particular
drop down menu you will find the
employee ID and their particular salary
so Jack happens to be carrying the
employee ID as one zero zero one and his
salary is ten thousand so similarly
let's try to find out petos employee ID
and salary
so there you go one zero zero five and
fifty thousand as salary so that's how
you use hlookup in Excel here you can
see the first chart so this particular
data is converted into a table format to
avoid confusion while you're fixing the
data so here you can see the name of the
employee employee ID Department salary
and date of churning and here you can
see the salary column and the bonus
percentage of each and every employee
based on their salaries now coming to
the new data table and here on the
tables 2 which is an updated table here
you can find we are going to find out
the department of the employee and the
current Department of employee and the
bonus percentage based on his or her
salary so why are we finding current
Department again
so here you can see that we have an
intern Emily who has joined in the year
2020 but recently she got promoted as a
developer so her department has been
changed from Department in turn to
Department developer in 2021 so that's
what we're gonna find out here in the
current Department using X lookup now
let's start to implement X lookup so for
that
equals to xlookup
and for lookup you can see if you need
to find out the lookup value lookup
array return array and all the other two
are not important right now but you can
use them to get some exact matches in
the future we'll also use that in the
future for now let's try to use the
first three parameters that is lookup
value lookup array and written array so
the lookup value is the name of the
employee Mary and lookup array is right
here which is this one
now we are going to select the lookup
array then comma and we're going to look
up the department so this is the
department lookup array
and that's all we need
close the bracket and press enter
okay I think we missed out the lookup
value
so the employee or the lookup value
which we required was missed so I've
added it here so that is the lookup
value the first one which is midi and
there you go
press enter and you have the department
here now let's add it to all the rows
and here you have all the rows and all
the data related all the employees now
we will find out the current Department
as you can see here you have Emily as
intern which is the older data but what
if you needed the latest data that is
the developer in the year 2021 right for
that you might want to throw up the X
lookup formula a little bit so let's try
that X lookup
lookup value which is the same and comma
now where you have to look for the array
that is lookup array this one and the
return array which happens to be this
one
and next
you can find the exact match for this
one so that's all right exact match and
here comes the important part where you
have to search last to first by default
X lookup searches for first to last that
is like this in the starting place to
the last place so that's the reason why
we had Emily as intern so now if we give
last to first then it retrieves the
latest data where Emily will be shown as
developer now select that and now you
can close the brackets and press enter
so let's add that to all the rows there
you go now you can see Emily Clark Peter
and James all they have got their
updated job profiles as you can see in
the original data Emily is a developer
now so is Clark who was originally a
tester and he got promoted to
development team in 2021 similarly Peter
became a senior Finance executive in
2021 and James the manager of sales now
let's try to find out the bonus for all
these employees based on their salary so
this one is quite simple
so X lookup
now the lookup value is their existing
salary
comma and the bonus part so the lookup
array is the salary range
then here is another important point so
here you might want to find the exact
match but finding an exact match will
not help you here you might want to
declare another type of value where you
can get exact match or next smaller item
so you'll understand it why I'm
selecting that so now let's close the
bracket and enter so
so now we have the bonus values now
let's add the bonus value to all the
factors all the rows I mean so you can
see we have different variety of
salaries that is thirty eight thousand
twenty two thousand thirty nine Etc but
here in the ranges we have provided 10
20 30 14 50. so what if the value is
between 30 and 20 that's when you want
the less number right that's when you
want the number which is equivalent to
30 or less than 30 which happens to be
15 percent so that's how it has worked
here that is 0.15 percent bonus to the
actual salary here on our Excel sheet
here you can see the employee names and
employee IDs of different employees from
different zones let us imagine that the
blue one is from East Green one is from
West and the black one is from or the
purple one is from South and the orange
one is from North so this data is a
little small but what if we had a data
with hundreds or thousands of rows
including all the Android names employee
IDs or another relevant data type like
sales of an employee and his employee ID
and you are supposed to combine all the
data from all the four different zones
into one single sheet it would consume a
lot of time right so recently Microsoft
has released some latest updates based
on arrays and details so one of those is
v stack function in Excel so how to use
it since it is a latest function I
recommend you to go to the file menu and
in the file menu you can navigate to
account and in the account you can see
the option of update options then you
can select update now and your Microsoft
Office will be updated to the latest
version and you'll get access to the
latest functions in Excel and all the
other office related things like power1
presentation Etc
now we are going to implement the
v-stack function in Excel it is
completely simple all you need to do is
equals to stack and then select the data
remember to select the data from column
A and cell to other row 2. we are not
selecting the employment and employee ID
we are just selecting the data now
separate them by comma then again this
one here this set and again this one
and again lastly in this particular last
set
now close the bracket and press enter
and there you go you have all the
employee names and their respective
employee IDs all together in one data
set so this is how you use restack
function in Excel hyperlinks in Excel
now hyperlink is something which is
clickable and when you click on it it
will redirect you to a different web
page to a different worksheet or a
different location in your local system
so there are a variety of options and we
will explore all of them using Excel
now creating a hyperlink is really
simple we have multiple ways now let's
write some text on the Excel worksheet
I'll write simply down
now creating a hyperlink is really
simple you have multiple ways the first
simplest shortcut is clicking on the
cell where you want to place the
hyperlink and holding Ctrl key and
pressing chain
now this will enable the hyperlink menu
box or the dialog box this is the first
way and let me close it now again we
have selected the cell there is another
option where you have to click on the
insert menu on the toolbar and navigate
to Links group click on the link option
and you will again have the dialog box
of the hyperlick in Excel and the Third
Way is right click on the cell and you
can see the link option in the last
and this will enable the hyperlink
option in Excel now let's create a
hyperlink the simplest way again Ctrl K
now we have a variety of options that is
existing file or web page placed in this
document create a new document and an
email address so we will address all of
these one at each time so first one
existing file or a web page now you can
select an existing PDF file or any file
in your local system and hyperlink or
create a hyperlink to the text or you
can select a website a link and place it
over here and create it as a hyperlink
let's explore both the options
first let's try to explore the web page
option so since I have written as simply
learn let's use the website link of
Simply learn and create a hyperlink
let me open Google
new tab and let me type simplylearn.com
let me copy the hyperlink and now let's
get back to the Excel workbook now here
let's place the hyperlink now you can
press ok
and there you go the hyperlink has been
successfully created now this link is
clickable when you click on it it will
redirect you to a new simply launch home
web page right so this is how you create
a hyperlink to a website now we shall
explore another option that is using an
existing file right let's create a new
text box here let's name it as existing
file and okay existing file should be
good again the same you can either click
uh you know right click and select
hyperlink or Ctrl k
now let's select existing file or web
page option now here you can see
navigate key press on that and let's
navigate our files
let's select all files here remember to
select all files okay by default it
shows as office files now let's explore
our file option
so let's select a fundamentals of
computer programming option which is a
PDF file press OK and there you go we
have created a hyperlink so when I click
on this you can directly navigate to an
existing PDF file in your local system
and it will be open as a web page
click on it and you can see the PDF file
now close
now another thing when you navigate onto
this you'll see the lengthier HTTP
address and same happens here right so
if you're a little uncomfortable
watching this lengthier link you can
also edit it you can choose the option
of edit hyperlink
and
see the screen tip option
click on it
and here you can change the text display
option
and write it as
click here
to no more
yes okay
again press OK and now if you navigate
onto it instead of seeing a Lambda
hyperlink what you can see is click here
to know more okay I think I made a
spelling mistake so I think I forgot an
e
somewhere over here yes click here to
normal
and press OK right so here you can see
click here to normal let's try this
again over here
so edit
edit hyperlink screen tab option and
instead of the lender text box or
hyperlink you can write as click to open
notes
or PDF
click ok
and click another okay and you are done
so instead of seeing that length your
hyperlink you can see click here to open
PDF right so so far we have explored two
options that is existing file and
existing web page
right now let's try to explore another
option again a hyperlink right click
hyperlink and here you have seen places
in document all right so which is like
uh okay let me
show this to you instead of telling you
so here what it is doing is you have the
cell A5 and you want it to refer to A1
or any other cell in the same worksheet
so you can do that right so now for your
reference let me cancel it and let me
create a new sheet and here
navigate me to here right let me write
this navigate me to here
okay
so now what we will do is
so here we will create that navigate
link
from using the hyperlink option place
this in this document you can see the
sheet to option and the cell references
A1 where we have written navigate me to
here so when I click this A5 cell
okay let me also rename it
write it as navigate cell navigating
cell
right nah
create that
Ctrl k
let me select sheet 2 and the cell
address is A1 press okay now what did
what what's the change right when you
click on this you will be redirected to
sheet to cell A1 navigate me to here
right so this can be like a shortcut
when you have multiple sheets like 100
sheets then you can you know have a
different column over here and add the
navigation address to all those cell
links you can just click on that cell
and go into the different sheet and to
the specific cell which you have given
the address in our case I have given
sheet to address cell A1 right so this
is another trick now let's get back to
the hyperlink thing again uh Ctrl K and
another option is create new document so
you might have been through you know
option of uh having
let's say some cheat sheets or clip-on
clipboards right so let us imagine that
you're working through a huge worksheet
and you wanted to you know have a track
of everything and keep notes updating
right so it might be a little
complicated to understand so let me show
it practically so let me write it down
as clipboard or sticky note
right
okay I think this has a hyperlink let us
okay this can't be used no worries
to
hyperlink option again
create new document
now here you can create a variety of
documents right so it can be a text
document it can be an Excel document it
can be a PDF document right for now
we'll create a text document okay uh
we'll name it as a Tracker
Dot txt
so this should create as a text document
and the location can be anything so you
can you know take it as a desktop
documents download so let me take
documents here and select ok so I'll be
having this tracker.txt located in the
documents folder
and you can also choose to edit a
document later or edit the document now
let us select edit the document now
press OK and there you go so you have
your text tracker here so let us imagine
that we have worked on the Excel sheet
and we wanted to write down as a sticky
note so that we can remember what we
have done on the Excel sheet so update
one
and update to now we can close it so
it'll ask for a save option save it and
done and let us imagine that you did
something else and you also updated
something else on the sticky note I'm in
Excel sheet and you wanted to update
that on your sticky note so click on it
and you'll see a minor notice over here
from Microsoft Excel based on potential
security concerns you can select PS and
you'll be having access to your text
document again and write down your
update again here update three what you
have written right in the latest update
we have
foreign
so that's how you keep track of your
sticky note and you'll have all your
updates right
now getting back to the hyperlinks again
the last one is email address
so you can also try to add okay let's
imagine that you're working with a
colleague and every time you make an
update in your Excel sheet or anything
and you wanted to send them out an email
right so it would be a little time
consuming that you open your email and
compose something and send it over here
but what if you had a one single click
and access to the email compose option
right that can be done so let us write
down email
actually
let me with the spelling
so again the Ctrl K and hyperlink select
the email option and you can write down
your email
which can be anything so you can write
down your friend's email address
so I'm just writing down some random
email here
friend gmail.com and
can write a subject about update
and press OK this will navigate you to
the Gmail option or the mailing address
options
click on it and you'll have a variety of
mailing options Outlook Office 365 Yahoo
iCloud Google Etc so you can select any
one of those since we have written as
gmail.com we'll navigate to Gmail and
all you have to do is log in you know
all the formalities and you're good to
go with emailing
so let's get this one now so yeah you
know how to do the rest parts
so so far we have you know covered all
the hyperlink options in Excel that has
existing file or a web page place this
in the current executive worksheet or
document creating a new document for
your update thing and also including the
email right so so far we have covered
everything around happening in Excel and
if you have anything to know more about
or if you feel that we have missed out
anything important regarding hyperlink
in Excel you can feel free to let us
know
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your Excel it's a
simple tab that you need to add in the
ribbon section which I'll be showing you
across and this will enable the macros
on your Excel so you go to files
good options
and then you need to customize whatever
click customize ribbon and then there is
a developer tab which you see here it
should be activated so you just need to
select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macros now you you
have your data and you can run macros or
record a macro and run it all on your
Excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your Macros from
here so this is two ways that you need
to that you can activate uh your Macros
so how you record a macro is the next
thing
so here I have a work orders sheet that
I receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do and you know this report has so
many things that are obsolete which you
do not need which has to be put across
to your management or your for your use
so how you record or start a macro you
go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro as soon as you click
on this record macro button it will
start recording your keystrokes on the
mouse mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that I have and we'll
try to run a macros on this and see what
it does
so here I have and
this actually works this way uh I need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro so when I click record
macro it starts recording my mouse
clicks and keystrokes so in this sheet I
have to you know remove some columns and
the columns that are Obsolete and the
data that looks weird here should be
removed and all what I need is the work
order number the district and the
tactician name and the kind of service
that we provide and the requested
workday the cost
and the payment so this is what I want
and I do it every day when I receive the
sheet and I have to make these changes
and send it across to the accounts team
so what I do is I simply automate this
by running a macro
so I go to
let's see how it records the macro
if I click record macro I save it as
work order
accounts
and I'll add a little description like
work order
account
because
click ok
and
see what I do is basically I add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper and then I
do not want this column I delete it I do
not want the number of technicians that
are there I do not want all these and I
also want the leverage the account and
what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the accounts name I do not
want any of these obsolete data
so I just delete this
okay and then I just want to have some
cosmetic changes done so
and make sure this doesn't have any
border
and that's it this is the task that I
prefer
every day I still don't need it
and I go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now I have the macro
save and when I have it I have you know
automated these all these steps in one
simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you
the next thing so here I have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and sent it across so I simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro Save which we ran the
just now and I simply with a single
click I will be able to do these daily
tasks and execute in a Flash so I just
click run and it does the rest for me I
have my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running a simple
macro continuing our uh to work on macro
we can simply do this by a single click
of a button by adding a button so what
you have to do is go to the developer
tab and in the control section you will
see the insert option option when you
click on the insert drop down you will
see a form controls and you can say
select a button and here I select a
button and the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when I just
assign that macro to this button I can
edit the text by
making it as a work order accounts just
to make it simple okay
and now if you see if I just click this
button it will run the macro
and format RC
So This Is How We Run The macros in a
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros and instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros or you can record
and you can edit your macro so when I
click view macros it will show you what
are the macros that I have and that I
can run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have to use a
simple application in Excel which is the
BBA Visual Basic application to edit
your macro you go to the developer tab
and then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on and you
can edit the
macro here so as we see if you go back
to the Excel
we see that every sheet we have been
working on
um the sheet and it has the column still
K and the actual sheet is this so if I
go to the Visual Basic editor
and I'll make sure the note I remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m and I just delete that
and I click run
I go back to my sheet and you see these
changes are not there
okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders so
these are the things that we can edit
with the VBA what is VBA Visual Basic
application it is basically a Visual
Basic application language that is used
for macros in Excel
so what it basically does Visual Basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate tasks by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks by running a
simple macro now to help us you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our abilities to
is our work an automated task we use VBA
so
why we be there are many advantages of
using VBA and why we prefer VBA in
macros for excel so basically it is a
very simple language it saves time in
performing tedious tasks you have number
of tasks that you do every day as we
have seen in the previous section how we
we can simplify your daily task by just
running a simple macro and this VBA
helps us in performing those tasks in a
very simple manner another thing is it
supports english-like statements there
are multiple statements that you can use
and which are very basic English
language statements and this can help us
or it is very easy to program our code
or edit these commands you can select a
range you can it is like a if an else
statement and things like that we'll
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple
functions that you perform in Excel like
selecting a number of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells in particular
you do it in a daily basis so these
things can easily be performed and
easily be edited and executed by using
VBA we will look into those in detail
now what is the BBA editor interface
this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail where where you can edit your
commands or your codes for your Excel
now how this is achieved we will see it
here
now these are the this is basically the
VBA editor interface where you can see
the uh this is the toolbar section where
it shows all the options wherein undo or
save or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section of the VBA editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important menu
bar option and when you can insert
different modules and buttons and all
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing all these
things fall under menu bar the next
thing is the VBA code window maybe a
code window as it says is the code
window where your actual code resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the course and select the
different range of functions that you
can perform and this is basically the
bdb VBA code window where you edit your
or write your codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the the Excel sheets or
the worksheets that you're working on or
the modules that you have saved and so
on basically it is an Explorer for your
PBA like a Windows Explorer which is for
the file explorer the next thing is the
properties window properties Windows
shows you the properties of the
worksheet that you're working on for
instance here we are working on the
sheet 2 and it shows the properties what
are the kind of uh
[Music]
worksheet that we have the page break
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that the next thing is the immediate
window and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window wherein you can run and execute
simple lines of course individual Excel
code that you can run it will allow you
to test individual lines
which is very useful and handy when you
are writing and debugging codes uh the
output if the lines that you execute can
be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch Window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its currently
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the you the advantages of
having a watch window in your VBA
interface
so these are the things that we'll learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
Visual Basic for application for macros
and I'm going to show you how to you
know run some codes and run some macros
and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and the first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
then just press and it will open the
Visual Basic for application window or
alternatively you can just go and click
on the Visual Basic I need to open the
sheet video I mean the code window field
and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project Explorer
and this is the immediate window I will
you can run some testing course
immediately it will show you the uh code
so here we see the project Explorer
window where we see the modules and all
for our Visual Basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see how
the code develops okay so I just go here
and click record macro
and I save it as a format
and columns
desperate but can I just save it click
OK and it has started recording so now
what I'll do is as make it simple and I
just delete some columns here
okay I do not need this
I delete this is there a wait I want
this I want the amount of payment parts
cost labor hours I do not want this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and I go for the left and see what all
do I need I need I don't need this
I delete all these and
I just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then I want to change the format I
mean the hot
so I select this
[Music]
and I change it to timestrone
okay
yeah I'm gonna go back to my developer
tab click stop recording it is saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see the
macro here
so we see the macro here and we can see
uh in detail what it looks like so we
see the code what it's doing and what
the macro run has generated the code
back so we see we have basically the
name of the macro is format columns and
what it is doing we're just selecting
The Columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee selected is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 so it is basically
a basic VBA code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or a format of the VBA code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
VB and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation I have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and I'll try to explain some
basic
functions and the commands and the
course that we use to accomplish the
task that we with PBA
so as we see this is the blank sheet and
I have selected a new module for it
so here I start the code and as you see
as it starts with sub and I am
specifying the uh module name as a
number so I'll just try to make it quite
simple and
you know so we as as soon as we enter
the sub it sends with the end sub and so
this is the start of the code and this
is the end of the code and whatever is
there should be here and this is the
name of the code of the macro now uh
I'll explain it further about the game
statement why is it used and what does
it use for so dim is basically a keyword
which is the a short form of Dimension
and it is used to declare variables in
the VBA so here I am trying to specify
uh
a variable called X and how I'm going to
do it I will as it have it as a number
or an integer or anything so here in
this example I'll put it as an integer
or a number okay and as I put as it
populates the prompt so I select integer
and for example I select the number to
be
500. okay and here I'm trying to assign
a variable integer a cell a value of 500
with a limb keyword
so where exactly I want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay range I am selecting it should be
under course where I'm going to put the
value of x as and I close the bracket
and what should be the value
[Music]
should be X
so now as I click runs up
or you can do it with the by running the
alt F5 key and it will run the
cool so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the dimension
keyboard or dim keyword and you can
assign the value as integers now proceed
we proceed further with certain more
example some more examples and how we
assign the string value as a as a text
or
something else okay
now I'm going to show you what dim can
be execute I mean used as to set
variables then can be used as a
double when double is basically a longer
form of single variable it usually takes
more space but uses needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can set
double and I just don't specify it and
you can do state it basically stores the
date values okay and then again string
so what string does if you use string it
stores the text it can contain numbers
it will have some text as calculations
or anything can be performed so these
are the basic thing that I will cover
and
you can also use different uh values for
it so I will discuss this in the next
example
okay
[Music]
so in the next example I'll try to
use a string value for it and
I put it as a string substring
[Music]
value
[Music]
is my name so as soon as I hit enter it
ends with the answer prompt and now I
can get my code so
I put the same book it has
okay now
I'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and I select country and in
country I select Mac
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country as so I have to
specify a range and as soon as I hit it
goes and I have to specify the
the cell here so here I put it as G
and 4 okay so I close it
and I put a value what value I am going
to assign it is a country okay
now I tried to run this code by simply
and see G4 the name populates as a
country here so this is a dim keyword
being used as a string in our VBA code
so
we can also use
VBA to you know pop up a message on an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be uh
executed using a
code here which I'm going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
[Music]
I'm going to name it as double value and
again the main keyword I'm going to use
the keyword as double
y double is used is basically uh it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable ticks it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now I'm going to pop up a message in the
which says a value of a is so and so so
I'm going to give value of a as
two five zero okay and how I it pops up
a message okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value I mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and you want you can
enter the text and you can edit so here
I'm going to uh write a code which you
know which gives a pop-up message a
message box saying that the value of a
is signed so
the value of a is
I'm going to put it in and percent code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay now that's it and let's try to run
this and you will see a message for
popping message box popping up
okay so the value of a is the message
box pops up saying the value of a is
250. so
in the next example I am going to write
a code wherein you know you can give a
value or a string you can assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when you have some you know when you
have a task of you know giving a value
to a particular cell or you have to
assign a text or say something about a
report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use the
I will say it as
run with some procedures
[Music]
so here I am giving to I am going to
give a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give an Eva I mean
any string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it here
[Music]
because
this is the
report
let's make it simple
okay and where I'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell that I
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input so
defined user input as this is a report
for VBA so this cell turns into you this
is a report for VBA
I run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and you know it makes life quite simple
when you use VBA for this as we have
seen before we have used message box now
I'm going to use the same message box
to display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes I'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your name
and I'm going to put it under course
that my name is
[Music]
and we'll try to run it
see here
so it pops a message saying that my name
is it fun so this is a message box that
you can display and I can do anything
with this uh
this is a PBA okay
okay I run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an Excel sheet or try to run a
Workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or you know Define a
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
now I have another good example wherein
you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so here it is
I'll put it as sub
number
and it will again populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
entered
value
is
tell me
which or I specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so I gave a range
of
I have to give it in two codes
I'm going to
foreign
[Music]
of the number that is present in the
cell A1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use Excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
I can change it to
a
4
as well and try to run it and it will
give me the number so this is simple way
of you know populating a message box
which will tell us the
value of a uh let me show you one more
simple example where in a message box
pops up or a welcome message that can be
power set when you open the Excel or
worksheet so
so let's
name it as Auto
open
[Music]
and then again message box I wanted to
populate and
what does it say
I put it in quotes welcome
[Music]
Workshop
[Music]
it's very simple you just run it and
see it pops up a message saying it
welcome to a workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or do simple
welcome message on Excel
next I'm going to show you a code
pairing you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curved
so we name it as add value
now I specify the range I mean where I'm
going to specify a cell
where the value will be given to the
cell
now I'm going to give it as B5
okay so put it as curves close the
parenthesis
what is the value that I'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0. okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell B5 let's see
run it see
again I do it to
it okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now I can run the same thing and give a
range of cells I mean let me make it
very simple here
I give it as B1
through b
5
as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here I'm going I'm specifying the
range to be B1 through B5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay in the
and then I can give another set of range
here
like let me specify it
[Music]
see one
because it will give me an error symbol
colon
C4
and I separated with the comma and I can
specify another range so the next one
will be D1 to D4
and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis I ordered the value that I
give is
let's say
two three zero
and I try to run it
so it gives the value of c 1 through C4
and D1 through D4 as 230 has been
specified in the
code
so this is one of one more example
bearing you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells and with
the VBA
one more thing I can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple just
specify the cells like
oh six
comma seven okay
and I close the parenthesis I assign a
value to it value equals
10. let's see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
Root 6
and concept
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in the sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using BBA so I will show you
how
this is our let's say selector
range
okay and
and I am going to set a dim variable as
a example okay let's say it has example
and um what I'm doing is I'm specimening
a range because I'm going to select a
range of cells okay now I'm going to set
the variable as
set example where I am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected so let's say a one
to the
five
okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going to
set the value okay I am going to set a
value
example
I'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task wherein
you know there is there will be a
scenario where you have to select a set
of cells and give a give a value to it
so you can do it with the click of a
button with a VPN
now I can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so there is
I'll remove this
and instead of assigning a value I'll
just
an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then it's it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or cells with these
groups
now what if I want to do a selection of
the same rows and columns in the next
sheet and I can do this with the
set of another set of commands so I will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing and we specify the worksheets
okay
worksheets
I want it in sheet 2 okay so I just put
it as G2 and I activate it basically
activating it and now I am going to
specify the worksheet
to
and what is the range that I am going to
select the same thing okay
A1
to D5
okay
what I'm going to do I am going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay okay
so here I am selecting the worksheet too
and I'm activating it and I'm going to
assign range and I'm going to select it
so I can just copy the same or select
the same set of cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be as I said
there will be a you know by requirement
where you need to copy some cell
contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that let's uh
again a simple code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a copy
and paste I'm just making it simple by
giving something that we can understand
and relate and copy
[Music]
so what I'm going to do is I am going to
select this range and I'm going to copy
it and paste it somewhere here okay so
let me just remove this
and actually first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again A1
it should be in codes
and I am going to select it okay then
what I'm going to do is uh once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it
okay so I just said that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to place
this selection and you can just mention
the
column here let's say G
uh
10.
okay
close it
I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active sheet
thank you
and paste it so we are selecting a range
of cells
selection and that selection what we are
doing is we will copy it and now we are
going to specify the range where you are
going to
select it and then paste it quite simple
let's
okay see
and
you can just change it to so it is
visible on this
G5
okay
so this makes uh quite easy
and you can run it
the next scenario will be like when you
need to get the count of the number of
cells like you have to have a selection
and you need to count the number of
cells so this can also be done and it's
quite easy
I am going to show it to you
let's say the summary
account
search
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you're using it and
I'm going to set a variable let's say
I'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we will
specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically so I'm going to
set a variable as array and then
what we are going to do is
basically
try the range or your selection where
you count the where you need the count
of the number of cells so even
if the high hopes
now how you want the output you want it
you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give it will give you the
count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples Okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay uh let's see it says
okay here I think and list it so I just
specify the number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of
found in disadventy okay
now let's see I want to
six
selection so it's quite simple it will
be very useful in our daily task and
wherein you need to count the number of
cells so this is one way to get it
uh well I can further tweak this and to
determine the uh the county number of
rows or columns so it's again very
simple I just need to do some changes
here I have to set the
column count
so if I want to
calculate the number of columns
[Music]
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
here
see it gives there are five columns okay
one two
one two three four five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here if I
change it to
should give me
for foreign
you can count the number of rows here
just
G3 says six rows are there
okay
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of cells number of
columns number of rows
with this
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is the if statement a crement is one of
the
most widely used statement and whoever
is in programming are very much familiar
with this function so what it does is we
specify a condition if a condition is
met then the output output should be
such and such we can specify the
condition and it will check whether that
condition is there and if it is
if it is achieved then you will have to
specify the output as well so this can
be achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh English
language so it's not very complicated
and I'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition and if
that condition is met then the result
you specify the condition and the result
okay so this is one thing and then you
can specify the s or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
two then
the result should be
this
so here you are going to specify two
conditions or multiple conditions where
you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or Max
and you have to select the result you
can do this manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
I have it here
okay
let's
I specify as
okay
statement
okay now I have to specify the variables
now I have two available I have a score
and I have a result and the score is an
integer the number and the result is a
string pass of a so I specify this okay
dim
score
as specified as integer okay
and then
there's another variable that I have to
set result
as string
okay
now what the score will be the score I
have to specify the range
score I am giving it as a range admin
yeah
hn9
cell A1
okay
I specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
should be erupt
okay
and then I'm specifying a condition here
if
core value the variable
is greater than or equal so as I said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
English language functions available and
then
the result result is another variable
that I have said result what it should
be it should be
and codes
okay so if this condition is met then
the result will be this okay
and now where I want to specify my
result I should give a range for that as
well so I give it in the next column or
any one
this is the basic uh example
value should be the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
space
change to 40
.
it doesn't give me anything because I
have specified only one condition here
okay
I'm 75 let's see how it turns
see so this way it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifying the
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next uh section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and see so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's stick to the same
values
and now
um I'm going to specify it and if the
score is greater than 60
then the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before and then
I'm going to specify another condition
else
the result should be
should be
okay foreign
[Music]
statement I have to specify the answer
and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be V1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fail
okay please pass let's see
40 and
run it again
foreign
two variables again we are giving it a
range and we are specifying one
condition if this condition is met the
result is passed otherwise else it is
fail
so another set of example
the next statement that we use or we are
going to discuss is the Loop statement
that is the for Loop statement and why
we use it there are there are situations
and uh tasks that you need to execute
and you need to do it several number of
times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first treatment or the function
is executed and the next is taken up so
and then the next and so on so these
Loop statements allow us to execute a
statement or a group of statements
multiple number of times many number of
times and this happens only when the
first task or the first task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we'll discuss a simple
example of the for Loop statement
so let's see how it
works and I'm going to set up a
Loop statement okay again the I'm going
to make it as Loop one
so here it is I have to specify the
variable that is dim
and I'm going to specify X as an integer
okay I'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to 1 2
94 okay let's see and I'm going to
specify the range
as so what I'm going to do is basically
I'm going to fill the column A from 1 to
24 with some value not from 1 to 24 that
the values of 1 through 24 okay
so I'm setting up a range
and How It Ends is it gives me a value
now it execute this and goes to the next
one I'll explain you have it so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up a an
integer a variable X as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here for 1 it executes the first
thing is it it takes X as 1. and it
fills in A1
and then the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to A2 and fills the value as
2 so just let's try to execute this and
you will see the
row column a airplane with 1 through 24.
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as X
and the number of values is going to be
24. okay so this is one basic example of
a Purdue statement
now let's do some more addition to this
uh
example by you know executing another
setup for Loop and giving the output and
we'll code the output to be the color
code advance in the column B so how we
do it it's a basic simple example that
I'm going to take and again what I'm
going to do is I will have this values
here and I am going to calculate the
B column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see
in
what I'm going to do is I'm only going
to change the B
and what action is going here we put a
value now we are going to select it and
with this selection
what I'm going to do is it should select
it and it should color the interior
backward
foreign
X
and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the
box to be colored and I'm going to put
it as a solid
you can fill the whole thing with the
solid
and then I just execute it see
it takes this
color B
and let's code it like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with p
codes and for Loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
we can perform tasks we can perform with
the PBA
and this can be found in detail
in the next process Advanced courses now
at times you might be working on a
really important spreadsheet on your
Excel or you might have the sales data
of your company or some confidential
data of your organization and you might
have shared the file with your junior or
you might face some pocket issue and you
forgot to save or you must to save your
data and what to do if you cannot save
your data and how can you recover it
right so this might be a really big
hassle today we are exactly going to
discuss the same and see how to do it in
multiple ways so Excel comes up with an
option to automatically save the data
also it will try to warn you that your
data is not being saved would you like
me to save it or not right so we'll do
the first one so here you have the auto
save option you can either say ok to it
or you can ignore it in case if you
ignore it if you choose to ignore it or
if you choose to manually save it and
then if you want to close the file
remember we haven't saved the file if
you wish to close it Excel will
automatically come up with a dialog box
asking you want to save your changes to
your
data.xlsx that means it is asking you if
I have to save it or not
let's try to ignore this and forcefully
let's try to close it you can go to task
manager option here we are trying to
simulate the option of Parker tissues
so we are forcefully closing Excel
without saving any data
so we have closed it now here you can
see we do not have Excel running in the
background now when you directly open or
try to start Excel when you get the
power backup again and if you want to
open that same data file it will ask you
the document recovery option it says you
have close the file without saving the
changes and you can choose to you know
come back from the same place where we
left last time okay now that was the
Parker tissue and now let's see uh
another way okay let's imagine that
somebody uh eliminated a few important
data files from your organization's
confidential data employee ID employee
name Etc and again uh let's simulate the
force uh close of the Excel
now we are closing it again without
saving no data was being saved
now it will also ask the same data it
has another version here the original
one which wasn't saved so here you can
recover the same file again however it
was initially so you can save it and it
will get back to the original place
so this was one way also we have another
few multiple ways just we have to
navigate to file and here you can open
and in the open menu you have a button
called recover unsaved workbooks not
just the current workbook it will also
have all the remaining files which are
related to excel that are not saved so
here you have a few workbooks which was
not saved this is one option and we also
have another option we can just navigate
to info and there you have another
option called manage workbook and in the
manage workbook you have another option
called recover unsaved workbooks which
will also redirect you to the same file
that is Microsoft Office and set files
and you'll have all the unsaid workbooks
which are related to excel so this is
how you can recover the unsaved data in
Excel using multiple ways first thing
Excel will automatically ask you if you
have to save the file or not and in case
if you forget to save it you can
directly recover it by default by Excel
it will automatically show that some
folder was not saved on the left side of
your Excel spreadsheet by default and in
case if you missed out on that one you
can manually go to file and you can
either choose open option or info option
to recover the unsaid folders from your
default file location from your page see
that as Microsoft Office and saved files
Etc
which will have all the list of all
unsaved workbooks related to excel Excel
supports a number of shortcut keys that
you can use to speed up your work and
make your work efficient
these shortcuts make working with
spreadsheets a little easier now the
question arises do I need to memorize
the shortcut keys the answer is no
the keyboard shortcuts in Excel helps
you perform data analysis better and
faster but it would be an advantage if
you can remember a few of them
now let's begin by looking at some of
the important workbook related shortcuts
so we will see how to create a new
workbook open an existing workbook and
save a spreadsheet so that you don't
lose any data or calculations that you
have done
towards the end you will see how you can
toggle between different sheets in a
workbook
now to open an Excel workbook on Windows
you can just search for Excel here
you can see
this is the Excel app
and click on it
and you can see there's the Home tab new
tab
from here you can open any existing
workbook as well so let me go to the new
tab and open a blank workbook
a Mark here on the top it says book one
Dash Excel
now if you were to create a new workbook
the shortcut is Ctrl n
now Mark this
so if I hit Control Plus n
you can see it has opened a new workbook
called book 2. I can show it to you here
you can see there are two workbooks book
one and book two
so the shortcut to open a new workbook
is Control Plus n
now if you want to open an existing
workbook that is present in your system
the shortcut is Ctrl o
so if I hit Ctrl o
you can go to browse and check for
your Excel file that is present on your
system let me go to the desktop and
search for
Excel workbooks
you can see I have two Excel files here
let me select the covid-19 file and
click on open
I'll enable editing
there you go
so we have our existing workbook opened
on Excel
now if you want to save a workbook or a
spreadsheet this shortcut is Control
Plus s now this is very simple you use
it in other editors as well
now suppose
I duplicate this column
I use Ctrl C
go on top
and hit Ctrl V
now to save this spreadsheet I'll just
press Ctrl s
you can see the workbook is saved now
you can also click on
this one which says save Control Plus s
so I don't need this column actually so
let me go ahead and delete this column
and now to close the current workbook
the shortcut is control plus W
so if I hit Ctrl W it will ask me do you
want to save this file or not
I'll say don't save and it will close
that current file
next if you want to close Excel
the shortcut key is Ctrl F4
now if I hit Ctrl F4
you can see my book 1 is closed so I can
go ahead and close the workbook
now let me go ahead and open a workbook
again so I'll search for excel
and click on it
I'll go to a blank workbook
now if you want to move the next sheet
you can use control page down
now in this current workbook we have
only one sheet now let me create
two more sheets and come to sheet1
now if you want to move to the next
sheet the shortcut is control page down
so if I hit Ctrl page down you can see I
am in sheet 2 now if I again hit Ctrl
page down I have come to sheet 3.
next if you want to move on to the
previous sheet
the shortcut is Ctrl page up so let me
hit Ctrl page up you can see I am in
sheet 2 now and if I hit Ctrl page up
once again I have come to sheet1
now to get a little more clarity on this
let me open a workbook that has multiple
sheets or multiple tables
so I'll hit Ctrl o and I look for my
sample Superstore data set
click on it you can see
this data set has three tables the first
one is the order stable
the second one is the returns table
which has the detail about the orders
that were returned and the next table is
of people table that basically has
person and the region to which the
person belong to
so let me come to my audits table
if I want to move to my returns and
people table
for that I can hit Ctrl page down which
is to move to the next sheet
so if I hit Ctrl page down see I am in
the returns table now
if I hit Ctrl page down once again I've
come to my people table
if we want to move back I'll hit Ctrl P
job
you can see I am in my returns table
if I hit Ctrl P job once again I have
come back to my audits table
now there are a few other shortcuts that
I want to tell you here
so suppose you want to switch between
different tabs that are present in the
ribbon you can do that as well with the
help of shortcut keys so in Excel this
is the ribbon which has different tabs
like the file tab Home tab insert draw
page layout and so on
now currently we are in the Home tab if
you want to move to the data tab
the shortcut is alt a so if I hit alt a
you can see we have come to the data tab
now
if you want to go to the view tab the
shortcut is alt w
you can see we have come to the view tab
and if you want to move to the formula
tab this output is alt M so if I hit alt
M you can see we have come to the
formula tab
now let me open another Excel file well
we have listed all the shortcut keys
that we are covering in this video
so let me go ahead and do that
so I'll go to file
and under open
I'll click on browse
and
under desktop I look for my Excel
shortcut keys file I'll click on open
so this is the Excel sheet we have
created for you for your reference
you can pause the video to note the
shortcut keys we have covered so far
if you want to get access to this Excel
sheet please share your email address in
the chat section we'll send it to you
over email
so far we have covered all the workbook
related shortcuts so these are the
shortcuts we have covered so far that I
am highlighting here
now let's move back to our slides and
see what we have next
so you can see we have our cell
formatting shortcuts up next
now here I will tell you the different
shortcuts that can be applied to a cell
such as editing a cell aligning cell
contents adding a border to a cell
adding an outline to all the selected
cells Etc
so let's go ahead and do these
operations
so
I'll go to my
book one
and the first shortcut that we'll see is
how to edit a cell
for example
there are certain values such as 10 20
30
and if I scroll down
like this
and now if you want to edit the cells
you can just
select that cell here I have selected
E4 cell you can see on the top and hit
F2 to edit the cell
so if I hit F2
you can see I can edit the cell and make
it say 40. similarly I'll hit F2 again
and make this as 50.
and so on
now you can also edit the formula that
is present in a Cell so let me use a
formula say We'll calculate the sum
and I'll choose
A1 to A8 and find the sum
now if I select this and click on F2
I can change the formula as well
let's say average
I'll hit enter you can see it has
calculated the average from E1
to E8
now if you want to copy paste cells the
shortcut is very simple is Ctrl C and
Ctrl V
now suppose I want to copy
cell A4 I can just hit Ctrl C
and I'll hit Ctrl V to paste it
similarly you can also select a range of
cells and hit Ctrl C
and Ctrl V to paste it
similarly
you can also copy paste
different cells
from other worksheets so I have come to
my sample Superstore workbook and let me
select a few cells
and
I can copy it by hitting Ctrl C I'll
move back
and I can paste it Ctrl V
next if you want to bold and italicize
the font values in a Cell you can use
Ctrl B and Ctrl I respectively
so if I want to bold
suppose
the headings or the column names I can
use Ctrl B
you can see it's bold
and if I want to italicize certain
values let me select this one I can use
Ctrl I to italicize it I'll hit Ctrl I
you can see
it's italicized
now you can also underline the cell
contents so let me show you how to do
that for this purpose we use Control
Plus U
so let me select this cell
and I'll hit Ctrl U you can see
it has added an underline similarly let
me do it for one more cell
I'll hit Ctrl U you can see it has put
an underline to this cell as well
now if you want to fill colors to
certain cells the shortcut you can use
is alt plus h plus h
so let me show you
if I select this cell and hit
alt h h
you can see it has
it has prompted me to select a color
I'll select this blue color
and you can see you have fill the color
to this cell
similarly
you can fill color to a range of cells
as well I have selected these cells and
let me hit alt h h
and this time I'll select this green
color
you can see we have filled all these
cells with green color
now if you want to add a border to a
cell the shortcut is alt plus h plus b
now let me select
this cell for t foreign
h plus b
so it has prompted me to select the type
of border that you want now let me
select I want a top border
you can see
here
it has put a top border to cell B5
and now let me choose cell E6 and again
hit Alt
HB
and this time let's say I'll select all
borders
you can see the cell
has all borders across it
now if you were to remove the outline
border the shortcut is Control Plus
shift plus underscore
so if I want to remove this top border
from cell B5 I'll hit Ctrl shift
underscore
you can see the top border is no more
there similarly
let's remove all border from cell E6
I'll hit Ctrl shift underscore you can
see the border is gone
now if you want to add outline to
selected cells the shortcut is Ctrl
shift plus ampersand
so let me select
the cells that I had colored just now
and if I hit Ctrl shift ampersand
you can see it has added a border
to the selected cells I can show it to
you here as well let me select it
and hit
Ctrl shift am percent
you can see it has added a border
to all the selected cells
another thing I want to show you here is
if you want to move to the previous cell
the shortcut is shift tab so if I select
this cell and hit shift tab it will take
me back to the next cell which is E8 if
I hit shift tab again it takes me to C8
next is B8 then it's A8
now if you want to move to the next cell
the shortcut is tab so if I hit tab
it will take me to the next cell
now
if you want to select the cells on the
right the shortcut is Ctrl shift right
arrow
so initially if I select cell H2 and now
I want to select all the cells on the
right I can just hit Ctrl shift right
arrow so as you can see it has selected
all the cells on the right
similarly if you want to select all the
cells on the left
the shortcut is Ctrl shift left Arrow
as you can see it has selected all the
cells
now if you want to select the column
from the selected cell to the end of the
table
the shortcut is Ctrl shift down arrow
so I'll hit Ctrl shift down arrow you
can see it has selected the entire
column
now if you want to select the data above
the selected cell
the shortcut is Ctrl shift up Arrow so
I'll hit Ctrl shift up Arrow you can see
it has selected all the cells that were
present on top of it
yeah
let me again take you to the Excel sheet
that is all the list of shortcuts
discussed in this video
so I'll go to file
and
I'll open Excel shortcut keys
so now we have looked at all the cell
formatting shortcuts
that I am highlighting
again if you want to get access to this
Excel sheet please drop in your email ID
we'll share it over email
next we'll be discussing about some
additional cell formatting shortcuts
so up next we will see some additional
cell formatting shortcuts
here we will have a look at how to add a
comment to a cell so comments are used
to give extra information about the cell
value
you can also learn how to find a value
and replace it with another value in the
spreadsheet then we'll see how to
activate a filter
insert the current date current time and
also add a hyperlink to a cell
finally we'll see how to apply a format
to the data in a cell
now let me go to my sample Superstore
data set
so this is my sample supposed to data
set
now if I need to add a comment to a cell
the shortcut key I will use is shift F2
so let me select Rosina Hoffman and hit
shift F2 you can see my comment box has
appeared now let me give a comment like
Rosina
is from
LA or Los Angeles you can see brasina
Hoffman he's from Los Angeles now if I
select this you can see
our comment
next
if you want to display find and replace
a value from a cell
or a range of cells you can use Control
Plus h
so let me select Control Plus h
you can see
our find and replace box has appeared
and here
if I want to change the name of say
suppose
brucina
to something like Angela
I'll first select for
brusina
so here I am typing what I need to find
that is prasina and I'll replace it with
Angela suppose
now I'll hit replace all
you will get a pop-up say all done we
made 48 Replacements if I click ok
and select close
you can see
the name Rosina was changed to Angela
Excel is another important feature which
is
to filter your data based on certain
values now
let me show you how you can apply a
filter
so I'll select this city column
and I'll go to my data tab
and here you can see we have filter I'll
choose this
now we have applied a filter to our city
column
to show you more
you can see here it has all the city
name listed
and if I uncheck this select all
and I'll select certain cities and click
ok
it will filter my data only for those
cities
Ctrl Z to undo it
and now
if you want to activate a filter
the shortcut key that I'll use is alt
down arrow so if I held alt down arrow
you can see my activate filter box has
appeared
choose cancel
if I click on a particular cell in this
city column and hit alt down arrow again
you can see the list of cities here
now I'll move back to my
book once
and I'll show you how you can insert the
current date now to insert the current
date in a particular cell
the shortcut I'll use is Control Plus
semicolon
so now if I hit Control Plus semicolon
it will give me the current date
you can see this is our current date
that is 9th of June similarly you can go
ahead and get the current time as well
so the shortcut for that is Ctrl shift
colon so if you hit Ctrl shift colon it
will give you the current time as well
also
Excel allows you to insert a hyperlink
now in order to insert a hyperlink you
can use Control Plus k
so if I hit Control Plus k
you can see the insert hyperlink box has
appeared
now you can give any address here so let
me
go to
Google and
say W3 schools I'll copy this link
and I'll paste it in the address section
and here on the top where it says text
to display I'll write
W3 schools
website
now if I hit OK
you can see we have inserted a hyperlink
and if I click on this it will take me
to the w3schools website
so it opens up in my Google Chrome you
can see this is the w3schools website
similarly let me insert one more link so
I'll go ahead and click Ctrl k
and this time let's say I'll choose
simply learns website
I'll select this website address and
here in the address section I'll paste
the URL and on top I'll write
simply learn website
which is my text that it will display I
click on OK
if I
click on this cell it will take me to my
simply launch website
going back
now I'll tell you how to apply certain
formats so let's see how you can apply a
currency format
so you can see
we have some numerical values here I'll
select this values and if I hit Ctrl
shift dollar
now these numbers have been converted
into
currency format
we have all in the form of rupees
similarly
if you want to
convert a particular cell value say 0.3
into percentage you can use Ctrl shift
and percentage symbol so it has
converted into 30 percent
suppose it's
0.6
and on this if I select Ctrl shift
percentage
it has converted into 60 percent
another shortcut key that you can use is
alt Q or alt plus Q
this will go to the tell me what you
want to do box so if I hit alt Q
you can see
it has taken me to the tell me what you
want to do box if I select a pivot table
it will ask you to give the range
and select where you want to place a
pivot table
I'll hit cancel
now moving ahead
if you have enjoyed watching this video
so far consider subscribing to our
simply learn YouTube channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
let's see what we have next
so now we look at some of the important
row and column formatting shortcuts
here we will learn how to delete rows
and columns hide and unhide selected
rows and columns as well as group and
ungroup rows and columns
I'll
go to my sample Superstore data set
now
if you want to select an entire row
I'll click on a particular cell and if I
want to select
row 7
I'll just hit shift space
so you can see it has selected my entire
row
similarly
if you want to select an entire column
you can hit Ctrl space
so if I hit Ctrl space it has selected
my order date column
now to select the entire worksheet you
can use Ctrl shift space
so I'll hit Ctrl shift space
you can see
it has selected my entire worksheet
now if you want to move to the edge of
the worksheet you can use Ctrl right
arrow
so this is the edge of the worksheet
now
if you want to delete a column you can
use alt plus h plus d plus C or alt h d
c
now let's say I want to delete a
specific column
let me choose a column
say the discount column I want to delete
it so I can use alt HTC
so let me press alt HDC
you can see the discount column is gone
I'll use Ctrl Z to bring it back
now
if you want to delete a row
you can use shift plus space to select
that entire row so let me hit shift
space now I've selected my row 10
and then if I hit Ctrl minus it will
delete row 10.
and see
row ID 9 is deleted if I
undo it
I have it back
moving ahead
now if you want to hide a selected Row
the shortcut is Ctrl 9
so let's say I have selected
row 11 and I want to hide it I can just
use Ctrl 9 to hide it
now you can see we have hidden that
particular row
now if you want to unhide that selected
row the shortcut is Ctrl shift 9 so I'll
hit Ctrl shift 9
to unhide it
you see we have that row back
similarly
he can also hide a selected column
now to hide a selected column let's say
I want to hide
first name column so I can use Ctrl 0.
so if I hit Ctrl 0 you can see we have
hidden the first name column
now to unhide that selected column we
can use Control Plus shift Plus 0.
or Ctrl shift 0
so if I hit Ctrl shift 0
you see the shortcut did not work let me
try it once again Ctrl shift 0 it's not
working
so for that you need to change the
settings by going to the control panel
so let me search for my control panel
I'll select it
and now I'll search for language here
let me
search for language
I'll click on it
I'll go to advanced settings
and then
I'll click on
change language bar hotkeys
in this
here I'll select change key sequence
and then
under switch keyboard layout I'll choose
not assigned and click on OK
I'll apply and click on OK and then I'll
close it
now if I hit Ctrl shift 0 it will unhide
my selected column
moving ahead
now if you want to group rows or columns
the shortcut key for it is alt shift
right arrow
now suppose I have selected
these two
cells and I want to group these cells
so I can hit
alt shift right arrow so you can see the
group box has appeared and I have
selected rows if I click on OK
you can see here we have grouped both
the rows now if you want to ungroup the
rows
the shortcut for it is alt shift left
Arrow so I'll hit alt shift left Arrow
and select rows I'll click on OK
to ungroup the rows
now let me take you back to our
reference sheet
so now we have covered all the row and
column formatting shortcuts that you can
see here
now let me move back to our slides
now we are into the final section of our
shortcut keys here we will cover the
shortcut keys you can use in a pivot
table
in Microsoft Excel a pivot table is a
table of Statistics that summarizes your
data
for example you have sales data for
different regions and for different
products
using a pivot table you can summarize
the data by region and find the average
sales per region the maximum and minimum
sales per region total sales made for
each region and for each category of
products Etc
it allows you to summarize and show only
relevant data in your reports
I'll create a pivot table and show you
different shortcuts to group pivot table
items ungroup pivot table items then
we'll see how to hide pivot table item
create a pivot chart on the same sheet
and create a pivot chart on a new sheet
now let me go to Excel and create a
pivot table using my coronavirus data
set
so
I'll select file and I'll open a file
I'll choose my covid-19 data set
so you can see we have our coronavirus
data set
it has the date column
the day column month year
the total number of cases that have come
up in each country
the total number of debts that were
reported
country territory code
and we have the continent as well
now let me show you how you can create a
pivot table first so I'll select my
table and under insert I'll choose
pivot table
I have my
table range selected then I'll choose
existing worksheet to place my pivot
table
I'll select a cell and click on OK
just squeeze this
and
I'll
sort in this column as well
now
I want to drag
my countries and territories onto rows
so you can see we have
all the countries here
and then
I'll drag
the cases column onto values and
similarly
the deaths column on two values as well
if I close this
and let me squeeze it further you can
see we have our pivot table ready
it has all the country names
and the total sum of the cases and the
total sum updates that were reported in
each country
let's use this pivot table and
apply some shortcut keys now first to
group pivot table items
the shortcut key that I can use is
alt shift right arrow
so let's select a few items from this
pivot table I have selected four
rows and if I hit alt shift right arrow
you can see we have created a group it
says Group 1 and it has
four countries and the total cases as
well as the total number of debts
now if you want to ungroup the pivot
table items you can use alt shift left
Arrow so let me use alt shift left Arrow
so first I have to select this group and
use alt shift left Arrow
you can see we have ungrouped the pivot
table items
now if you want to hide a pivot table
item you can use Ctrl minus
so let's say I want to hide
the values for Afghanistan I'll use Ctrl
minus to hide it
see Afghanistan is no more there in this
pivot table
to unhide let me just use Ctrl Z it's
back
similarly
if you want to create a pivot chart
based on the pivot table on the same
sheet you can use alt F1
so let me hit alt F1
close this
and let me hit alt F1
there you go we have our keyboard chart
ready on the stream sheet itself
so you can see there's a blue line and
there's orange line as well
the Blue Line represents the number of
cases and the Orange Line represents the
sum of deaths
this chart depicts that United States
has the highest number of cases as of
now
and then you can see we have
Hungary Iraq then there's Portugal
and other countries as well
let me delete it
also if you want to create a pivot chart
on a new worksheet the shortcut you can
use is f11 so you just have to hit f11
so let me hit f11 you can see here it
has created a new pivot chart
on another worksheet
it has a sum of the cases and the sum of
the deaths
with that we have covered all the
shortcut keys that can help you speed up
your work in Excel if you think we have
missed out on any shortcut keys then
please put it in the chat section as
well as in the comment section of the
video and with that we have come to end
up this session on data analytics full
course with Excel if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you
require the resources that we used in
this session then please do let us know
in the comment section below and our
team of experts we'll be more than happy
to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here